in this course you will learn how to
build your own design system and improve
your front-end development skills while
building a space travel website with css
guru kevin powell
i am so excited to be presenting you
this project our space tourism project
that we'll be doing together here's an
example or i mean we could look at this
and just look at some screenshots and
these are the different pages we're
going to be looking at or of course we
can just come here and see the actual
page that we're going to be building and
to see the different things and how they
work and if you are in scrimba right now
and you'd like to jump on in and
actually come in and play with this code
this is available to you you can see the
finished result and play around with it
of what we'll be doing and then when
you're done you hit play and then i'll
get back to introducing the course to
you so
yeah those are the pages that we'll be
looking at of course it will be fully
responsive and as we just saw there are
some interactive elements as well with
these tab type systems that we will be
building out
before i get any further into what we're
going to be doing and how we're going to
be doing it though i want to let you
know that this course is a collaboration
between front-end mentor scrimba as well
as myself kevin powell and one thing
before we do get started this course is
not for people at the very beginning of
their front-end journey having a good
base in html is really going to help as
well as experience having already
created responsive layouts with css i'm
not saying that you need to be an expert
in creating layouts we're going to be
breaking things down as much as we can
but i am assuming previous knowledge of
using css and html so i'll break it down
as much as i can and i'll be challenging
you along the way as well
to help reinforce what we're learning to
make sure you have a proper
understanding of it but if you're new to
html and css i do think you'd become a
little bit lost along the way so this
could be something fun to come back to
later once you feel comfortable making a
more complex page also if you do have a
base in javascript or you're comfortable
in javascript it will definitely be
helpful but though it is not a
prerequisite though when we do get into
the javascript parts at least a basic
understanding of it will go a really
long way but you could build out this
entire project with very little
javascript if you wanted to and that's
because there are a lot of different
ways that you can actually approach this
project you could build it only with
html css and a touch of javascript or if
you're more experienced or you've been
learning something like react or vue or
maybe even a static site generator you
don't have to follow along exactly like
i'm doing this i would actually
encourage you not to follow along
exactly as i'm doing things so if you've
just learned a new framework or in the
middle of learning a framework or a
static site generator you can definitely
use this as a really good project to
help reinforce those skills and of
course there is a whole middle ground to
this as well which is more where i'm
going to be focusing things where we're
going to be using vanilla html css and
javascript but we're going to be sort of
going a little bit deeper than a touch
of js to build in a little bit more
interactivity into this project some of
the main topics that we will be doing
and one of the very very big topics of
this entire course is building out a css
design system and to do this we're going
to be creating a lot of our own utility
classes as well as using a lot of custom
properties creating your own css design
system it can seem like a lot of setup
but it's one of those things that in the
real world would be a really useful
thing to have because then everything
else can come together really fast i'm
also going to talk about the balance
between utility classes and component
styles and things like that
and the usefulness of custom properties
in both of them so we're going to be
diving pretty deep into that world at
the beginning of the course for the
layout we're going to be using both
flexbox and grid for this neither one of
them will be too complex but at least a
basic understanding of both of them
could really help you out and it's one
of those things that if you don't have
experience with grid it could be a nice
introduction to it because we're not
doing anything too complex but we are
using some grid lines in some areas and
we will also be using grid areas as well
another really important thing for me in
this course is to look at the
accessibility of the site that we're
going to be building so throughout the
course i will be bringing up and
mentioning accessibility we're going to
be slowly adding in accessibility
through the course so sometimes i might
even do things in a less than ideal way
and that are sort of the common ways
that we see things done and then as we
go through the course i'm going to be
adding the accessibility into it and
making small tweaks to what we've
already created so this is going to
include just writing proper semantic
html as well as getting into role
attributes and area and other things
like that we won't be going in so deep
that it's going to feel overwhelming i
want to show you that proper
accessibility can be added to a project
without things having to be very complex
all that out of the way it is time to
get into the project itself i would
really encourage you to head on over to
front end mentor because this challenge
as we've mentioned already is being
provided by them and it is part of their
new free plus category which means that
everything you could need for this
challenge is included for free including
all the assets jpeg design files for
both mobile and desktop and the sketch
and figma design files so you can click
on over and you can get access to all of
that you can download the starter files
and you can also get the sketch and
figma files that you can download from
here just really quick i use figma
personally so throughout this course i
might be saying you can reference this
in the figma file of course if you're in
sketch you can also reference it from
the sketch file as well but i do say
figma most of the time when i'm
referring to them and if you do want to
jump in and you can just click on this
link that is right here in this slide
and it should bring you to the challenge
page where you can get the starter code
and the sketch files you'll notice
there's also a submit solution button
right here which means when you're done
with this challenge or any other
challenges on front end mentor you can
submit your solution you can also see
other people's solutions and you can
share the link of yours with others to
get feedback on your solution that
you've managed to come up with and so
you can access these files on front-end
mentor this link will bring you right to
that challenge as well and i've also
created a github repo that you can
access the files for so if you're
following along this course with files
on your computer instead of following
along with the files here on scrimba you
can download everything from the github
repo and it's also going to have the
start and ending stage of every one of
the lessons in this course because as i
said i'm going to be offering challenges
throughout the course so that way if
you're not following my exact code you
are doing things in a little bit of a
different way you'll be able to get the
exact code we have for that challenge at
any given time through the github repo
but now it is time to jump into the
actual project itself and get started
with it i'm really looking forward to
this i hope you are as well let's go do
this
all right so as i mentioned in the
introduction the first thing we are
going to be doing is focusing on the
design system itself and that design
system has been provided to us from
front end mentor we can see it here on
this slide and this is what we're going
to start by building because it gives us
an overview of the styling we need for
our entire project or at least most of
it anyway so rather than trying to style
everything page by page we can design
this design system which is going to
allow us to work really fast when we
want to start working on the actual
pages
so how i'm going to be approaching this
first of all is i'm going to be using a
lot of custom properties because they're
absolutely the best and allow us to work
really well and i'm going to show you a
few cool things that we can do with
custom properties to
sort of open up extra doors and things
like that along the way we're also going
to be using a lot of utility classes
because even though it takes a little
bit of time to set them up they allow us
to save a lot of time in the long run
the one thing this design system that
front end mentor has provided us with is
it has all the things we need other than
the layout so i'm not going to worry too
much about the layout even though we can
make a few quick columns and other
things like that along the way and
lastly when we're finished with it like
we won't have all the layout parts that
we need we won't have everything
completely done but we're really going
to be off to a running start and it's
going to enable us to work so much
faster so we're almost ready to dive in
the first thing we're going to do is
create a general reset just because css
as you might know comes with a few
little things along the way that can be
kind of annoying so before we even worry
about the document itself we're going to
create a general reset then we're going
to create some generic utility classes
that i just create on every single
project then finally we're going to dive
into creating the design system itself
and we're going to break down everything
into multiple lessons it's not going to
be one big giant thing i'm going to have
lots of challenges for you along the way
to be taking steps and seeing what you
can do
and then i'll be giving solutions to
those as well as we go through all this
and one really important thing to start
with is we're really starting with blank
files we have nothing here to start with
i haven't brought in the assets or
anything like that yet because we don't
need them we'll bring all of that in
later in the project but one thing i
have done just in case you want to make
your life a little bit easier i have
included this preview.html file in the
design system so if you go into this one
and you just hit run or hit save it
should load it up and you can preview
what the design system looks like here
if you need to get font sizes or get
other things from it because sometimes
when you're looking at it in the slides
my screenshots might be a little bit
small but of course this is just a jpeg
you can't copy and paste things or
anything like that so if you want to be
able to work a little bit faster copy
and paste text you can do all of that
from either the sketch or figma file
which is being provided by front end
mentor so you know that might be a
little bit easier of a way to work but
if ever you need to reference something
really quickly you can reference this
preview.html file if you just need to
grab a few values or something like that
i know i'm anxious to start writing some
code so i'm sure you are too so in the
next lesson we're going to be doing just
that
all right so it's time to work on our
reset and so for that all of the css i'm
writing now is going to go just in my
index.css file because this is the one
that will be controlling our entire site
we're using this across all of our pages
and if you don't already know what a
reset is for it is something that just
helps us make sure we're starting on a
good base before we really get into
anything and i'm going to write a few
things here and then i'm actually going
to encourage you to see if you can think
of a few things you'd want to reset
along the way as well and so the very
first thing i am going to do though is
create a comment here at the top so i
can do that you can just write out the
comment thing or you can use ctrl
forward slash and that will set this up
and i'm going to put a whole bunch of uh
dots here because this is sort of our
dashes i should say as this is going to
create a section for us and here i'm
just going to write reset if you're on a
mac it's probably um command and forward
slash will give you that as well and
then we can create our reset section
here this just makes it a little bit
easier when we're going through our css
file which might get a little bit big to
keep track of everything we're doing and
the first one i'm going to do and if you
want to take a guess at what it might be
before i start it's one of the things i
do on absolutely every single site i
ever work on which is my box sizing and
that is setting my star and then as well
as my star before we're going to be
using quite a few pseudo elements in
this so resetting the box sizing on the
pseudo-elements is important because it
will even though we've selected
everything with the star selector it
does not select your pseudo elements
when you use that so we want to come in
here and just say box sizing border box
if you don't already know this reset
this is one of the most common things
you'll see on any website these days it
just makes calculating the widths and
heights of things much much easier
another one i'm going to do is reset
margins reset margins
and
the one that you usually always see is
the body but i'm also going to include
all of my h2 my h3 which you could go
down to h6 we won't have an h6 on this
project i'm not even sure if we'll have
an h5 to be honest but i'm going to
include it just in case
i'm also going to do my picture
my picture my paragraphs as well as we
will have
picture elements which so we'll just
throw all of these in there
and we're just going to say that they
all have a margin of zero and this is
really handy we're actually going to be
using different ways to reintroduce
spacing and one of the most frustrating
things with css is collapsing margins
when everything has a margin top and
bottom of it so we're gonna see it
simple ways that we can sort of
reintroduce spacing without having to
worry about things like collapsing
margins um and there's a few other
things that i'm gonna bring in here in a
second but i want you to try and think
of a few things that you might reset or
common resets that you do so throw them
in here create a bit of a reset yourself
you can see sort of the types of things
i'm trying to bring css to something
that is a nice place to start from so
see if you can think of anything that
you've seen or things that you commonly
use in projects and then we can compare
that to what i end up doing in mine so
yeah you can go at it and in a few
seconds i'll finish this up on my end
all right so i'm going to keep on going
here and i'm actually going to take a
second before i do that just to come up
here and in a comment i'm going to put
this which um is andy bell's modern css
reset and this is something that i use a
variation of in all the projects so this
is actually a variation of that um that
i'll be using i won't use everything he
has but this is a really nice starting
point for resets if ever you just need
something to copy and paste into your
projects uh quickly you can't go wrong
with this one there are other ones that
you could use like just the the hard
reset where we just strip everything
down by eric meyer there's also things
like normalize and sanitize as well
those are also great places to work from
but i sort of want to take advantage to
explain a few of the things that i'm
doing in here and there's not too much
that comes into this so i think it's a
few important things to address when
we're starting to write our css and so
now we can jump in and let's just say
set up the body
and i'm only going to do two things here
i'm going to say that we want to do a
line height and on most projects i do
it's either a 1.5 or a 1.6 because the
default for browsers is 1.4 which tends
to be very very small so i'm going to go
with the 1.5 and we can always adjust it
from there and we're just going to do
that as our quick reset for now and i'm
also going to set a min height here of
100 vh and that just sets the stage to
prevent any short pages from being an
issue and especially in the designs that
we're building for this project a lot of
them there's no scrolling that's
happening so this just sets the stage
and makes life a little bit easier on
that another one that we're going to
want is make images easier to work with
and if you don't already know images
sometimes there's a few defaults on
images and because we are using the
picture element as well we'll select
both of those and we're going to say a
max width of 100 which just helps us
make them nice and easy to work with as
well as a display of block
so this just helps us deal with the
little
spacing sometimes issues that you can
get on images from time to time and the
max width 100 here is a nice step to be
taking and it just ensures that the
images will shrink as the viewport gets
narrower or the space they have to live
in gets narrower we also want to come in
and just you know make make forms make
forms easier to work with
and that's just because any or form
element i guess um forum
elements i should write because a lot of
these and we're not we're going to be
using buttons but it's just you know
this is forward thinking if ever other
stuff gets added so
and select destroy font and do inherit
and the nice thing with doing this uh
because we will be using buttons on here
by default buttons and all these form
elements don't inherit the font
properties which is a nightmare because
font properties are inherited everywhere
else so that just simplifies our life a
little bit and this last one is a remove
animations for people who've turned them
off and this one i have copied so i'm
going to paste it in
and this is using the preferred reduced
motion media query which means if
somebody's taking the time to turn off
animations within either their browser
settings or at the os level that this is
going to disable animations and
transitions for them and this is a
really important thing that we can do to
deal with accessibility because there
are a lot of people out there who motion
causes problems and that motion could be
parallax scrolling it could be constant
movement on things as you're scrolling
the scroll linked animations all these
different things for a subset of the
population
it can make them nauseous it's going to
make them leave your site it is an
unpleasant experience for them it can
cause nausea and it's just something
that they don't want to have to deal
with they've taken the time to turn it
off in their browser or at the os level
and we should respect that and we can do
that really easily with this media query
here
there is also the option of a no
preference here which we're not going to
use because this means they haven't
disabled it
but that is a way that you can add
animations in only if somebody is
allowing them so there's the two
different ways that you can work but
just as a really quick solution here
we're going to be throwing that in right
there and that is it for my reset and
everything we're going to be using as a
hard reset there are other things that
we often need resets for that i haven't
included in here but we'll either be
overwriting those ourselves with our own
css or it's things that we don't
actually need for this project so with
that done in the next video we're going
to start writing a few utility classes
all right time to write some utility
classes and in case you're not familiar
with the term uh utility classes are
something to do one thing and they do
that one thing very well that means that
often those only have one declaration
and by declaration i just mean like it'd
be color red so i'm declaring it's the
property value pair is a declaration but
sometimes they can have multiple when we
need to as long as it's still just doing
that one job and doing it really well
we'll see an example of that in this
video and this allows things to be much
more modular and allow us to write a lot
less code in the long run
you might already be familiar with them
if you know of something like tailwind
we're not going all out and creating an
entire library of utility classes for
this finding a nice balance between
utility classes and more component based
classes is a really good way to work and
we'll be exploring that more as we go
through this but having a nice set of
utility classes to start with can be
very very useful so let's dive in and
actually start setting up these and the
first thing i'm going to do is actually
go all the way to the top and copy the
reset that i have here so i can bring
this all the way down and make a new
section of my css which is going to be
my utility classes
and now we can start working and so the
first thing to do is create a flex
utility class and we're going to do a
display of flex on there and as you can
guess that's that's one of those ones
that i mentioned it's one declaration it
does one thing it does it very well and
we're also going to come in with a grid
one and that one will set up a display
of grid
and this is one place though where we
can actually take things a little bit of
a step further
and it's an interesting way where we can
get utility classes to work with
components and it's to take advantage of
custom properties a little bit
and if you're not familiar with this way
of working with custom properties it is
something i'm going to explain much more
because we're going to be using this
quite a lot through this
and that is i'm going to come here and
write gap and actually we can do this on
both of them so i'm just going to hold
down alt on my keyboard and select both
sections right there so just by clicking
and alt clicking in multiple places if
you're on a mac that might be option or
it might be alt i'm not sure because i'm
on windows so i apologize for that and
flex now has gap support this is a
modern css approach which is really nice
safari now has support for it which was
the last major browser that we were
waiting on for this and so i'm going to
do a gap and you could do like a default
of 1m but i don't want to do that what
i'm going to do is a variable of gap we
don't have a gap custom property and
this is something again that is going to
come back a little bit later and i'm
going to explain more of how it works
and i'm going to set a default of one
rem for that it's going to allow us to
use this custom property but really
easily tweak it when we're setting up
our different utilities like our
navigation or a few of the other things
as well where we need to use flex and
grid and there's a few other things we
could do with these um it is common to
see things like fl align items justify
items justify content and those types of
other things set as utility classes and
for this layout i don't personally see
the need for it but if it is something
where you see that being something that
could be useful you could go ahead in
your own version and add utility classes
for some of those i'm only going to make
two more generic utility classes in this
lesson and then we're going to be going
into ones that are more specific before
now for these generic ones i only have
two more and the first one is going to
be a container and i'm sure you're
familiar with either a container or a
wrapper and if you are i want you to
write your own and then i'm going to
show you my own version of it and i want
you to see if it's actually the same as
what i would do don't just think it in
your head take the time to write it out
think of all the different properties
you might need on something like this
because this is one of those utility
classes where you definitely need more
than one declaration to really make it
worthwhile as far as what width to use
don't worry too much about the maximum
width on it
just as long as you have a value in
there and then i'll show you my own
solution in a few seconds
all right so the very first thing i'm
going to do is i'm going to write
padding and very often you'll see
something like padding 2m0 and i'll show
another solution here that we could also
use for this
which means no padding on the top and
then 2 on the left and the right which
just prevents things from like touching
the side of the page which can obviously
be very useful
another way that we can do this with
more modern css is actually to use
padding inline and then come in with qm
scrimba is underlining this right now
because this is a new css property it's
called a logical property and what it's
doing is looking at the inline axis of
my container so it's gonna be the left
and the right side and not the top and
the bottom and even though scrimba is
sort of complaining about this as well
as gap here don't worry it's going to
work even in the scrambler previewer
that we're going to be using and it's
also something that's supported in all
the major browsers now so browser
support as long as you're only worrying
about newer browsers there's no issues
with it at all and i'm going to come in
and write a max width i said not to
worry we're going to start with 80 ram
and maybe we have to modify that and
that could be somewhere where you
actually use a custom property for this
instead but we're going to stick with a
set number
just because i want to be consistent
between all of my pages and the last
thing i need is my margin auto to hold
the content in the middle of the page i
only need the margin on the left and the
right side so can you guess and maybe
write the line of code now similar to
our padding that would work with our
margin
and so hopefully you thought of or wrote
margin in line of auto which once again
is going to be my margin left and my
margin right and it just doesn't set any
value to the top and the bottom even
though you generally don't run into
conflicts with these this could
technically prevent conflicts and the
last thing i'm going to include in my
reset for now is an sr only class which
are super super useful i'm going to
paste it in because there's quite a bit
in here
this is a really common
utility that you're going to see which
is screen reader only and what that
means is it's only for assistive
technologies that are reading the page
to somebody if they're visiting the page
and you know they're visually impaired
and let's say we have content on a page
that might be say a button that doesn't
have any text in it but visually it's
very clear what that button does so
somebody who is a sighted user can see
it and know if i click this this is
what's going to happen but if it's a
screen reader who's reading through the
content on a page it's just going to
announce that there's a button there and
the user is going to have no idea what
that button does if there's no text in
it so we can use this to visually hide
content for sighted users but then keep
that content in the page as something
that's actually there so if a screen
reader comes across it it can give that
extra context to the users that are
using those assistive technologies it's
a very easy thing to do and we're going
to be using it in several different
places throughout this project
so in the next lesson we're going to
dive in and start creating our own
utilities but first before that i want
you to get a little bit of practice
using these ones that we've created
right here so i'm going to jump over to
the html file and this is just sort of a
standalone we'll delete everything
that's in here once we're done uh but
you can see i've created a few
challenges for you and i want you to
hold the content in the middle of the
page wrap it either in a flex or grid we
have our utility classes for that try
changing the gap variable without
modifying the original or gml utility
class and to use the sr only class on a
div to see what happens and by this one
what i mean is find a way to modify this
variable here
without actually coming onto here and
changing it see if you can find a
different place you can change it and to
get a different gap than the default one
rem that's on there and you might be
saying what content so i'm going to come
and give you some really quickly
so there's the content we're going to be
working with really nothing too fancy
but i will come down into the css and
just give them a little bit of style and
again we won't have any of these this
i'll make sure all of this is cleared
out before the next lesson but just a
little bit of practice and this will
help so i'm just going to give the dot
box a background color of light blue so
we can actually see something and i'll
give them a padding of three rem just so
we have something that we can work with
and i'm going to click run over here
just so we can see that we have some
boxes that are coming in so why don't
you go ahead and try following each one
of these things here if you get stuck on
any of them or you're not sure don't
worry i'm going to give my own solution
to all of this in just a second but i'd
like you to try it out first
all right so i hope that went well and
some of these might have been easier
than other international class container
and we can just wrap all of this here
and close
div over here and let's just fix my
quotation mark
and by doing that and then we'll hit tab
we should see now that my content is
held in the middle of the page when
we're at larger screen sizes and then as
we go to these smaller sizes it's
shrinking but we have that two rem gap
on the side so our content is never
touching the edge and 80 is a little bit
big for scrimba so just to show you if
you did run into this and you couldn't
see it if you are using the scrimba
editor i will drop this down to 60.
just so we can see that we do hit a
point where we get to that maximum size
and then it holds it at that size right
there so for this lesson i'll keep this
at 60 but when i get back to the next
one i'm gonna pump that back up to 80.
the next thing that i wanted to do was
to wrap the content in either a flex or
the grid class so if you created a new
div to put all of this in that's
perfectly fine or because it is a
utility class we could put it here it
really depends on circumstances it's not
too often that i end up doing something
like this but it would work
we need to have them set up in the flex
or if i switch it over to grid we can
see that it will be in a grid and the
grid the default for it doesn't actually
make columns or anything so we just have
these guys stacking on top of each other
but we can see that the gap property is
working and again if we switch that back
over to flex we can also see that the
gap property is working there and it's
creating these spaces in between them
the next thing we want to do is try and
change that gap variable without
modifying the original utility class and
there's two different approaches you can
take to this one of them which is
popular is actually using inline styles
and within an inline style we can just
say gap and change this to say five ram
which would make it quite a lot bigger
and now we get a bigger gap between them
and this will also work if we had that
as a grid and then you can see the
spacing has increased vertically
this is a popular one and the nice thing
with this is it's easy just to create
like a one-off modification
of that custom property that you created
so if you had the same type of thing
being used in multiple places and this
is just one off you don't really want to
create a different class for it
you can have that set up and then we can
have our smaller gaps that are appearing
over here these two are stuck together
because it's there's no gap between this
big div and this div over here um but
yeah it's just a quick way to make a
one-off style it's become actually quite
popular and you'll see it used a lot
some people don't like the idea of
in-line styling things just because then
you know maybe you can't find what's
actually controlling it or why those
gaps are bigger than they were uh before
so the other way that you can do it and
let's just pretend instead of in this
situation we're working on this little
very simple grid but let's just say that
this was actually a like a different
component so we had a container a grid
and then say this was like my call to
action call to action
and in that case what you could do is in
your css you're writing all of your
styles for your call to action so say
you give it a background that's ping and
the padding on it is to rem and it has a
border radius
of one ram and don't forget your
semicolons and of course call to action
i actually wrote it out uh so there we
go we can see it's actually coming in
and it's working
so in a situation like this where you
have something like that what you could
do is come on here and actually say gap
and change the property here and i can
make it five rem and then it's going to
actually modify it within that class so
two different ways that we can modify it
we'll be taking advantage of the inline
style way of doing it especially within
our design system since that's a lot
more one-off things and generally
speaking i like working this way but
both of them work perfectly well and are
valid ways to work so just a fun cool
way we can do that and one last thing
before i let you go is i did want you to
try and use the sr only class so let's
get rid of our call to action here
because that pink is not working and
then i'm going to come on this a box and
say sr only and if i hit save it is
visually gone it's completely pulled out
of the flow we don't see it anymore but
if you were to look in the dom it would
still be there and a screen reader would
still be able to access it so it's not
like a display none a display nun takes
it out of the dom that is no longer part
of your page this sr only class we've
created leaves it in the dom it just
fully visually hides it so there we go a
quick little rundown on these ones we've
created now we can jump on in to
creating our colors and if you want to
play around with things a little bit
especially maybe this way of
manipulating things just make sure that
you're used to it if it's something new
that you haven't seen before do that
first play around with it get used to it
and then i'll see you in the next lesson
when you're ready
all right so it's time to start working
on the color section of our design
system and this is what we're going to
be setting up right here and just before
we dive into it you'll notice that we
have the values in hex as well as rgb
and hsl and i'm going to recommend
either that use rgb in hsl and i'm
actually going to set things up in a
very particular way when i do it and
i'll explain why as as i go through it
all
but there the advantage of rgb and hsl
values with hsl actually it's the
easiest one to make modifications to but
in this case we don't need to because we
have all the colors that are being given
to us but there is a trick in using
custom properties with hsl or rgb that
allows us really easy ways of tweaking
the alpha value when needed which we're
going to be using quite a bit in this
project with how i'm going to be
approaching it
and so i'm going to leave the this slide
up just because we're going to actually
move away from having this jpeg here and
what i would recommend that you do is
actually go to the original design files
at this point and instead of referencing
this because instead of looking at this
file i've created this design
system.html which is where we're going
to be working from so we have a nice
blank page to start with
and before we even get started with
anything we do need a little bit of
content in here which would help us out
so i'm going to start things off by
coming in and giving us that give class
of container to hold everything that we
need and i'm going to close my div
and i'm not going to worry so much about
the title let's just throw an h1 here at
the top of design system
i'm not going to worry about i know it
has the logo and the design system on
the right side in the actual design
system but i'm just going to throw this
here for now because the one i'm really
worried about is our section which we'll
call colors
and i'm just going to use an id on here
not that we really need it but you could
include links somewhere if you want to
easily get through between these
different sections
and so we can close our section there
usually i always recommend writing the
html for something first but in this
case i'm actually going to recommend
that we come in and do our css first and
if you remember i said that i like
having hsl or rgb
so i would really recommend that and i
am going to set everything up all the
way at the top here
we're going to create this custom
properties section at the top here and
if you're comfortable with custom
properties what i want you to do is
create the custom properties we need for
the three colors we're going to be using
and again choose either rgb or hsl for
this because i do want to show you a
trick that we'll be doing if you've
never used custom properties before then
you can wait for my solution in just a
couple of seconds
all right we only have three colors and
when i do custom properties i do like
prefixing if it's a color with color and
if it's a font size with fs and other
things and we'll see why as i work
through this project
um in this case we only have three
colors and it sort of breaks from how i
normally like to name things so i'm
actually going to name them
and then color white and
it's really different from how i
normally do things but we really only
have three colors that we need to work
with and then it's varying like alpha
values on them
and this is where it's very common to
see something like hsl and then you come
in with the numbers and this is again
i'm looking at modern css so we're going
to do it the modern way 35
where you don't need commas anymore and
7
um so we can write that without commas
it's very it's perfectly valid with the
new color syntax and again it is
supported in all modern browsers and the
advantage with writing it like this is
you can come in and do a slash and like
0.5 and that would be your alpha value
but
the issue is if we store it like this in
a custom property we lose the ability to
manipulate that alpha value very easily
and there are ways you could do it with
another custom property and sort of play
around with things and get clever with
it but what i actually like doing is
storing this value as my custom property
instead which might look a little bit
weird but i'll explain why in a second
but first i'm just going to fill out
these two really quickly
all right so we have those there and now
to explain how i'm going to use them
when they're just values like that let's
go down and create those custom property
colors so i'm going to come here and
we'll create a colors section
just like that and i'm calling it a
color section so here's our general
classes and then underneath that we can
have our colors which are all utility
classes
and you might also be wondering at this
point like why would i make utility
classes as well as custom properties and
i'm going to explain as we go through
the course why i would do that so let's
start with a bg dark and i'm going to
say that that means the background color
is the value that i wanted but remember
i'm using the hsl values so i'm actually
going to write hsl like this and then
inside of there i'm going to write my
variable color dark
and
we can do that and what that means is
and this will enable us to use it so
just to show you that working i'm going
to come over to my design system on the
body here i'm going to give that a class
is equal to bg dark i'm going to hit
save and the background has changed over
to that color
and so what i'm going to do is challenge
you now to create
background class for the three different
colors we have and another class that
will set up the text color for the three
different colors that we have as well
all right so what i'm going to do is
just copy this and paste it and paste it
so we can work a little faster and you
know what i'm actually going to paste it
again here because i'm going to be doing
my bg dark and what i'm going to do is
actually change all three of these so
again i'm holding alt down and i'm going
to call these text dark what i actually
like doing on something like this i'm
going to select both of these and it's a
little weird because i did do
a color of light and here i'm going to
call it color accent just because i'm
funny that way and how i like to name
things but
um that's what i'm going to do and then
this one we will do a color white and
i'm just going to update these so they
match everything that we have
i almost left this here using background
colors on all these and that would have
been a little silly of me and while we
have enough to get started in creating
what we have on the screen right now
before we do that i have a little bit of
a challenge for you and we'll see that
challenge in the next lesson
so before we start building this out and
give you a little bit of practice i want
to give you a little bit of a challenge
first that's also going to explore the
alpha value thing that i was talking
about with our custom properties so
the first thing i want you to do is to
give this first div here a light blue
background and a dark text color this
second one here we're going to give it a
white background and we're going to give
it a dark text color and this is only
using the utility classes that we've
created so far and this third one is
going to be a little bit different
in that we can't necessarily use one of
our utility classes for it but i want
you to give that third div a light blue
background but with an alpha value of 20
and with a white text in there and so i
already gave you a little bit of a hint
for that third one and so i'm gonna
recommend you dive in and see what you
can do with it and if you haven't played
with custom properties too much this
last one might be a little bit tricky
but see what you can do with it anyway
and if you get stuck i'm going to be
giving my solution here in just a few
seconds
all right so i'm going to come on this
first guy we're going to give this one a
class and we want to give it a class
light blue background i call that bg
accent so we can use that and then the
dark text color we can just do a text
dark and let's save and go take a look
and we can see it's working right there
then we can jump onto this next one
right here and i'll give this one a bg
of white and my text dark
and we can see that one is also working
fantastic and we have one more to do and
this is the tricky one
and so if you tried this
if we use the i'll do the white text so
text uh
white and we can see that that text
color has indeed changed but for the
background color i can't use the bg
white on this one for this one i will
have to create my own class for it and
so i'm just going to write example for
now um and this is going to come in
we're going to be using it for actual
components and you'll see how this can
actually really play into things really
really well as we go through and build
out actual components with this so maybe
even example component might be a better
name component and this can work whether
it's a text color or whether it's a
background color and it's going to be
something that we use quite a lot
actually through this project so i want
to make sure you understand how it works
so we're going to jump over here to my
css and i'm going to do
example component and on that example
component we need to do something so i'm
going to say that we have a background
color that makes sense i think and
obviously we have our hsl and i want it
to be the light color and
that's the the light blue and if i just
do that right now let's hit save and go
take a look and it has the regular light
blue background on there and i mentioned
that we can change the opacity on it so
if you got stuck before and now you
might have a little memory of how to do
it why don't you try and do it and if
not
or if you don't remember i'll show you
the solution in just a second
and so before i show you the solution
let's just go back up and look at what's
happening here and to really grasp what
we're doing so this is the value that
i'm grabbing right there and i'm going
to come down
and so writing this is the same thing as
writing
that just like that these are doing the
exact same thing i'm just going to
change the number here to 150 just so we
can see that it does change
so we go look we can see that it's now
that green color because i changed my
degrees here and i mentioned that one
thing we can do with hsl values is we
can do a forward slash and then change
the opacity of it
so i can go take a look and now we can
see we have the lighter color that's
come through it's a lower opacity
because we can see the blue color is now
starting to come through i can drop that
down to 0.1 and we can see that it's
almost gone to the same color because
it's so faded out so remember when i do
the var color light what that's doing is
it's just inputting these three values
right here so it's the exact same thing
as taking this deleting that and putting
that in there
so that means we could leave this here
and delete this right here
and i could leave this exactly like that
but then i could do a forward slash and
then choose an alpha value so dot 0.2
because we wanted a 20
alpha value and we can see that it's
working just like that so if you want to
play around with this experiment with it
a little bit just to make sure that
you're really understanding how it works
go ahead and do that and then when
you're ready i'll see you in the next
lesson
so we know how the utility classes are
working and we're starting to get into
that flow of things so what i'm actually
going to do here is i'm going to create
a div
and on this div and we're going to do a
closed div right here and i'm going to
use this div to make one of these guys
right here and one thing that is
important with this is
there's a few styles in here that are to
if we want to match what this actually
looks like that are important for this
one place that would not be used in our
actual page like these little color
samples with the border that is on them
because those borders don't exist
there's extra padding on here and stuff
like that so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to start by coming in here with a
div and i am going to give this a style
so it's an inline style for my style i'm
going to give it some padding of three
ram on the top and one ram on both sides
and one ram on the bottom and next up
i'm also going to give this a border of
one pixel solid and i'll put white even
though i know uh or i'm pretty sure it's
not actually white and actually let's
close that div and let's go see what
that looks like so i'll hit save and you
can see a big box has come in and it's
stretching all the way across the page
which is perfectly fine
and then here i would have two
paragraphs so paragraph close paragraph
and we need another one underneath that
and i'll just bring the content in here
really quickly so that content is all in
place now but obviously we can't see
anything that's on there and we need to
make this come to life a little bit so
what i would challenge you to do now is
actually see what you can get done on
this without seeing anything more for me
but i will show you my solution to this
one in a few seconds but hit pause try
and get everything just the colors
matching we have background color we
have text colors on these and if you
have the time you can also go through
and do these other ones as well just
don't worry about the numbered title
here because i have a specific lesson on
that as we're going to take a little bit
of a different approach to it but i do
think you can get this one done pretty
easily so i'm going to leave this one
for you and then in a few seconds i'll
show you my solution
all right so for my solution if you
didn't take this approach is perfectly
fine but i'm actually going to go up on
my body and put a text
white on there just so we can actually
see our text everywhere which makes life
a little bit easier and whenever i can
apply something on the body and let that
cascade down i'm always going to take
advantage of that
and so the next thing i want to do is to
go on this div right here and we can
give this a class and we don't need to
give it the bg dark because we have abg
dark on the body obviously so we don't
see that difference but i'll throw it on
there anyway and a text white so if i
hit save i can see it's working and the
text has changed and if i took off my
text dark and we hit save you can see
it's still working and i can still see
that there
so that's the main reason i just want to
show if somebody's looking at my design
system that they'll see those two
classes that are on there
down here we can come on and we don't
need the text of light but we do need to
put a span here so on both of these we
can add an opening span and we can come
on both of these and do a close span
just like that and if you weren't sure
you got stuck there and now you know
what to do well we just have to come in
and add our class of text accent
and then i can do the same thing on that
one hit save and we can see that the
different color has come on that and
that is pretty much what we needed to do
for this one but my next challenge would
be i'll copy this for you
and paste it so if you didn't already do
all of them we do want to get all three
of these guys done and there's an extra
challenge of getting them to go next to
one another and i'm not going to give
you the solution to that not in this
video and not in the next one either
because in the next one we're going to
get into the typography so try your best
at solving this getting it all set up
getting used to using the utility
classes and if you can't get things to
go next to each other or there's an
issue with something else you can always
look at my finished code which will be
available to you in that next lesson so
when you're ready i'll see you over
there
all right so time to dive into the
typography and things are going to move
pretty quickly here where we're going to
build out this section here not worrying
too much about the spacing but we can
get all of this set up and looking
pretty good
and pretty quickly once we have our
utility classes created but one thing i
really want to make sure when we're
doing this is remember utility classes
do one thing and one thing really well
so we want to make sure that we break
things up so everything is doing just
one job and here we can see i have a
font family i have a font size and on
some of the styles we also have
character space which is your letter
spacing
and
everything becomes more plug and play if
we actually separate these into their
own classes rather than having them act
as one thing and especially the font
family and the
pixel value you're going to see like
that repeats itself over multiple ones
so it becomes very easy just to create
utility classes that make all of this
very plug and play this also allows us
to write more semantic html and by
semantic html i mean our headings can
actually do the job that a heading is
meant to do rather than the heading
styling something if your h5 like this
one is linked to a very specific style
that could actually cause for on
semantic html later on because you might
be using an h5 somewhere you shouldn't
be using it or maybe you're using an h1
when you actually
or maybe you're using an h2 on something
that should be in h1 or you know there's
a lot of different situations that come
up like that so do not pay attention to
the heading levels that are here we're
going to break things up as much as we
can and just like before we're going to
start that up here
in our custom properties and so i'm
going to add colors here we don't really
need it but we can add colors and then
here i'm going to write fonts and what
start with font sizes actually font
sizes
and there are a few important things one
of them is i like doing fs as you might
have guessed and setting things up with
400 being my base size and when i say
base size what i mean is the body text
size so this here it's not actually
listed right here in this screenshot but
it's actually size 18 and the font the
font family for it's actually this
barlow regular it's not a condensed
version of it
so that's sort of where i like starting
my base and then as we go smaller i go
like here is a 16 18 to 16 that would be
my font size 300 my font size 200 so
this is like font weights and the font
weight system which goes the lighter you
get the smaller the number and then the
bolder you get the bigger the number so
this would be my four my three my two
and then my four then this is the next
one up so five six seven eight nine and
that works really well with the system i
like because i really like going in with
that type of idea and i've already
have these ready and i don't think you
want to watch me write them so i'm just
going to plug them in and one thing
you'll notice is i am using rems for
these rather than using the pixel values
that are given here and this is once
again for accessibility reasons because
if you were to use pixels it could
potentially overwrite settings that the
user has put into place to give
themselves a bigger or potentially
smaller default font size and if they've
taken the time to do that we want to
respect that they've played with their
settings a little bit and if you use
pixel values depending on how they've
set things up zoom levels are different
but if they've done other system
settings or browser settings
pixel values could potentially overwrite
that and then their font sizes could be
smaller than they want and then they
leave your site so it's very easy to see
whatever values you see on the slides
and just divide by 16 to get the numbers
that you have here and because we're
using custom properties i feel no need
to do that html
62.5 on the font size to reset things
like a base 10 working from base 16 when
you only have to worry about things once
it doesn't make things that complicated
because you're not remembering these
strange values you're just remembering
five six seven eight or nine hundred i'm
also going to speed things up a little
bit for you here by coming in and
bringing in the font families as well
just because again writing the custom
properties here there's no you know i
don't think you'd be learning a ton from
it and we're going to be looking at how
we can turn all of these into our
utility classes and that's where the
challenges are going to come so you can
see here i've set up these three
which is my
font family serif which is my serif one
my saw serif condensed barlow condensed
and then my font family songs normal
which is barlow's serif
and all of this already i've also taken
the time to go to google and get the
links to everything that we need right
here so the google fonts are linked in
the design system they're not in their
index but we're not there yet anyway
and so we have everything that we need
to get started and create some things
and then start applying them in our page
now you'll notice one thing i didn't do
is turn the letter spacing ones into
custom properties
um this could be just if you think you
would need them as a custom property by
all means go ahead and set them as
custom properties i think we can just
set those as utility classes but just
because i don't see those changing very
much uh down the road i think they're
very locked in values by the looks of it
but if you prefer them as a custom
property there's no issue with that
whatsoever
but having things like this that could
potentially change
as custom properties is always a good
thing and you'll see what i mean shortly
as we play with this site a little bit
and instead of challenging you here to
actually create all of these because
once again we're going to have a whole
bunch of them and they're just pretty
much taking the custom properties i've
done and switching them over i'm going
to place them in here for you and then
challenge you to actually use them so
here's all of the
utility classes for the typography that
i think are going to be useful
and so we have our different font
families that we can control here we
have our letter spacing ones that we can
control here and so it's the biggest to
the smallest then we have my uppercase
which is something that's not actually
listed but if we come and look a lot of
these are uppercase but every now and
then you might not want an upper case so
i created an uppercase one just to make
it easier to make changes because it
sucks coming in and actually trying to
like retype something in your html to
get it to be uppercase so this is a very
handy little utility class we have all
the font sizes set here and i've also
come in and changed the line height on
these bigger font sizes just because uh
the line height when the lines break
gets really really ugly so i've taken
the time to go and make that change
right there and one thing we're going to
do before actually starting to use these
just to speed things up a little bit if
you look through all the different pages
that are supplied in the design there is
one thing that we can do that's going to
help a little bit and cut down on some
extra stuff we're doing is when we set
up our body here and so the first thing
i'm going to do on here is set my font
family and there are different ones we
can do but the nice thing with this is i
can do a dash dash and i know you can't
see it on your screen so i'm going to
get you to practice it or try this out
in a second but as soon as i do that i
see all of my custom properties and then
i can put ff and it's only going to show
me the ones i prefixed with that and in
this case i'm going to choose the size
normal just because that's the one that
is on my body and that's you know my
paragraphs and my regular body text so
i'm going to put that on my body
you could make a case on the site to put
this as the condensed because you might
actually have to use less utility
classes along the way but i'm going to
do it like this
and then what i want you to do is try
this out so we also have a font family
another one we need is the font size and
if you remember my font size is the 400
is the default so what i want you to do
is pause the video now and do the double
hyphen and see the whole list that comes
up here in scrimba and this will be the
same in text editors like vs code do the
double hyphen you get the full list do
your prefix fs for font size and then
you only see the font sizes and then you
can just choose the one that you want
from there so i'll give you a second to
try that out and then we'll look at a
couple of other little adjustments we
can make before we start using all of
this
great so i hope you saw how nice that is
so that we have my font size and we said
we want the 400 on there so i can do
that it auto populates it just by
selecting it and we're starting to be
off and running
there are two other properties that i'm
actually going to add to here and that
is it would be kind of annoying if we
had to always come in and add this on
every single one of them and these
utility classes work great but setting
that every time on the body is a little
bit annoying so i'm actually going to
remove them we're going to come back
into here and we're going to add them
here so if you want to do that to get a
little bit more practice with the double
hyphen just seeing how it populates
making sure you're comfortable with it
you can do that right now and in one
second i'll add my own in
alright and you might have had a little
gotcha there along the way and that
would mean that you would have had to
have remembered that we actually need to
because of how i've set things up wrap
things in the hsl because i did things a
little bit differently and so here on my
color instead of just doing the custom
prop i'm going to do my hsl and then i'm
going to choose my color light
just like that and then on my background
oh i don't want light i want color white
actually
and then
on the background color
we can come and do the same thing hsl
and choose my color dark and there we go
that should set things up nicely there
we go we can already see it's come back
and it's starting to work so that's
fantastic all right and with that set up
we can come over and i'm going to do one
thing really quickly because we're going
to see there's one more problem that
we're actually going to run into and
before we get into that next section i
can start using some of those classes up
here and on here and i just want to
highlight what the problem is going to
be so actually here we have our design
system i'm going to come on and give
this a class is equal to font family
serif and i know we don't need to do
that but you might notice and maybe it
looks okay for you but the rendering of
things looks a little bizarre on my end
and if we look here every single heading
level is not using a bold which is the
default and because i didn't include the
bold from google fonts because we didn't
need it for the serif font it actually
renders things really bizarrely and so
you can play with your font size a
little bit if you want to highlight that
a little bit but i don't want to have to
come in on all my headings because by
default they're all bold and have to
reset them because this normally
wouldn't be bold this wouldn't be all of
the headings through here are not
nowhere is using the bold so one last
extra step that we can take is coming in
and just saying that
and i don't think we're gonna get to the
h6 but i'm still gonna come in and say
the font weight here is 400 and if you
want to be even more explicit we could
also say that my paragraph's default
font weight is also 400.
because we're not going to see a lot of
bold in here but by doing that again the
p we might not need but we're just sort
of explicitly setting it and even that
could be said on the body instead of the
paragraph but just by doing that it's
going to set us at a little bit of a
better starting point as we come through
and we can see things are already
looking a little bit better so what i'm
going to challenge you to do is actually
set everything up properly here from our
font sizes and our font families you can
use the upper case where we need the
upper case and in the next video we're
going to continue on and look at this
section and make sure we can set up
everything there to make sure that we
have all the utility classes we need and
to give ourselves a little bit of
practice using them as well
all right so i've been very nice to you
and i'm not going to make you type out
everything we need for all of these
different parts because it would just
take you a little while and i don't
think you'd be benefiting from it too
much but i do want you to get some
practice using what we've learned so far
and i've also done a few things here
just some inline styles just to style
things and space them out a little bit
the one thing i'm going to say now is
don't worry about the spaces in between
these guys we're just going to try and
style this up to be matching what we see
as a whole here as closely as possible
in terms of font sizes colors and all of
that but don't worry about the spacing
we're going to come to that in a future
lesson and so i'm going to do a couple
of these and then get you to do the rest
of them and so here we have all of these
are actually the same so that speeds
things up a little bit we can come on
all of those and say that all of these
have a class that is equal to uh the
text accent and remember that's my color
that's going to come on that and so we
go and look that's looking pretty much
what we need it to be i think and so
those are looking pretty good and now
the next thing we need to do is actually
style these other ones up so here i'm
going to do this one class is equal to
and on that one it would be my font size
900 and what else we know in there we
need an upper case and we need to set
the font family so i'm going to come
here and say font family of sarah
and let's come and actually i'm going to
copy this one here and just place it on
the next one
and then what we're going to do is i
want to look at why i like having
utility classes and custom properties
and all of that set up so here this is
going to go down to an 8 and we can see
that they're both looking
just like they should be looking and so
one thing that's nice about this and we
can even come and add this on this one
and this is where
i could have it styling up properly and
then i can easily come and change the
font size you can see how the same
styles are working but things are
becoming very plug and play with this
approach because i can just plug in the
different things that i need but it's
also very plug and play because i can
easily come on here and say that this
should actually be my size condensed
instead and in another situation maybe
that's exactly what i need right there
so the size condensed is coming in and
it's working so that's really good and
it just makes my life a little bit
easier being able to make those changes
here plug and play whatever i need and
then it's updating and we're getting
what we need there but also i could then
come over to here and i could actually
change what my font family is here and
maybe instead of belfair at one point
the brand gets updated
this ends up becoming something else and
let's just take off serif and let's just
put this as uh cursive just so we can
see then i can quickly update all of the
places that were using that in one shot
so that is why i like having utility
class as well as a custom property it
just makes it easier to make big changes
or to plug and play and make little
changes along the way and we're also
going to see with the font sizes that
there's even more magic that can happen
by having the two of them separated and
as i said before too one of the other
advantages are we're not worried about
the heading level here these are
independent classes that can get plugged
and played and used anywhere we want so
i'm going to leave this like this for
you and so i'm going to challenge you to
go through and finish the rest of it now
because we sort of get an idea of how
the flow is and i'm you might be going
kevin i can figure this out it's not too
hard i really want you practicing to do
it so when we get to the actual site
itself you sort of remember a lot of
these different properties you remember
the font sizes you have a little bit of
muscle memory built up and in a second
i'll run through it and finish it myself
as well
all right so i already had my class
copied so i can paste that in this one's
becoming a 600
and in this case i think that's perfect
then we can come down onto this one and
in this case we want it to be a little
bit different so we don't have the serif
in this situation it's going to be my
size condensed
and the other thing is we have our
letter spacing and this one is the
biggest one and it is also uppercase so
we're going to leave the uppercase and
we can come in here with a
letter
spacing of one and that should give us
exactly what we know except we have of
course the wrong font size that should
be a 500 and of course this one also has
a different color on it so we can come
here and say that this should actually
be a text accent as well and let's hit
save and take a look and there we go i
think it's looking pretty good i know
it's close to the bottom of the page
but you can see that it is coming
through and it is starting to work so
let's quickly go through and style these
ones up as well
and there we go we finished all that up
and if we go and take a look now
everything is starting to come together
and match the style that we had with our
design system so we know that it is all
working it's all looking pretty good now
before we jump into the interactive
elements which are going to be very fun
to style up we are going to look at how
we can to fix these titles up to be
exactly like how we need them to be and
then i'm also going to be looking at how
we can add spacing to everything in a
very simple easy way and then after that
we'll get to the interactive elements
all right so we're gonna go into the
numbered titles now and those are these
guys right here this is not from the
design system but you know we recognize
them from the design system i'm sure
and these are the ones but these are the
ones that we see on the actual pages and
they're everywhere except for the
homepage
and
i want to look at these in a way talking
about how we can find the right balance
when it comes to things like utility
classes because utility classes
definitely allow us to work very quickly
as you would have seen when you did that
last section we just added those classes
in and really quickly we can style any
piece of text to look any way we need it
to be
but when we have something like numbered
titles that are always the same it can
be a good idea to find a balance
and so with these they always have the
same font family they always have the
same font size they always have the same
letter spacing and they always have this
number that's the same that's actually
like faded out and looks a little
different there's always this space here
and this is where you'd end up you know
having to come up with a new utility
class potentially for these numbers and
like every single time we do it it's
always going to be literally exactly the
same so i do think this is where having
a little sort of utility class
plus
uh because it's not quite a component
but maybe we could call it like a mini
component
where those things start to work really
well just like we applied several styles
to our body to allow us to work a little
bit faster
and it really depends on your workflow
and how you like to work but i'm going
to be setting up a specific class just
for these numbered titles
so it does a little bit more than what
you might consider a
normal
utility class to do but let's just come
and we're going to add it here and we'll
call it numbered
title because it describes exactly what
it is and
there's a few different things we're
going to want to do and what i'm going
to do before anything else is let's come
up and add that class all the way on our
first one that we had in our colors area
which is right here
i'm actually going to delete this
uppercase and i'm going to call this
numbered
title just like that and i'm going to
challenge you to style it up and make it
look the way we want it to be uh you'll
notice there is a span in here and so
you know we want to take advantage of
that do the best you can on it even if
you're really not sure where to start we
have all of our custom properties that
you can rely on and if you get stuck at
anything don't worry too much about it
and do your best to style it up and i'll
give you my solution in just a few
seconds
all right so for these we have a few
different things we need to do one of
them is going to be my font family which
is going to be my size condensed so once
again i'm just going to do that double
ff and then i can find my songs
condensed really nice and easily
we also want to set our font size which
always is the same one and in this case
it's once again fs and it's right there
i just have to choose the right one and
it will be 500 in this case then we need
to come in and set a text transform
of uppercase and again you could mix and
match a little bit with utility classes
here as well and that there's nothing
wrong with doing that
so maybe you want to mix it with your
letter spacing one but i'm just going to
come in and do this and i just realized
i didn't talk about why i set these in
pixels and earlier i talked about
setting font sizes with
rems and if you know me i like m's and
rams for most things when it comes to
sizing things and
here i left the pixels just it's just
these like decimal points that are very
specific and they're very
small numbers so i thought it was fine
to leave them as pixel values
that's just the reason why i did that so
there's nothing wrong with using pixels
for very small things or very specific
things every now and then and so if we
go and look at what we have we can see
it's coming together pretty good
compared to the design of what we want
it to look like i think it's actually
very close the only issue is our numbers
over here
and this is one of those places that the
custom properties for my colors that i
set up are really going to shine so i'm
going to create a number title span
and you'll notice i'm not putting a
different class here you might hear that
you should use a class for absolutely
everything but as we go through this
we're going to see that sometimes maybe
you don't want to and doing something
like this and if you want to be very
specific you could do something like
that
but when we have a span inside our
number title i want to style it in a
specific way and this sort of scopes the
style of the span to the numbered title
it can't escape out of there and we're
going to see this as we work on some
other things the first thing we do is
add a margin to the right side and i'm
going to try 0.5 m which is the
if you don't know m it's going to be
relative to this font size so that means
if ever we had a different font size
that would come on that spacing would
adapt with it and there we go we got a
nice healthy space right there
we also need it to be bold
a font weight
of 700
and the last thing we need to do is to
change the color of it because obviously
it's not the right color and if you try
the accent you'll also realize it's not
the right color if you look in the figma
file the opacity of it is 25
so if you haven't already done it or you
weren't able to do that the only thing
left is to do this color see if you can
think of how to do it we looked at it
briefly when i looked at how i set up my
colors with the custom properties if you
forget that's okay but pause think about
it maybe even go back to that video when
i set it all up to remind yourself so
you can try it and do it now to see if
you can get it to work or not and i'll
give you the solution in just a few
seconds
all right so i hope you did it i hope
you gave it a shot and hopefully you got
it right but if not no big deal remember
from now on and that's where i want to
come in with an hsl value and then in
here we can do my custom property so i
want this custom property my color light
or color white i should say because we
want to keep it white but it's at 25
percent so what i can then do is the
forward slash and 0.25 which sets the
alpha value and if we go and take a look
now look at that
perfect it's exactly what we needed so
there we go it's the numbered titles
that are set up so we can then run
through just take this numbered title
class apply it anywhere we need it and
in these cases it just so happens to be
on an h2 but it could be something that
it doesn't have to be on an h2 this
could be on an h1 or it could be on a
paragraph or it could be on anything
it's a class that can be plug and played
and used in any way that we need it to
be and so with that done we can move on
to adding the spacing that we need with
a very convenient way to add spacing in
my opinion and then after that we'll get
into those interactive components
all right so we're going to be looking
now at how we can add the spacing in
ways that is very adaptable and very
easy to update depending on the type of
spacing we need and we can do this with
a utility class and there are also other
common systems where you're using
utility classes like m1 m2 m3 p1 p2 p3
to add margin or padding around elements
then you have other utility classes like
mx2 which would be only left and right
and then m y2 which would only be top
and bottom and so on and so forth you do
it with borders as well and those can be
very useful but in this case i don't
think we need it for this design and i
want to show you a very modern approach
that we can take to doing it with just
one utility class and a modern pseudo
class that's recently been added to css
which does have good browser support
with the modern browsers because we
don't need all those other utility
classes and i think it's going to speed
us up overall just by using the one so
if we dive back into here i'm going to
go to my css file and i'm actually going
to come up back into this section here
which is my general utility classes and
here we're going to do is we're going to
create one called dot flow and if you
remember earlier when i talked about the
reset i talked about somebody called
andy bell and this is also where this
idea originates from and where i picked
it up and andy is a very smart css
person so if you want to give them a
follow i'd always recommend it and i'm
going to start this off how andy does it
and then i'm going to make a modified
version of it of how i'm going to do it
which i think makes it a little bit more
readable and what i'm going to do right
now is add a margin top of one rem we're
going to modify this but i'm also going
to put an outline just so we can
actually see what this is doing one
pixel solid red so maybe you've already
seen this this is the lobotomized owl
but if you haven't it can be kind of
confusing so i want to take a quick look
at how this is going to work
if you've already seen it and you
understand how it works you can skip
ahead a little bit in the video because
i will be modifying this and i will
actually be modifying this right here so
don't skip to the next lesson just skip
ahead within this lesson to when i make
these adjustments but i want to explain
how this is working first it won't take
me very long to do and we're going to
come into this section here which is my
typography
and in here where i have this div class
i'm going to add a or i have a div and
i'm going to add a class
at that class of flow
and we're going to look at what it does
and you'll notice now that we have earth
doesn't have a box around it but these
four do
and if we look here the direct children
of flow has my heading 1 and then we
also have this div this div this div and
they're all getting a red border around
it
except for this one and the way that
this selector here which again this is
it was hayden pickering who termed the
coin the lobotomized owl the way that
this is working is it's
the plus here is an adjacent sibling
combinator so it's looking for elements
that have adjacent siblings that come
before it so select everything that has
an adjacent sibling before it or a
sibling directly before it so if we look
here we have this guy does he have a
sibling before it he does
does this one have a sibling before it
he does does this one yes does this one
yes and does this one no he doesn't have
a sibling before it he doesn't have it
he doesn't get any of those styles
applied to him
now the one complaint that i hear about
this is it's
it's hard to read if you didn't get the
explanation that i just gave to you and
you just stumbled across it it can be
hard to understand you could come in
with a comment to explain what it's
actually doing
or we can do it another way that a lot
of people like which is the star and
then not and then we can do a first
child and this isn't the finished
version we're going to modify this again
from here but this is doing the exact
same thing it's saying anything that's
not the first child and if we come and
take a look now we can see that it's
exactly what we had before and if you're
going why why are we not selecting the
first child or you could also do this
with last child as well some people like
doing it with last child and doing this
as a margin bottom instead so either way
would work perfectly fine because you
can see it's selecting all of them
except for the last one
and the reason we like doing that is
just really fast let's come in here i'm
going to come in on this guy right here
where we have the flow and i'm going to
add a background of pink
and let's add padding of 1m just so we
have something on there
and notice the spacing on everything is
nice and consistent the space on the top
is one m padding the space on the bottom
is one m of padding as well and i
realize the contrast and that's really
terrible with our text colors so we'll
get rid of this in a second
but if we did the same thing where we're
just adding the padding on everything
but we say we just did this instead
where we're adding the margin bottom
well now it's going to mess up my
spacing here this space here is actually
twice as big as the space on the top so
what we're trying to do here is say the
first element has no space on the top
and the last element has no space on the
bottom
i'm very used to doing this
with doing it on the margin top version
of it with this being first child so i'm
going to work this way you can in the
future if ever you use this you could
choose whichever way makes more sense to
you but this is just what i've gotten
used to and i use it basically in all my
projects now so i'm gonna leave it like
that and now we can go through and get
rid of that pink background color all
right and now what i'm going to do is uh
i said i'm going to do one more
modification to this and the reason that
andy does it with the star plus star is
this has no extra specificity to it the
flow has the specificity which is
important because on our paragraphs and
all our headings we set a margin of zero
so we need this to overwrite that to add
a margin top on them but this doesn't
actually add any specificity whereas
when we do this this is a pseudo class
which has the same specificity as a
class selector and that does lead to
potential problems where you can't
overwrite something or you need an
important somewhere which you probably
don't want to have to do or worry about
so one way that we can actually overcome
that is with a very modern piece of css
and it makes this a little bit more
verbose but we can add a where and if
you've never seen this uh where and is
our new selectors that we have
this
if we didn't is it's not actually going
to help at all it's the exact same
situation
and where and is are generally used as a
different way to group things so before
you might do a let's just say we had
um a card and i know we don't have one
but i would say you had a card and you
wanted to style titles in it so you had
card h1 card h2 card h3
and that can be kind of annoying to have
to write out the same thing with your
nested selector like that so what you
can actually do now is card where and
then say h1 h2 h3 and that would be
exactly the same thing or you could also
have an is here
the difference between is and where is
where has where is will take the highest
specificity selector inside here and
apply it to that entire rule where on
the other hand and doesn't add any
specificity so everything in here gets
no added specificity so it just helps
keep it a little bit lower this is
actually used in the sanitize css reset
now and i've started seeing it in other
resets as well so it's a nice so it is
sort of a new way that we can eliminate
specificity from selectors to make it
easier to overwrite in situations where
we might have to i'm actually going to
leave the outline on here just so it's
easier to visualize what's happening but
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
change my margin top here to be a
var of flow space
and i don't want this float space it
doesn't exist it's doing nothing now i'm
going to do comma 1 rem
and this could actually be another
custom property if you wanted to have
like a spacer custom property at the top
and then you know all of these could
actually use a spacer custom property
but i won't get into that now we'll keep
things a little simpler
but just like i said these gaps up here
and i said these could become very
useful this is an undefined custom
property so the one rem becomes the
default so let's go back to our design
system where we have our flow here and
i'm going to come down onto this one and
i'm also going to add the class equals
flow on this one as well and we can see
it's working in both of those sections
the way it's intended to work but just
to show you where the power of this
comes from is
i can come now on an inline style and
one popular way to do this is with
inline style and of course you could
come in with an extra class and modify
it on a class 2 which is something we'll
see later in the course but what i can
do on here is i can actually redefine my
custom property so i can say that my
flow space
is four rem
and if i do that you can see this
spacing is now at four and this one over
here on this side has stayed at one rem
and you might be able to already see a
little bit of the power that can come
from something like this
so just for now what i'm going to do is
i'm going to come here and i'm going to
add it
here just so the two sections are
actually consistent with one another and
the spacing comes in might be a little
big compared to the actual figma file
but it's not terrible i'm going to leave
the outline on here just so it makes it
easier to visualize if changes are
working and how things are working and
i'm going to recommend that you go
through on the color section here and
you play with it that you come down here
and play with this a little bit
especially if you're not used to it to
see how it could work how you can
manipulate things you can try doing it
with classes within your css as well
instead of just applying it
to is an inline style if you want to
experiment a little bit with that and
once you're done playing with that once
you feel comfortable with it then i'll
see you in the next video where we're
going to be diving into the interactive
elements
all right so i'm sure you've been
looking forward to this for a little bit
getting into the more interactive things
and we have all these different
interactive elements that we have to
build out and there are some
similarities between some of them that
we'll be able to take advantage of and
just looking quickly at them we have
different states for all of them right
we have hover states neutral states and
active states and we'll dive more into
the ones that have three states shortly
but we're going to start with this which
only has the regular state as well as a
hover state on there and it'd be a nice
jumping off point i think before we get
into some of these other ones that are a
little bit more complex
and so this explore button it's very
unique to the entire site which is
important because often buttons and i'm
calling it a button it is a link
but it's sort of this big buttony thing
that we can click on and often buttons
have a whole bunch of different versions
of buttons throughout a site we don't
have to have one with primary color
secondary colored tertiary colors and
all of that we just have to have this
one guy right here and another thing
that's interesting is we do have these
two states but could we add some
animations to it as well that is
something when you get static designs
that we can't always explore some teams
will have people who animate them to
show the dev what it should look like in
this case we don't have that so we're
gonna have to figure that out on our own
and make some decisions so let's jump on
over to the code and you can see i've
actually set things up a little bit here
in this interactive elements section
that i've created and actually you know
what we should also have a class is
equal to flow on there just add a little
bit of spacing
and you can see i've set up a section
for our navigation and right here i've
set up a spot for our button and in this
case because it is a link i am going to
style it with a link it could be
something that could be a link or a
button so we could add extra styling to
it but because i know it's going to be a
regular link on a site that's just going
to bring us to another page it's not
something where we're opening a modal
we're not interacting like that i'm
going to be just doing it on a regular
link here and then we're going to give
this a class and i'm going to call it
large button instead of explore button
just because
trying to forward think it might change
the text inside of it might change one
day
it could also end up maybe the site gets
bigger they need more large buttons on
other pages so i just think it makes it
a little bit more versatile and we'll
write explorer in there close a and
before i do anything else let's go take
a look at what that actually looks like
it's all the way down at the bottom it's
this blue thing there and you know what
i'm going to do um i'm going to add on
this div right here i'm going to do a
style is equal to margin bottom of 50 vh
just so when we're working here i can
actually scroll down and we can see what
we're looking at and we have some margin
down there at the bottom so we have an
explore button that looks like this and
what i want you to do is before we even
do anything
could we
one thing we could think of is maybe we
could style a lot of these things up
with utility classes instead of styling
everything specific to the large button
so there are some things the large
button will have to have so we can't
make it a circle and we can't do the
hover effects but we can add utility
classes here to get us along all the way
and i'm going to tell you why i think it
could be a good idea in this situation
compared to when we did our
numbered titles here so add as many
utility classes as we have they can get
us closer and then we'll talk about it
more in just a few seconds
all right so i'm going to come in we're
going to add an upper case on there we
can add a font family of serif and we
can add the text dark and a bg of white
and it's not all the way there but look
at that it's coming together pretty
nicely and there's one more that we
could also add on here actually which
would be my font size of 600 just to
give us the right font size and it's
coming together and i know it's not all
the way there uh but it is a decent
start and one of the reasons i like that
idea is maybe in the future it gets
updated maybe we need a second button
right so someone you know they add
another design somewhere else where
there's a second button that comes in it
looks exactly the same but maybe this
time it actually needs to be a bit
smaller so it's going to be the small
version of the same thing and
we don't need to create a new class to
be able to accommodate it we could just
update the
font size here and it's going to change
it or maybe they decide that
there's going to be two buttons that are
next to each other an explorer and a
different button and one of them is
going to be a white background and
another one is going to be the accent
background and then so we can get the
two different buttons very easily very
quickly so
setting these up with some utility
classes and then finishing things up
with my large button class that will add
the finishing touches is one approach
you could take and one that i'm going to
stick with in this case
you might say that we could do the same
thing on the number title and 100 you
could take the same approach there but i
do want to show you different ways of
working at the same time and one thing
just very quickly if you are going to
take this approach with utility classes
and a component type class here
is i would always start with this one
and then add the utilities after or vice
versa do all the utilities first and
then add the
more component based one after
just to make it so it's very consistent
every time you do it is i prefer having
the component first and then all my
utility classes just because of what i'm
used to but if you think the other way
around makes more sense it's up to you
and so i'm gonna hit save on that we
have my explore button there so let's
come down into my css file and i'm
actually gonna go all the way to the top
just for one second to grab this guy and
then we're gonna go all the way back
down because now we're outside of the
utilities and we're coming into the
world of components
and components are things that are a
little bit bigger they have more pieces
going on there's multiple things inside
of them now this button it's it's not
really multiple things it's just one
thing but it still falls into that world
of components
but the other things in our design
system
like these these are definitely
components where we have different
pieces that are all part of one bigger
thing so we're going to enter into the
world of components for these
interactive elements and we call this a
large button so what i'm going to
suggest now is style this up do what you
can with it don't worry about the hover
state yet though because i want to show
you my solution to this before you go
into the hover state because i'll give
you another challenge uh once we finish
this to do the hover state on the button
there so start off right here go for it
get it as close as possible as you can
and then i'll come in and give you my
solution
all right so the very first thing i'm
going to do is give this guy a bit of
padding and i'm going to actually do
padding of 0 on the top and bottom and a
2m on the left and the right and the
reason i'm using m here is if ever the
font size were to change the padding
would grow or shrink with it so that is
a little bit handy there and again this
is to try and make it a little bit more
robust and we can see that that is
coming in and giving us a bit of size on
the left and the right and because we do
want to give it some height one thing i
usually want buttons is i give them very
often a display of inline block in this
case i'm actually going to instead of
that give it a display of grid and i'll
explain why afterward
and not too long just in a few seconds
but uh it is important we change the
display here because we are working with
a link which is an inline element we
can't really give that padding top and
bottom you can but it doesn't work or a
height wouldn't work on it
and it would actually overlap with the
content that's here if we can get the
padding working so i'm doing a display
grid often it would be a display inline
block and
then i do need to give it a height right
and a lot of people would come in with a
height of say 100 pixels and a width of
100 pixels and not have the padding
instead so we can actually get
an actual size but we have modern css
solutions that we can use instead and
i'm going to give this an aspect ratio
and this is a really nice little bit of
modern css it is supported in all modern
browsers now and you can see it turns
that into a perfect square isn't that
cool uh and you could play around with
aspect ratio i'm doing one which is the
same as saying one over one but you
could come in here and say it's a two
over one so then it's twice as wide as
it is high or you could come in and do
the opposite with like a one uh with a
one over two it's gonna be twice as tall
as it is wide so it's always the width
over the height now i'm just gonna put
this back to a one so we have our nice
perfect square but if you do feel like
you wanna play around with that a little
bit and have some fun with it go ahead
and then when you're ready you can
resume the lesson
but what i'm going to do now is come in
on here and right now there's two things
one there's the underline on the text
that we want to get rid of but we also
need to get that text in the middle and
this is why i use grid instead of a
block or inline block because then i can
just do a place items or place content i
think would work here as well uh center
and this is a shorthand for align items
and justify items and we only have one
thing in there it will put it right in
the middle and just a nice easy way you
could do the same thing with flexbox you
just need an extra line so with grid we
can do it with one right there so that
works really well and then we do want to
get rid of that text decoration so we
can do text decoration of none and of
course we want to have the border radius
which i'm going to keep over here with
the padding and a border radius of 50
to give us a nice perfect circle and
there we go i think that's looking
pretty good and we are gonna get that
like the glowy bit that's going to be
coming on this uh shortly so what i'm
actually going to do
is just in my inline styles here
uh on this even i'm just going to do a
style is equal to a margin top of 5 ram
just to give us a little bit of space
here so when we do that it doesn't clash
with the text that we have on top of
there but that's just for that because
now i want to challenge you to create
that glowing effect and if you can think
of a way to do that and so i'm actually
going to do that in the next video so
i'm challenging you to do all of the
work right now here in this scrim and
then see my solution in the next one but
if you do need a hint to get you started
i will give you one at the beginning of
the next video but i really would
encourage you to try this out on your
own see if you can get there and then if
you need a few hints along the way then
you can see my solution world i'm going
to pause along the way a few times to
give you a chance to give it your own
try so good luck with it and i'll see
you in the next video when you're ready
all right so if you're here just for the
hint i'm going to start with that where
i'm going to start off with a large
button and i'm going to use a pseudo
element for this and there could be
other ways to achieve this but
pseudo-elements are something that i
really like and for decorative elements
like this it's just really easy to do
and it gives us a lot of possibilities
on the types of animations and other
things that we can do with it so if you
weren't sure where to start and now this
gives you a little bit of an idea you
can take off from here and then in just
a few seconds i'll give you the rest of
my solution on animating this background
glowy thing that we're going to add in
here
all right so the very first thing we
need whenever we have a pseudo element
is the content property because without
it we won't have a pseudo element that's
there and i know i'm going to want a
position of absolute on here so we can
add that right away and just to make
sure that things don't get out of hand
or you know out of the way i'm going to
come up onto my large button and give
this a position of relative just so this
becomes the containing block for my
absolute positioned element over here
now i think a good thing to do so we can
actually see it and position it i always
like just giving them a background of
red so we can see what's actually
happening and well we could give it a
top bottom left and right all of zero
there's other solutions one of them you
could use inset um of zero or you could
just come in with a width and a height
of 100 and that should work too and we
can see my red box is showing up right
there and the next thing is obviously we
do want the shape of it to match so
there's two choices here on the border
radius we could either do a 50 here to
make it a circle or if you wanted to you
could actually make that inherit and
then it would match the border radius of
the parent but i think the 50 here is
fine and now we can see that it has
become a circle so we're on the right
track but we can see that's given us the
nice perfect circle here so that's going
to work and we're on the right track but
obviously there is a big problem now in
that it's covering the text and we
definitely don't want it to be doing
that we need to see the explore text and
one way we can do that is to come on
here and i'm gonna go where i have my
position and add a z index of negative
one which is going to push it all the
way back um the problem with this is it
pushes it so far back if we have other
elements like a background image or
other things it could actually get lost
behind them so even though we could
technically get it visible right now
just to prevent potential problems from
happening in the future i will come up
on the display here and add a z index of
one and what this is doing is creating a
new stacking context and that means that
this negative one it is below everything
so it's still a negative z index but it
can't escape outside of my large button
so if we go and take a look at it now
you can actually see the text even
though it's in front of the white
background if i take this off
you'll actually see that it's gone below
my white background that i had on there
and well that might be something that
you're thinking well that's exactly what
we want kevin we're going to be using
white anyway so it doesn't really matter
and again this i don't think we'd run
into a problem with it on this site but
whenever i have a absolutely positioned
element within something else it's
usually a good idea to force a new
stacking context just to prevent weird
problems from happening especially
because you might end up doing an
animation or transition that creates a
new stacking context anyway and then all
of a sudden things are changing when the
animation's happening which could be an
absolute nightmare so this is a nice fix
of course this background actually won't
be red like i just mentioned on this we
can use my hsl and use our color white
and i think we're going to try like a
0.15 and we'll see how that looks uh but
we need to add the animation in now and
if you didn't already do this part and
you sort of wanted to follow along a
little bit to set the stage now you
could also try and just do the animation
for it at this stage and we're not going
to do anything too complex and if you're
not too sure where to start i will give
a small hint in just a second so if you
need a little push in the right
direction just wait around or if not hit
pause right now and jump into it
all right so the hint here is if you
aren't used to using or animating sugar
elements we want this to be on hover so
we do have to choose our large button to
hover and then choose the after here to
be able to do the hover animation on it
and uh because we are doing a hover we
should also come in and add in a focus
here as well so if somebody tabs onto it
we still get the same type of effect
going so if that was the little push you
needed just to get you started you can
go ahead and add your animation in now
and i'll come in with my final solution
in just a few seconds
all right so uh with that working i'm
actually going to move my background
just because of how i like to organize
my own css i'm going to move that right
to here
not that it changes anything in the big
picture of things and then we can come
on here and i'm going to here do a
transform and do a scale of about 1.5 i
think that's going to work out nicely
and let's go take a look before i add
the animation on that and we can see
that there we go it's getting bigger and
smaller which is exactly what we wanted
now one thing that's really important
with this instead of doing an animation
on the width and the height which are
actually kind of expensive for the
browser to do if we do that it would
actually even though we've positioned
this absolute it could potentially lead
to repaints and actually reflows of
content on the page when you do
animations or transitions on the
transforms like scale translate or
rotate then those don't actually cause
any reflows on the page and they're also
gpu accelerated so you get some nice
smoother animations that way and it's a
bit easier for the browser and so with
that we just need to come up on here and
we can add a transition so we can do
transition and i want to do my transform
let's say 500 milliseconds and i'll just
do an ease in out and so if we go and
take a look at it we can see that we get
now a nice little animation that happens
there and i think we can improve that
just a touch so we can keep that like
that but another thing i'm going to do
is i'm actually going to change the
opacity here to zero
and on here we can then say that the
opacity becomes one now this isn't
actually going to be transitioning so
you can link together multiple ones go
ahead and do opacity 500 milliseconds
and linear and you just come and
separate them and you might be wondering
well why do both of them and not just do
an all again i want to choose the
different ones that i'm doing i can
choose different timing functions for
them by doing it this way so that can be
a nice little touch so now we should see
see the opacity it just gives it a nice
little the glow comes in as it's
expanding and then it sort of fades out
at the same time so i think that looks a
little better
and i said we can have different timing
functions but we can also have different
times as well and you can even have
delays on some of them if you want and
not on other ones so by separating out
the different properties you're doing
you're getting that extra level of
control and you won't accidentally
animate things that you're not meaning
to do as well so i always like
specifying the exact things that i want
to actually be animating and now if we
go take a look
i just think that looks really great and
the opacity being at a little bit of a
different speed than the transition for
me gives it a nice little extra effect
and i think it looks pretty good now if
you want to step your game up and
experiment with this a little bit more
i'd suggest going in and trying to play
with these timing functions here and if
you haven't done things with cubic
beziers before this could be a nice
opportunity to get it more to like snap
into place or to do a little bounce or
to come up with some interesting effects
but this is my final solution so i'm
going to encourage you to play with it
some more and when you're ready i'll see
you in the next lesson
all right so we move on to the next
element which is going to be our
underline indicators and not
specifically the navigation
and that reason is you can see here i
have an underline indicator here i have
one over here we have some two and uh so
these indicators we have a hover state
and an active state for them and you'll
notice even though this is the
navigation and this one over here is
some tabs
it's just an underline so we have
the navigation with an underline and
over here we have the the tabs over here
with the same type of underlying action
going on the hover states the same and
everything there's some spacing
differences and some minor changes to
them but overall they're very very
similar to one another so we can tackle
these both at the same time a little bit
now this part will be broken up over
multiple lessons because there is a few
things we need to do to sort of set the
stage and make sure that we're on the
right track so let's go and start things
off here and we'll come over to my
design system once again and now we are
going to build in the quick navigation
as well as our tabs over here so for the
navigation typically you'll see
something like this
and you know we just have our nav with
the ul we have our allies with our links
inside of it and it usually is not
anything too special we start with
something that looks like that and there
are a few things we can do before we
even get into styling anything specific
for the primary navigation we've already
created a few utility classes we could
use here just to sort of get things off
in the right foot so why don't you go
ahead and do that and use some of the
classes we've already created to try and
get this as far along as you can without
writing any extra css
all right so i hope you're starting to
see the benefits of having these utility
classes
if it's something that is newer to you
so we're going to come in here and give
these a class and we'll do equals and
there's a few different things that we
can put on these first we'll do an upper
case and we'll also follow this up with
having a text white and let's go and
take a look and that already looks a lot
better let's just go and take a look
here i'm pretty happy with already the
progress that that gave us and there is
one other class that we can give these
and that is the letter spacing q these
are not outlined or given to us in the
design spec anywhere but if you look in
the figma file or if you just look
closely you might notice that we have
those we can give that on all of those
and it just spaces the letters out a
little bit for us and there's one other
one maybe you've already done this when
we did this but we can come over here
and add our flex class on there right
away and we can see it also spaces
things out a little bit
now i'm not going to stress too much on
the actual big spaces that we see here
just because the finished design does
have a smaller one but once again we
could come on here and say that we have
a style and do the gap and make this
bigger say we do four rem instead and
that's gonna add to the spaces maybe you
want bigger you can come in with an 8
ram or something like that and we can
space things out more and more based on
what we're putting here so that could be
a way to get started with it and that's
again one of the nice things with having
that custom property here another option
you could do instead of doing an inline
style i've mentioned it but i haven't
looked at it yet would be to over here
we could actually create our primary
navigation
and on there we could come in and say
the gap is a rem
and that's going to have the exact same
effect if we come back and take a look
we can see the nice big spaces are there
and if i knock that down to a one rem
and we go and take a new look you can
see that those spaces have gone down and
it's much closer together so custom
properties are amazing it is my big
takeaway from that let's jump that back
up to eight
and of course there's a few other things
that we need to do on this so we'll do a
list style
of none just so we don't have anything
there and i will do a padding of zero at
margin of zero just because it is a ul
that we're placing all of this on and
there's some default styling in there
that i do want to get rid of so we can
come and take a look and i think that's
looking a little bit better
now another thing we can do on our
primary navigation is we can come in and
say that we have our primary navigation
and we can do our links that are in here
and say that these links are a text
declaration of none
and this is our we're really in
components here so i really don't see
any issues with using descendant
selectors like this where we're scoping
the style of the link within a primary
navigation and we're going to see more
and more of this especially as we go
into the tab system as well
so we've done a nice job setting the
stage there's one more thing i want to
do before we worry about the underlines
and that is adding those numbers in
there
because we did see you know we have the
numbers here that we don't have down
here and this is very similar to our
numbered titles where i'm going to throw
a span on this one and i'll do this
really fast
and there we go so i put a span on those
and so with those there this is very
similar to our numbered titles that
we've created so i'll let you come in
and add the styling on there that we
need for them and then after that we'll
look at adding those underlines
all right so on there i'm going to come
in with my primary navigation
a
and
we could do the a and span like that
we don't really need the direct
descendant selector here but i'm going
to do it anyway
you could even come in like this but i
just want to make sure if something
weird were to happen maybe somehow a
span gets put in that's not inside a
link and i don't want this style to leak
out necessarily so on here i'm just
going to say the font weight
is going to be 700 which is my bold
weight and we're also going to add a
little margin to the right side of like
a 0.5
m that let's go and take a look and see
how that looks
and if we come and compare that to here
it is looking pretty good i just
realized i put the wrong numbers but for
this it doesn't matter too much uh but
for now let's focus on putting those
underlines in there before i challenge
you the one thing i'm going to do is
because
these underlines are sharing between two
different elements and this is why i've
called this whole thing underlined
indicators
is
because they have that in common we
don't want to do double the work because
we could style it up for our navigation
and then we could style it up again for
our tabs over here and i really don't
want to be doing that so instead of
worrying about right now our primary
navigation what i'm going to do is come
on the same place where we have our
primary navigation and i'm going to call
this underline ndk tours and you could
do this instead of having it here as
almost a utility class that is being
placed on each one of the links i'm
going to put it here to create sort of
this grouping it's part of a bigger
component and it's going to allow it to
work in both places and just have to put
the class in one place instead of
multiple but there are different ways to
skin a cat so i don't think there'd be
anything wrong i would just take the s
off so it's underline indicator and put
it on each one of the links this just is
a little bit less work to do it this way
and so we can come in here we can create
the dot underline in the k doors and if
you think you're able to dive in and
start doing it and getting it to look
like this where we have a normal state
the hover state and then active state
here just be very careful it doesn't
mean active with the active pseudo class
this is active in a different way if
you'd like a little more information
wait in a second
and i'll give some on there but if
you're ready and you think you could
style this up go for it right now don't
worry about the background color here
let's just worry about getting these
underlines coming on and so let's go and
i'll you know you can jump in there
right away or if you'd like a hint you
can wait a few seconds and i'll give you
a hint and i'll be giving the solution
to this in the next
video all right so i do have two hints
for it one of them is about that active
class so that would be on my li here i'm
actually going to put a little class of
active just like that and that's going
to allow me to sort of hook into here to
add it
it could also be placed on the link but
in this case i much prefer it on the li
just because it's going to make it a
little bit easier to share this between
here and ship and here so i'm going to
do it in this way
so that could help you just you know get
in so the dot active is going to be
styled a little bit differently and with
that i'm going to once again give you
the reins and let you go but if you
start and you get stuck i do have one
more hint to give you um which i'll be
giving in a couple of seconds
all right and the last hint is that we
don't want to be styling
on our underline indicators class itself
because that is all of these and i'd
much rather place it on each individual
one of my lis so to do that we could
come in and say li here and it would
choose my allies but once again i want
this to be more robust to be able to be
used in different situations so i'm
going to do this instead which means
we're selecting every direct child or
direct descendant of my underline
indicators and just to show you if i
throw a background of red on there it
should come in let's just make sure that
this is also saved and there we go we
have the red coming in on all of those
so hopefully with that you have enough
information to get this going and start
styling it up and i'll see you in the
next lesson with my solution
so very quickly for anyone who didn't
watch the hints in the last one i am
selecting all of the direct descendants
rather than the lis here just so it's
more reusable in different situations
and we'll talk more about that when we
get over to our tabs over here but let's
get this all working for us now i don't
actually want to style anything here
directly but i'm going to do it now just
so i can see it on the page and then
we're going to transfer that over to the
hover and our active and so i'm going to
use a border for this and it's not often
we use borders but i'm going to do a
border bottom and if you did this with a
pseudo element instead then you're a
person of my heart
because i love suit elements and my
first initial thought for this was to
use suit elements but in this case i'm
going to come in with a border bottom of
0.2 ram solid and we can use our
variable of our color light right here
with with our hsl on the outside so it's
actually working just so i can make sure
that it's actually showing up so let's
go take a look
and there we go it's working except i
chose the wrong color color white not
color like and there we go we can see
that it is underlined just like we
needed to but obviously uh the spacing
is a little bit off and the easiest way
in my opinion to fix that is to just
come in and on these right here give
them some padding so i'll do padding and
we'll do a one m on the top and the
bottom and a zero on the left and the
right i am adding the padding on the top
and the bottom um as you'll notice here
and we can actually play with this a
little bit as you'll see in a second but
let's leave it like that for now and we
can see that's looking pretty good the
spacing maybe is not quite big enough
for this section but it might be even
too big for when we do the tabs
so because of that can you think of a
way that we could sort of customize
things a little bit depending on their
situation so set a default and then to
have something that could change that
default depending on the situation
something we've looked at a couple of
times already if you can think of it go
ahead and do that now and if you'd like
a hint i'll give one in a second
and that hint is custom properties are
amazing and so if that gives you a
little bit of a clue as to how to do it
maybe you have to look up at some of the
other ones we've already set some
default custom properties to so then you
can go and replace this number with that
and i'll give you my solution in just a
second
all right great so let's come in and
change this padding right here to be a
custom property so we're going to do
var and we'll just call this underline
gap i don't want to call it gap because
i want it to be something that is unique
and we do this is one of those undefined
local custom properties so i will come
in and give a default value that we can
overwrite really easily
and so if we look that's looking pretty
good but as we know our primary
navigation actually needs a different
one so i can keep my gap there and i can
come and say my underline gap is let's
do maybe two rem in this case and
because this is on the padding it will
affect the padding top and bottom so
there we go we have the bigger space
just like we see in the design here
where it's a much bigger space and
that's going to give us the padding on
the top here as well which is going to
be very handy because that's going to
sort of set the stage for this
background that we'll be bringing in
once we get to the actual pages because
there's some interesting things with
that background that we're going to have
to do
so i know that everything is looking
good and what i'm actually going to do
is change the opacity on here to be zero
because then just by setting it up there
and you don't have to do it this way if
you just change the border bottom each
time that would work perfectly fine but
i'm just going to set the color to zero
and then what we can do is say that my
underline indicators
cover
and we can come in with the uh we don't
need the whole border bottom actually
all we need to do now is our border
color and we can change that and say
it's our hsl with our color white once
again but come in with a bit of opacity
on it
and if we have a hover before i forget
we should also have a focus state so we
can come in and bring this right here
with our focus as well
and then we can also come in and i'll
just copy this actually
paste right there and instead of having
all this we can just come in and say a
dot active and if you left the star
there he said start on active but we
don't really need it so we're going to
say that a dot active that is a direct
descendant of our underlying indicator
will come in and get this white with the
solid one here and let's go and take a
look at how that's looking so my active
is perfect let's see
hover is also working and there we go
that's looking pretty great to me
i think the underline is actually
supposed to be a bit more and checking
the figma file it is so i'm going to
boost that up to a 0.5 instead of a 0.25
and there we go really really cool works
really well the hover doesn't change on
this one because the active here is
overriding it and i think that is pretty
awesome so in the next video we're going
to look at how we can come in and get
this tab component to come in instead
and just get the same functionality in
there and it should be easy breezy
because we've already set up the
component though there will be a few
little tweaks and extra styling we'll
have to do not so much on this one but
just for the tabs themselves
all right so we finished this one here
with our underline indicators and we're
going to come in and create some tab a
similar tab system just to show you how
easy it is to move things around and i'm
going to be asking you to do most of the
work here but i'm going to do set the
stage a little bit and we're going to
have a div class there and actually i'll
leave that empty
and we'll do a closed div and in here
instead of using a list we're just going
to be coming in with buttons because
this will be an interactive section
we're going to be doing
and so we're going to have a button and
there are several important things that
are actually going to come up when we
add the functionality here when it also
comes to accessibility for this type of
system but for now i'm only worried
about the styling of it
we can have our three buttons if we go
and actually take a look at that we have
these three buttons that are showing up
and there there's nothing in them and in
here right away we can add our text we
can do our moon we can have our text
right here of mars and we can do our
text of europa
and i think i've done a lot of what we
need for you to actually be able to
style this up and make it look the way
we need it to so why don't you take what
we've learned so far we'll have to add
utility classes to a few different
places here and maybe make a few extra
tweaks so i'll let you do your best we
might have to create a new class as well
just as a little hint and i'll leave it
to you to do your best on it and then
i'll come in with my own solution very
shortly
all right so i hope you had some success
and if you ran into any problems
hopefully we can address what those
might be
so the first thing i'm actually going to
do is on all these buttons here let's
come in on these with a class is equal
to and what do we need we need them to
be
uppercase
we need them to be text
and i'm actually going to do this on all
of them and you'll see we'll sort of
tweak things a little bit
because i think it'll make life easier
so on all of them i'm going to do the
text accent and if you change that for
the moon button because the moon one
should be white whereas the other ones
have the accent color perfectly fine and
i'll just talk about in a minute why i'm
making this difference
or why i'm including it on all three i
should say so we can have the text
accent that's on all of those we also
have some letter spacing so we can do
our letter spacing too just like in the
navigation it's the same letter spacing
another thing we could do since we're
here and we do need to set a background
on them anyway to get rid of the default
background so if you did a bg dark here
that'd be fantastic we have the borders
that are really ugly but at least the
rest of it is working and the last thing
we need to do is our font family so
let's come right here on these and do
our font family
songs condensed and they're pretty much
there but we need those underlying
indicators
ah that shouldn't be too hard we can
come up to here and say underline
indicator and we did a lot of work on
that don't forget the s and it's sort of
working though there's some weird border
stuff going on with it so i hope that
didn't trip you up too much
uh and there's two other things that i
can think of doing before we leave is
even though they're next to one another
we need some more spacing on them and we
saw that we can add spacing quite easily
by using a flex class and there we've
got a bit of spacing and maybe we want
to tweak that with the gap property that
we can play with or that custom property
that we have why don't we start there
and one of the easy ways to do that is
i'm going to call this my tab
list as its own class just like up here
we had our primary navigation and our
underline indicators here i'm going to
have my underlying indicators but also a
tab list just because this does need a
little bit of custom styling on it
you could say could our underlying
indicators set the stage for both of
these and 100 we could definitely make
that a little bit more robust by coming
in and let's go find that
um when we set our border bottom here we
could come in first and say that there's
a border of zero and that just means it
doesn't matter if there wasn't one like
with our links but if there was a border
it would actually eliminate those right
away and look at that it's already
looking much much better um another
thing that we could probably do on this
is the cursor because on this it was
links and we're getting the hand cursor
and i realize you can't see it now while
i'm doing this because the scrimba icon
is the same but i'm getting a hand icon
here and i'm getting the regular arrow
on those so why don't we come in on here
and also say that we have a cursor of
pointer which just because of how i like
to organize my css i'm going to move up
to right here
and again this is just making things
more robust whether it's a link or
whether it's a button so they will work
no matter what and there we go that's
working pretty good
now i did add my tab list so we can come
down and say that we have our tab list
and in here i can change my gap so let's
make it maybe three rem and if we go
take a look there we go we have a better
spacing on those maybe 2.5 would
actually be or a 2 or 2.5 would actually
be right in the ball house of what we
need so that's looking pretty good and
last but not least we do need to have
the active one and i'm almost guaranteed
use an active class when you did this
which is perfectly fine and it works and
it's what i've taught you to do and what
you probably assumed would be the
solution
i am going to do things a little bit
different for this one just because i
was talking about accessibility
um so i do want to come in on these guys
right here and instead of using the
active class i'm actually going to come
on this first button and i'm going to
write area selected
is equal to true
and we're going to take the same thing
and we're going to put it on our other
buttons
but we're going to switch them to false
and
if you don't know what an area is it
stands for accessible rich internet
applications and basically it's
something that we can use to give extra
context once again to assistive
technologies and because we're going to
be turning this into a tab system it's a
way to let them know that this is
actually the selected tab that's very
different than links because when you go
to a different page we're going to have
to manually move this class one to the
next when we click on a link we're going
to literally another html page whereas
here we're staying on the same page and
we're changing content around and we're
going to have tabs that are related to
each one of these buttons and this is
going to let the assistive technology
know which one of the tabs is actually
open we're gonna have more area stuff
that's gonna be coming into here area is
something that can seem overwhelming if
you first start getting into it because
there's so many different properties but
in general if you're using semantic html
you don't need to worry about it too
much but for something like a tab list
it is going to really help us out and
one way that we can sort of try and
enforce people using these types of
things is to come in and here we have
our active another way that we could do
the same thing is with our underlying
indicators
we could say that anything that has the
attribute here you can actually put
attribute selectors so anything with an
area selected equals true and now if we
go and take a look we can see it's added
that underneath because that's the area
selected equals true the one issue is
obviously the text color so we can also
come in and say that
we can change the color of the entire
thing as well so then the color will
also become this one right here
and paste that so it's the same in both
spots and then the selected one will be
white and then we can you know we have
the hover effect once we add the
functionality to this when we click on
this it will switch which one is the
area selected and the styling of it will
update along with what we've done here
so there we go that is our tabs nice and
done
all right so we're moving on into our
dot indicators now which are these guys
right here and there's really nothing
too much complex or nothing new about
these other than one little thing that i
want to look at with you before i give
you the challenge of completing them and
that is if we come and we're going to
jump over here and they're actually very
very similar to our tab list right here
so i'm actually going to copy that and
paste it in
but we obviously will change this over
from a tab list to dot nbk tours and i
think leaving the flex on here makes
sense because it'll give us extra
control on spacing them if we need that
and then in here we don't really need
these classes on here i don't think so
let's get rid of these for you just to
speed things up for when i give you the
challenge
and we get rid of that that and that and
we want to keep these areas selected
because it's going to work very similar
to how our tabs are going to work and
that when we switch between them we want
them
we're going to be switching between
different tabs effectively just with a
different type of visual indicator to
show us what's happening but the problem
is we're saying area selected equals
true but then if we take the text out
and we hit save and let's go and there
they are and actually let's do one thing
really really fast here uh on this div
i'm going to come in with a class is
equal to flow
and then here in my style let's just say
that my
uh
flow space
is for ram or something like that just
add the extra spacing so we can see
those are the dot indicators right there
and so
this is where they're going to be but
there's no context right so it knows the
screenwriter will know which one is
selected but it doesn't know what is
actually selected if it's reading this
out loud it's going to read button
button button and it doesn't there's no
context to what the buttons are or what
the buttons are doing whereas this is
our slide title or our tab title i'll
put slide title but it's really a tab
title uh but i've already started
writing so there's no going back now
slide title and
now we have context for what they are
just like here we know it's our moon our
mars and our europa
but we don't want that text there
because visually this is what we need
where we just want these visual icons
instead
but there is a solution to this and what
we can do is come in on all of these and
add a span
class is equal to and this is something
we created a long time ago and we
haven't used yet our sr only which is
short for screen reader only
and there's other ways of adding context
like this but i'm going to do it like
this in this situation where now you can
actually see it's hidden away the text
that was in there
and that's perfect it's exactly what we
wanted and what this basically is if we
go and find that in our css it's doing a
whole bunch of things here to visually
hide whatever is
inside this class so those spans they're
just hidden away they're not going to be
visually seen but when an assistive
technology like a screen reader gets to
this and is reading out things it will
read this and it gives the button
context to what happens if the person
happens to click and select that slide
so we're just helping a bit with the
accessibility and again we're going to
be going deeper in as we make these
functional but for now we're worried
more about the visuals and we sort of
have some ugly buttons
that we want to turn into those little
circle buttons so i'm going to come all
the way down here and i'm just going to
let you do it it's a little bit simpler
i think than some of the other ones
we've done so far i don't think you need
a helping hand based on everything we've
looked at so give it your best shot and
in a few seconds i will give you my
solution
all right so just like before we have
our dot indicators
and we don't want to actually do
anything on the dot indicators we want
to select all of the direct children
that are inside and there's a few things
i'm going to do the cursor pointer once
again so we have a nice pointer on there
i'm going to come in with a border that
is zero
and we're going to throw in right away a
border radius of 50
to make them nice perfect circles and
hopefully it makes some perfect circles
but we might go and look and find out oh
they're just really flat now
that's not what we want how could we fix
that this is something we've looked at
before how can we make a nice perfect
square or circle in this case because we
already have our border radius on there
without setting a width and a height
hopefully you said that we could set an
aspect ratio of one so it's one over one
which we can make just into one like
that and by doing that we go and take a
look look at that perfect little circles
right there uh they do need to be a
little bit bigger than that so why don't
we just add a touch of padding so we can
do padding of like .25
uh m or rem would probably be fine you
know what that made them too small let's
try 8.5 instead and go take a look and
that's more in line with the actual size
that we want on them and of course we
need the now set the colors so we have
very faded medium faded and not faded at
all so we can come in and set first a
background color background color right
there and i'll do my hsl and choose the
0.25 as my starting point and then what
i'm actually going to do just to speed
things up let's copy that paste it and
make this my hover
and of course with my hover we also want
to have a focus we're actually going to
change the focus to something different
a little bit later but
we'll talk about that once we make it
functional because that's where we'll
see why we want to change it for this
one the only thing we need to do is come
in and change the color 2.5
and then we can also take advantage of
this type of selector right here you
know what let's just copy all that
and change this over to our dot
indicator with an area selected is true
and in that case the background color
will be our pure white and let's go and
take a look and i think that's looking
pretty good and there we go we get our
hover seat that's looking good we have
the active state that's looking good and
i think i'm pretty happy with that i
hope you are too and i'll see you in the
next lesson
so it's time for the last interactive
element which is our numbered indicators
and you before you started this you
might have noticed that this lesson is
actually a lot shorter than pretty much
all the other ones we've done so far
and that's because i'm not helping you
with this one i'm leaving this one
completely up to you i'm not providing
any solutions i think you've learned
enough along the way and yeah you've
reached a point where you you know what
to do here you don't need my help
anymore you can pull this off all on
your own and this is one of those things
that's really important i've mentioned
it before i've been challenging you
throughout but i want to leave certain
things in this not actually done to give
you a real initiative to take them on
and to try them because up until now if
you were stuck you'd be able to just
watch my solution a few seconds later or
in the next lesson and
at one point you need to take those
training wheels off and put into
practice what you're learning and maybe
you haven't been doing the challenges
knowing that i was coming up with the
solutions and it's very different to
watch someone else do it and to
understand what they're doing and i'm
sure you've done this before you've
watched tutorials you've understood what
they're doing and then you go to do
something similar yourself a week later
and you just have no idea where to start
so it's really important we've done a
lot of things there's a lot of
similarities there's a few little things
that are going to be different here and
i want you to take what you've learned
throughout all of this and put it into
practice and if you get stuck along the
way refer back to those previous lessons
where you might remember i know kevin
covered this i just don't remember
exactly how to do it and then you can
come and fix whatever you were stuck on
and keep going forward until you're done
because that's what's really going to
reinforce everything that you're
learning here you're in probably the
most interactive way to learn code you
just have to you know
come in pause the video and start typing
stuff take advantage of that and do as
much coding as you can so yeah i'm not
giving you a solution i'm leaving this
one completely up to you i'll give you a
little helping hand just by going over
to here putting the indicator right here
where you need to start and take as much
time as you need with it don't feel
rushed because i know you're going to be
excited to get to the next lesson where
we're going to be starting to get into
the actual design the actual pages and
making things come to life but please do
take the time to complete this first and
then i will see you in that next lesson
when you're ready
so we've finished working on our design
system and now it is time to start
working on the actual content of the
pages and before we dive into writing
some code i just want to look quickly at
what we're starting with from friend and
mentor because they do give us some
resources to be starting with so first
of all we do have the design of all the
pages that we're going to be creating
which we've already been using our
design system fork we have our homepage
we have a destination page we also have
our crew page that we're going to have
to build as well as a technology page
and there's different ways that we might
approach this and this is where you need
to make some choices in how you're going
to do that and this is just a screenshot
we can see all the files are here as
well
in this scrim and if you download the
files from front-end mentor this is in
the starter code section where we have a
lot of html files and this is where
you're going to have to make a decision
based on where your experience level is
at with html css javascript any
frameworks you might be using and all of
that because if we look here we have all
of these crew pages right here we have
all these destination pages right here
and we have all these technology pages
that are right there and you might be
going why do i have all of those and
that's because when we're on any given
one of those designs let's rewind just a
second and if i look at this on my
technologies one we have three pages
because there's three different slides
here so they're providing us the content
for each one of those as a separate page
and if you're newer in your front-end
journey you might decide to take this on
as actual links when you click one of
these it just goes to another html page
and then this one goes to another html
page they're links they're not buttons
and that's completely fine that's
perfect you could do the same thing on
our uh crew page you could do the same
thing on this where each tab is actually
just a different link that brings you to
a new page if you're more comfortable
with javascript then you can add some
javascript functionality with just one
page where we're changing the content or
if you're further along in your journey
what you might want to use is actually
the data.json file which is right here
and we can take a look at that where all
of the information for all of the pages
is available here as a json file so you
could actually populate all the content
using this instead of having to copy
paste and have a whole bunch of divs and
everything and add a bit of
interactivity that way where you're
pulling the information from here for
this because i want it to be a little
more vanilla in terms we're just gonna
be using regular javascript and also
because i'm targeting more of an
intermediate level we're gonna find the
middle ground i'm not going to have all
of these pages here i'm only going to be
having one page for technology one page
for destination and one page for crew
and i'm gonna have all the content on
that page and just create a tab system
using javascript to make it a little
interactive so it's not pulling the
information from here it's not going to
be static individual pages for all of
them it's a middle ground but based on
your skill level if you want to
challenge yourself and pull ahead of me
which i really encourage that you do at
this stage you can choose whichever
direction you want to go in for these
now if you and if you are going that
route we can see that if you go in the
destination all the content is here but
there's no markup or anything so you are
going to be writing your own html to
actually organize the content that we
can see in each one of these so that is
an important thing to know and we are
going to be starting with our index
right here which is our homepage and for
this one we don't have to worry too much
because there's no different tabs or
systems like that it's sort of the
simplest page but at the same time we
will have to do a bit more work to get
our navigation working
so at this stage we have a design system
in place if you feel ready to start
taking what we've done and applying it
you can go ahead and do that or if you'd
rather you could work with me as we go
through the home page here see how i do
it a little bit i'll be starting mobile
first we'll get the whole homepage
working the navigation the mobile
version as well as the large version of
it working and then from there we're
going to work our way into the other
pages so you can always see how i do
this first page and then take what
you've learned from here to push ahead
of me to finish off the other pages
before i look at my solutions for them
all right so it's time to start our work
on the homepage and i'm really excited
for that and here is the design that we
are going to be focused on
we will have to do a little bit more
work for the navigation to finally get
things working here but we will be
breaking this page up over multiple
lessons we can focus on the mobile
version as well as the large version of
the navigation as we run through on this
but before we write any markup let's
look at what we're actually starting
with here so we have some html that's
done for us we have our head that has
the meta viewport which is very
important because this means that our
media queries will work on mobile
devices so that's always a good one and
we have a favicon here that's being
brought in and a title so we're missing
the link to our css file and we're also
missing the link to the google fonts
we've already got those set up in the
design system so we might as well steal
them from there so we can just grab this
right here and i'll take that comment
with it
go back to my index and let's go right
here and paste them in
we have my google fonts that's awesome
and then here we might as well put
another comment just saying that this is
our
custom css
and we have our css coming let's hit
save cross our fingers c and yes we did
something right we already got a win we
can see the colors and the fonts are
coming through so that is awesome
all right so the next stage is to start
writing our html for this and
one thing that people ask me a lot is
mobile first or desktop first when i
style i style based on mobile first but
when i'm writing html i focus on the
desktop first and the reason that i do
that is because this is where the most
complexity in the layout is if i focused
on this everything's stacking i don't
really need to do anything it just it
will stack automatically so i will focus
on this while i'm writing my html and
i'll be using as many of the utility
classes as i have already along the way
and just really quickly for the images
and all that they are in the assets
folder you're going to see that there's
different versions for each one of the
pages and some of the images like our
background we actually have multiple
versions of which i'll be talking more
about once we start styling things up at
this stage though i do think that you're
ready to start going and remember we
have some of these things or at least
this already done sort of in our design
system so don't feel shy about going to
copy and paste it from there and if you
haven't already gone ahead and started
trying this out on your own just come in
and see if you can figure out what tags
you'd be using where what utility
classes that we've already set up and
then i'll go through this and give you
my own solution to it
all right so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to start up here and i'm going to
create a header and i'm going to give
this a class and we might need more
classes on here but i'm going to call it
primary header for now and this isn't
saying that there will be secondary
headers or any other headers but the
header is an element that you can have
multiple on a page this could be if you
have sections or articles within a page
that need a header so i do like giving a
class that i could hook into just in
case and again sites can grow and
different things can happen and if you
style everything on the header element
it could potentially run into conflicts
down the road
then in here i'm going to put a div that
is going to be used close div
this div is going to be used for my logo
and then we can put our navigation which
we already had so let's go and grab that
because as i said we've already done the
hard work on creating a navigation so
why do the hard work twice
nav close nav it has our classes already
on there everything we need so i can
just come here and i can paste it in
there are a few little things that we
will have to change first let's just fix
my tabs so things are sorted out a
little bit better and obviously the
names here need to be updated and we
need a new one so i'll do that really
quickly
and there we go i can delete this and
let's hit save and just see there we go
look at that we have a navigation it's
not going to go anywhere yet but at
least it is working and we already have
our index we can do an index.html here
we know this one is going to go to my
destination.html
and there we go i have that set up and
ready to go now as i mentioned this div
i'm going to be using for my logo and
the reason i put a div here instead of
just putting an image is we are also we
need flex on this because both in this
version and in this version we always
have two columns that are popping up
here and if an image is a flex item
there are some bugs that can come up
with that that are well known um
especially within chromium and pretty
much all of that gets fixed if they're
inside a div because the div is the flex
item and then the image can just be a
normal image so here i'll come in with
my image src is going to be equal to
we want to go to our assets and from our
assets it is in shared and then we have
logo.svg
and i will give that alt is equal to
space tourism logo
and i'm also going to come and give that
a class of logo just in case and we
probably will need to add some styles to
that just to control it a little bit
better so let's hit save and go and
there we go we have a logo now so it's
not perfect yet but let's come in and
give a flex here on the entire header so
we have one child here and my nav is the
other child here so the flex will make
each one into a column and said save
there we go they're next to one another
it's not perfect but at least we're on
the right track and actually realizing
now when i set this up one thing that i
missed from the design system is all of
these should also have been the
condensed font so we can come and add
that in now which would be font family
songs condensed
and there we go that's looking a little
bit more like the actual one so i
realize the alignment's not perfect
positioning is not perfect but i just
want to use what we already have so
let's go and look now we've got that
done we want to come down to here
and one thing we had created was a
container class
and just as a little heads up we will
actually be changing what the container
is doing but i want to leave it like
this for now and then we'll come back
and modify it a little bit later and how
it's working not just in the size we're
going to take a little bit of a
different approach on what the container
does but now at least we're holding our
content in the middle of the page and
that's working pretty well i can't get
big enough on my small screen right now
but if we could get bigger it would
leave us some space on the sides there
so the next thing that we can do now
that that's all in our container is we
have all of our text and this is right
away a really good look at why i wanted
classes for our typography rather than
setting things up because so you want to
travel to space to me is the h1 and we
have two different styles that are
coming in on there so what i'm going to
do is take this entire thing and we're
going to open our h1 here
and we're going to close our h1 down
here
and so you want to travel too and we can
throw a span on this one right here and
we can close our span because it is one
sentence this is not a heading five
followed by and heading one of space the
h1 should be the title of your page so
you want to travel to space is one
sentence that all goes together and it's
just a visual difference for people that
are visiting it so what we can do now is
so you want to travel to space on my h1
we have some utility classes we can use
so the color on there is my accent color
so we can use text accent we have my
font size and the font family size
condensed as well as having the upper
case
and hit save it's looking good except
obviously space needs to be changed a
little bit right here so on space we can
come here and give this a class is equal
to and that would be my font size 900 my
font family
serif
and my text white
hit save and look at that we're getting
there i know it's not on its own line
and i'm not too stressed about that
right now but look at the progress we've
already started to make uh the last
thing i just realized that we missed
here would be my letter spacing so on
here
i'll do the letter spacing at the end
letter spacing
one just there we go now we're really
rocking and rolling so now we can jump
down into this paragraph that is down
here and if we go and take a look to me
that's just one big paragraph that we
have so that's nice and simple we can
just throw a p and close our paragraph
right here and we shouldn't actually
have to do anything else on that that i
can think of so i'm going to leave that
just like that so let's style this
explore button and we'll look at that
we've already done all that we don't
have to do it again so we can go to our
design system and right here we have my
explore button so i can just copy that
come back on over to here and paste that
in and hit save and we get this giant
explore button that's coming up and
maybe going what's happening here why is
my explorer it's working it's just if
the browser is larger it's exploding and
getting really big and it's an
interesting reason why that happens so
let's go to our css and look at what
might have caused that it has to do with
our display of grid
large button we did a display grid so we
could easily center the text in the
middle of it
the problem with this is when you do a
display of grid it's actually making it
into a the grid is an inner display
value and the outer display value
becomes block and because it's a block
level element it's just growing to fit
the page automatically
i think however i'm going to end up
setting this up in this two column
section like this it's not really going
to change too much along the way so what
we can actually do to fix that is to
come on here and actually say it's an
inline grid and then it means it won't
automatically expand to take up as much
space as it can because it's more of an
inline element on the outside and a grid
element on the inside
and even with how we're going to set
this up i don't think it would be an
issue but i will leave it like this for
now because that does the job that we
need it to and it could be good if ever
we have to use it in a different place
all right so our homepage it's not
amazing but it's getting there and the
next part i'm going to do is to fix the
layout on here
and then after we do the layout we can
do a few little tiny touches before we
get to the navigation itself so
there's a few things let's first jump on
over to my back to the index here
because we're going to need a couple of
things that are different
one of them is on the body here i'm i'm
going to give this a class it's equal to
home
because we do need to set background
images on these pages and this is going
to be one way that it opens the door for
those
another thing that we're going to want
to do is play with this container a
little bit and this is where i'm
actually going to keep this utility
class because it's something that's very
useful but i'm going to change this to a
second one which is grid container
and the reason why i'm gonna do this is
actually because of this page right here
um if it wasn't for that all the other
pages we have actually have like a very
consistent spacing on everything but
here we have this image that peels off
the side and stretches off and sort of
breaks out of the container and so by
coming up with a grid container that's
going to replace our regular one it's
going to be the easiest way to achieve
that type of effect and this is one of
those important things that i know we
created in our design system before you
do want to keep an eye on what's
happening on the other pages but just we
didn't have to make a layout yet so i
didn't want to dive into creating the
grids and all of that at that time i
really wanted to focus on all of those
sort of more functional utility classes
and now we're worrying a bit more about
layout so we'll dive into here
and how we can sort of set something up
like this that will help when you get to
this page here
and so for the grid container i'm let's
go back over to our index here and let's
find that container class because we
actually want to sort of replicate it
but with grid in an interesting way
so we have a regular one there so i'm
going to come here and i'm going to do
grid
container
and so this is going to be a display
grid as the name sort of entails
and i had a padding in line of 2m before
for the spacing on the left and the
right and i want to maintain that
so one way we can maintain that is and
all this will be with our grid template
columns that i'm going to set up so we
could do a 2m on that side something
here and then a 2m on the other side and
that means that we have
like a grid column on the left that will
be two a grid column on the right that
will be two and then something in the
middle that could be something looks
something like this and that could sort
of set the stage so if you have an idea
of how we could do that to sort of set
the stage with this 80 in the middle
without it being locked in 80 because if
i do 80 rem here and i hit save on that
it's actually going to like break
everything right because now we have
this grid that's locked in at 80 pixels
wide and you can see everything sort of
went all wonky because of how the
some stuff is actually going into those
columns that are two ram on the two
sides that we don't want to do right now
but uh we can see that we have this sort
of broken thing with a lot of over
scroll going on so if you know how to
fix that and you've used grid before and
you can think of a solution you can come
in and do that now and if you're not
sure just wait a second and i'll give my
solution
all right so instead of doing an adram
like that what we can do is a min max
and with a min max value if you've never
seen it it's let's set a minimum value
and a maximum value and so we could say
is zero pixels can actually literally be
zero and then the largest it's allowed
to get to is my adren and i'm gonna go
with a bit smaller here just um so we
can see it a little bit better in
scrimba what's actually happening and
let's hit save on that and go take a
look and you can see that now things are
there and you will see that it is
actually still sort of breaking but
that's just because the button is
overflowing it has nothing to do with
anything else it's really just the
button overflowing out the side you can
see that that middle area is actually
shrinking and growing right now whereas
if i switch this back to just being
let's do 60 for the moment
and i come back you can see that text in
the middle it's not shrinking because
it's locked in because this is what's in
that middle column right now
so by having the min max here instead it
means the middle area is growing and
shrinking
the only thing is we don't have one
column really in the middle we have two
and we have two here and every page has
two columns on it
so for me the easier solution isn't only
to have one column here it would be to
have two columns instead if you can
think of a way to do that go ahead right
now and set that up
all right so there's a couple of
different ways we could do it we could
actually just take this i'm going to
drop that down to 30. i'll do 40 so we
go back to our original 80 size that we
had
and we could just take this and put two
of them and so we're saying we have one
column is two rem one column is this one
column is this and then that so now we
actually have four columns you can see
my layout has changed a little bit
because everything is sort of just
trying to squeeze into the spaces it has
available and that works and that gives
us our four columns
if you want to make this a little bit
shorter another way you could achieve
the same thing is by doing a repeat here
and then with repeat you can repeat
things as the name sort of implies so we
do repeat comma and then ha so repeat
two times and this so we're getting two
columns of our min max 040 and then a 2m
on both sides now i am going to do one
more step and then give you a little
challenge to do so
let's go and take a look at what we've
created just really fast here where we
have our grid container and we have all
of this in our grid container
so for this to really work and the
easiest way i think just to make sure
this is grouped on one side and that
button is grouped over on the other side
i'm going to wrap this and i'm literally
i'm not even going to name this class
i'm just going to do a div that ends
right here close div and if you named it
that's perfectly fine but we don't
really need to name it
uh for this purpose and then we open a
div there and we're gonna close that div
right here close div and let's just fix
our spacing a little bit here okay so we
have a grid container with one and two
children in there and in every situation
for the other pages we can do the same
thing so here we could have one for this
one and then one over here and the other
pages well we can set these all up to
have two columns effectively inside of
them and even our button i don't know if
it even needs to be in a div necessarily
we could just leave that on its own but
we'll leave this like this for now just
because it makes it a bit more
repeatable
where you just throw whatever content
you need into each one of the columns so
what we can do for that is and again
this wouldn't necessarily work for every
possible site that you're doing in the
future but
in this one where it's very consistent
how this grid container is going to work
from page to page to page we could say
the first child is a grid column
of one over two and you could actually
we could just say one and it's going to
work and then we can take that same
thing and you want to guess what i'm
going to change this to
that would be last child here and that
would get a great column of two and i
just realized this should actually be
two and three
now the one problem that we're running
into if we go and take a look is well we
have some overflow we're going to talk
about that in a minute and there's
actually two things i can think of that
i think you could try and do one of them
is something we've already looked at so
if you're not familiar with grid i think
you could still solve this problem and
there's a second one where our content
is actually stuck to the left of the
page instead of being centered on the
page and again we're trying to recreate
this idea with a margin of zero auto or
auto on the left and the right we're not
doing that with our grid this is my auto
feature or function right here so the
first thing is i want some spacing in
between them now we have overflow that's
happening because of the the sizes on
some of this and this text is actually
overflowing because it's one word we're
gonna solve that problem later
um but i want like here you can see how
close this text is getting to my button
so
think of something we've done before
that has allowed us to add space so you
can try doing that and if you're
familiar with grid see if you can find a
solution to these two m things on the
side to actually have them act as a
a buffer at small screens that will
allow as much space as we need at big
screens
so let's start with one of them which is
my gap and we can just come in and say a
gap of say to ram and that's going to
give us a space and i'm actually going
to do this one only as a column gap not
that we have any rows but just in case
and so the column gap is in between
these so you can just see now compared
to before and if you want you can pause
and comment the code out and play with
it you'll just notice that this text
here isn't getting as close to there
delete the word space even if you want
and it might give you a better
illustration that we're getting now a
gap in between my button and what we
have on this side so you can give that a
try if you want but we've also seen that
we can come in and we can come in here
and give this a ver and i'm going to
call this one container gutter and it
could be container or no with container
gap just because it would be more
consistent with the naming that we've
had on other gaps throughout here and we
could default that to to rem and that
way if we need to change it for some of
the different pages where we need less
space or more space it becomes very easy
to do and if we don't need to change it
it just sticks at the to rem the other
solution was that spacing thing on the
sides where we don't want it to stay
here
so for this and this if you don't know
grid you probably wouldn't know the
solution to this but it would be a min
max where the minimum is 2m
and this could be rem 2. it wouldn't
change anything in this situation and
then the large is a 1fr and fr pretty
much just means take as much space as
you need or take the available space and
use it
so if both of this have a one fr and a
one fr when we get to the larger sizes
it will hold the content in the middle
now the only issue is uh in my window
right now in scrimba is a little bit
small so i'm gonna bring this down to 30
just so we can really visualize what's
happening but if you're on a larger
screen you could leave that at 40 or you
could choose a different number that you
want for the total there and what we can
do is come take a look now and we should
see let's refresh our page and when it's
at the small sizes we have our two
columns ignoring the overflowing text
but you can see that this text in this
text is breaking so we have two columns
right there and actually let's highlight
those let's just come here and say uh
outline
one pixel solid red just so we can
really see what's happening and this one
can be a one pixel solid yellow
and if we go and take a look we can see
our two columns now and just that the
space is overflowing out and they're
gonna get bigger bigger bigger and then
at one point there we go they lock in at
that size and those two other ones those
frs come in and save the day and just
hold everything in the middle of the
page and that's one of my favorite
things to do with grid so we can see
that that i think is looking really nice
right now it's working great so if you
want to play around with this experiment
with that a little to really understand
what's happening go ahead and do that
and then i'll see you soon in the next
lesson
all right so we can continue on our
homepage and start trying to get it a
little bit closer to what we see on the
page right now uh one of the things that
we are going to do though is we're going
to take advantage and you might remember
a long time ago when we did our reset
on the body itself i gave it a minimum
height of 100 vh and this is really
going to help us
because if we come and look at our grid
container right now and i look at here
and i look at the height of it now let's
do an outline of
five pixels solid
and we'll do lime green so it stands out
compared to the other outlines we have
and it's not stretching the entire space
that we need and ideally it would just
take up the rest of the available space
on the page so one way we can take
advantage of that minimum height we did
on our body and this is going to help us
on all these pages that we're creating
right now
is along with this we're going to add a
little bit more we're actually going to
throw a display of grid on here which is
going to help all the items that are on
here stretch out
now when we go and take a look what's
happened is now you can actually see it
it is stretching out and we don't quite
see the bottom of this but effectively
they're stretching but there's this
weird thing going on in the height as
you can see
which is that then it's sort of dividing
the space somewhat equally
and it's the leftover space underneath
my navigation is the same as the
leftover space here and it's dividing it
between the two of them
so to fix that i'm going to set up a
grid template rose
and we're going to do a min content for
the top and an auto or one of our uh for
the bottom and what that's going to give
us now if we go back look at that we
have the grid itself is stretching the
outline's actually bleeding off the side
of the page a little bit so maybe what
we'll do is we'll find our grid
container here and we'll just switch
that outline
that we had to a border
so now we'll actually see there we go we
can actually see the border uh on our
screen
and now we can see how that's sort of
giving us a lot more room to play with
so our entire page is a display grid
which is allowing this to stretch and
fit that minimum height that we have and
now we also have the advantage within
this of the
because the green box our our grid
container is a grid that we have the
grid inside here and we can play with
the positioning of our elements within
that
now obviously we've run into a few
little things is small screens this is
definitely not working so let's fix that
and we're going to use a media query to
do it so here where i have my grid
container it's really nice and easy to
do we can keep everything here exactly
the same i'm just going to grab this
take it out and put a media query so add
media
and i'm gonna do a min width and we'll
talk about what my min width is going to
be in a second but then we can choose
our grid container once again and throw
that right in there
and the other thing i do want to do is
actually grab these right here and also
move them up into this media query
because
this is a display grid um and i you know
we could move this grid down to here but
it could come in and be useful for gaps
and other things so i'm going to leave
the grid on the grid container itself
but that could be something we move off
into the media query but um because this
has a grid column two and a grid column
of three
even though we're not defining any grid
columns here it will actually place them
on a grid column two and three will
create those columns for us because
we're telling them they have to live
there so if we do this now what it's
going to do is actually it will only
apply them when we've created our
explicit columns here and i'm going to
go with a 45 rem which comes out to i
think it's about 760 pixels which is
often where like these tablet layouts
sort of reach that maximum size you want
and things start looking ugly on them
and we want to sort of go more into the
desktop style layout so i'm going to do
it like that and let's go and take a
look at what that's given us so when we
look at the smaller sizes now we can see
that there we go it's breaking we have
some overflow that's happening because
of the navigation so why don't uh in the
meantime until we get to that let's just
take our navigation and comment it out
so we can really focus on what's
happening here so there we go we can see
we have my two columns that are then
turning into one column and everything
is stacking and then we can go back to
our two and that is pretty awesome now
we're missing some things that are
specific to the home page layout but as
far as the functionality of the
container itself i think it's working
really well at this point and it should
work for us uh well at on all of the
pages we are running into a few
different things that we clearly have
this space thing that is you know the
space is overflowing out the side which
is a little bit problematic and ideally
you know our container would probably be
a little bit bigger than this as i
mentioned but i set it to a smaller size
but it would still run into this
potential problem of some overflow
happening and that is something that's
actually going to affect us across
multiple pages with the titles and i'll
explore why that is in the next lesson
okay so this space right here is causing
us some issues where it's overflowing
and as i mentioned this is going to
happen on other pages as well and this
is going to happen because we focused on
the design system that was provided and
actually all the font sizes there were
based on the largest sizes available and
not on the tablet or on the smallest one
and if you go into your figma file
you'll be able to do the inspecting and
find all the font sizes you need and
you'll see that some of them are only
smaller at smallest screen sizes some of
them at the tablet screen size they're a
little bit bigger and then they get even
bigger at the large one and our big
space title here is one of those ones
that does adjust between the different
screen sizes and the different layouts
and there are many other ones that do as
well so if you want to go through and
dive in and get them you can i don't
mind if you do all the hard work there
but this is going to be made a lot
easier for us because of these utility
classes and especially these custom
properties that we created
uh if you come from a background with
sas variables and you haven't done a lot
with custom properties you might
remember a system where you'd have like
a font size small 900 font size medium
900 font size large 900 and then you'd
actually have media queries where you're
changing what this is the font size
every time so my 900 you have to
redefine each one of these selectors
within a media query every time
luckily we don't have to do that anymore
with custom properties because we can
redefine custom properties within a
media query and we've already made that
executive decision that our larger
screen sizes will kick in here at the 45
rem
so i'm going to come up and use that
over here i'm going to say that we're
going to have our at media with a min
width of 45 rem
and in here we can do our route and if
you're up to it and you want to redefine
all the sizes these are as i mentioned
the ones from our largest screen size so
that would be the ones that go here
if we want to sort of follow along with
what the what's provided in the figma
file we can have an app media min width
of around 35 rem which would be our
tablet sizes and this comes up to 560
pixels and actually i put ram on all of
these i normally use m for my media
queries
and there is a reason for that and it's
just safari treats media queries a
little bit differently
than the other browsers if you zoom in
and out on them and if you use rem or
pixels whereas if you
have them set in m it actually treats it
in a similar way so we'll go with m on
these so everything sort of behaves the
same between all the different browsers
um and this is where the tablet one
would come in as i said it's around 560
pixels so it's a little bit bigger than
the tap the mobile design but we're
getting into that tablet and then here
we'd hit the larger sizes
at this point so if you want to go
through and dive in and try and redefine
them all and get all of these and then
see if it matches up with what i come up
with by all means you can go for it and
in just a few seconds i'll just come in
and do it so if you just want to wait
for that
and then see the magic results of it all
you can come in and we're going to do
one more thing with our typography
before i let you go
all right so i'm going to start with the
tablet layout and the tablet sizes which
are going to be right here
and these are at the smallest one so
that that's going through all of the
tablet ones just finding each one
correlating it to the design system we
had and these are the sizes that i found
then what i want to do is i want to come
in and get the ones for my uh right here
just like that and you'll notice i'm not
redefining all of them i'm only
redefining the ones that are changing so
my body font size went from this really
small
15 pixels to a 16 so we can go to one
rem and then at the larger sizes it goes
up to the 18 so we can redefine each one
of those along the way whereas the 300
it stays the same throughout all of them
and the 200 also i believe stays the
same throughout all of them except here
actually we also have this one that
would come in right there
because that's where this one gets to
the biggest size and then
on this one again this we don't need
here anymore this one so the 900 is at
the same
800 they're not the same so we'd leave
800 700 is bigger 600 is bigger
500 is the same as we had in our
original one so i don't need to redefine
it 400 we want and then these two i also
don't need because they're the same as
our original declaration here
so this is where we're starting we're
changing them and then changing them
again here so if we go and take a look
we should see that space we're still
going to have an overflow issue but
we're going to see that when we get to a
small enough size that it is redefining
so we know the media query is working we
can see that everything is working we
can see those font sizes switching
on the body as well as we go through on
these and the body font size gets
smaller and then it gets smaller again
even though some of those changes are a
little minor and hard to see
they are happy or the button especially
you can see the button gets smaller and
smaller there and maybe we'll have to
adjust that actually so it doesn't get
too small at small screens but i did
mention we're going to do one thing a
little bit differently um and that is
with these really big font sizes we can
actually run into some problems with
them as we can see here with our space
and this is where sometimes executive
decisions have to come in but we also
have like this thing right where we have
the tablet where we're here and
everything maybe would be okay then we
have the bigger font one and then like
where do we get things to change um and
so we know this is our smallest size we
know that this is our biggest size so
what i'm actually going to do is remove
this completely and come in with a clamp
value here instead and if you don't know
about clamp clamp allows us to do is set
a minimum size so we know the smallest
we want it to ever get is 5 ram it
allows us to set a middle value and it
allows us to set a maximum and the
maximum was our 9.375
rem and for the middle value we wanted
something that's going to allow it to
grow and to shrink so what we often see
is viewport units and usually if you're
using viewport units it's a good idea to
also include a rem value as well just to
uh viewport units won't react to zooming
in and out so if somebody needs to zoom
in and out it could lock things in so
even though this is really big i'm still
going to do it just for best practice
and the you the one thing that can be
really hard to figure out is this and it
just takes experimentation you could try
with 10 and then we could take a look at
what it's looking like so we can see
that that text is getting bigger and
smaller as the screen is shrinking and
we see it's not actually causing any
issues so maybe you like 10 and you can
see it here it's not shrinking anymore
and we get big enough at one point if we
had a bigger screen it would lock in and
it wouldn't get any bigger and we're
probably very close to where it's
locking in
and you could try doing this at a
smaller growth factor so five would be
much smaller so you can see the text is
really small it's going to be harder for
that to even start to grow because that
five viewport unit's not even kicking in
or you could come in with 50 viewport
units and then it's basically always
going to be the biggest size
because 50 viewport units is so big and
the viewport units is just based on the
width of the screen
so if you want to experiment play with
this i'm going to go with around 8 but
if you want to play with that experiment
with this
there's also a v-min and v-max that you
can play around with and have some fun
with it do a quick search on those if
you haven't heard of them because they
look at either the width or the height
depending on the situation and they can
be kind of interesting too and play with
that if you want to try playing around
with some of these other ones instead
and replacing them with clamps as well
go for it explore that and then when
you're ready i'll see you in the next
lesson
all right so we've fixed some problems
but we still have other ones that are
left and one of those problems is our
title going in a big string all the way
across like this at certain screen sizes
before it breaks back down like that and
even here you can see like the word two
is squeezing in next to it and it
doesn't look very nice
we have some layout issues as well but
for this lesson i just want to focus on
fixing this title so let's just quickly
look at my markup where how we did that
we have an h1
right there with our span inside of it
and if you have a rough idea of maybe
how we can fix that from happening why
don't you jump in and tackle that right
now and then in a second i will show you
my own solution
all right so there's a few different
ways that you could solve this and one
of them would be in your css doing
something and i'm going to throw it at
the bottom because we're actually going
to delete this in a second but this is
maybe an approach you took you did h1
span and then we said display of
block or something like that and that
would work 100
if we go and take a look we should
actually see that it is working so if
you thought of that there we go we can
see that because now the word space here
is always
selected there is always a display of
block nothing can go next to it so no
matter what happens no matter what
layout we come in with space is always
going to be on its own line
and this works but it's a little bit
dangerous because we will have h1s on
other pages and that could potentially
and actually would run us into some
trouble when we get to those so this is
where a class would be better suited
here it could be like home page homepage
title maybe could be something that you
could use to do the same thing and then
over on your homepage you could do you
know add that or for me this is doing
one thing and it's only doing one thing
we don't need it to do anything else
when you have declarations like that go
could this be
a
display block utility class instead i
don't even know if we're going to need
one anywhere else on our site but i'm
just going to move it up here so it's
within our utility classes my grid we
have a display flex a display grid and
now a display block and again if
something's doing one thing and one
thing only it's usually a good idea just
to turn that into a utility class so you
can use it in other places if you need
to so then i could come over here and on
that span we could just add the d block
to it
and
there we go it solved that problem it's
never going to be on more than one line
all right so i'm going to give you a bit
of a mini layout challenge now and what
that's going to be is actually to see if
you can accomplish the same layout right
now with what we have and you might have
to play around with things a little bit
but without a grid container and instead
switching this over to using flexbox and
hopefully for you to be able to see why
i chose grid to do this in the first
place so i'm going to leave this here
for you to tackle and do what you can
with so i'll pop so i'll stop talking
for a few seconds to let you hit pause
and come in and try your best with it
and see what you can do to get as close
to the layout that we had you might have
to add more divs or play with different
classes go into the css do whatever you
need to do to get it to work and then
when you want you can hit play again and
you can watch me take my own try at it
all right so let's come in here and i'm
just going to add we have the flex
utility class so let's start by adding
that and well there we go they go next
to each one one another and that's what
we sort of wanted in the first place so
that's not bad except obviously being a
little bit too wide
and we want to be able to stop it and we
were using our grid for that but luckily
we also have a container class that we
had created so i'm going to bring that
on there the only issue right now is my
container did have a max width of 80 rim
versus the 60 where we're using and so
just for now i will come in with a max
width here of 60 of course i could go in
the css and do the same thing but just
to get a little bit closer to what we
had before and there we go we're getting
there it's a little bit better but it's
definitely not matching the design where
we have this big space in the middle and
we're not limiting the length of things
and it's not quite the same and right
away this is one of the things that i
really like about using grid in certain
situations is i can create a grid and i
can just sort of lock things into it now
with the grid we didn't have a gigantic
gap between them and here obviously we
do but one of the things that we're
going to see in the future lessons this
is going to have a 50 of the room to
play with but within that 50
we can easily align this in the bottom
right side and so the cell is actually
going to be taking up a lot of room and
the content of it is moving over and it
creates that space and then as things
are shrinking down these both state 50
width but just this empty space here
that from that 50 percent is a little
bit less so things just sort of flow
really nicely and that's one of the
reasons for bigger layout pieces even
though this is sort of like a 2d layout
right we're just doing two columns like
that i'm using
i'm using grid more and more for that
type of thing even if i just need two
columns
i find it a little bit easier to set up
and so like one way we could go i'm
going to create an even columns class
here even columns
and then we can come over into my css
and here with my flex what we'll say is
if it's flex with even columns and this
is just to be really clear i'm deleting
it anyway so i'm just going to leave it
like this
actually i don't want to do anything on
that i want to select both children and
then we can give both of these a width
of 100 and there's other ways of doing
this as well this isn't the only way to
do it and let's just save here so i save
my class with it and now we actually do
get two even columns
and just to show you that they are
actually even columns let's also give
these an outline of one pixel solid lime
green just so we can see them
and now we have two even columns in
there and then i can take this explorer
and actually push it over to the right
side a little bit more um and there's
different ways of doing that we could
create a class for it we could come in
and play around
um one thing we could do is actually on
this div we could give like here i'm
just gonna we'll do an inline style
again because we're gonna delete all
this and so here i could do another
display flex and then do an align
uh not a line justify dust defy
content flex and
um and that should line things up over
on that side or it can just break
everything and it's doing that that's
also going to need an align items
start i think we'll fix it there we go
and the reason that happened was just
because by default it's stretch and
because we have an aspect ratio of one
so it's stretching that way and then the
aspect ratio is just making it huge and
it's actually overflowing out of the
area that it has to live so this flex
start means it has to live at the top
and then the justify content pushes it
all the way over to the right side
and this is where with flex you're doing
a display flex or something and then you
have to do something like your even
columns where you actually have to
select the children and
do different things like a flex one
would work here flex basis 100 will work
here i'm not going to go into those
differences now it does create all these
sort of little moving pieces and that's
a nice thing with flex when you want
something to flex like we're going to
use in our navigation you sort of want
these pieces to do their own thing to a
certain extent whereas grid is much more
structured and the parent has so much
control over everything and we're going
to see that we can sort of accomplish
the similar thing that we just set up
now but with grid and see that why i
chose grid in the first place
and for now i'm actually going to leave
this here just in case you want to play
around and experiment with it a little
bit when you get to the next lesson
it'll all be gone we'll go back to our
grid solution and start setting things
up to actually work the way we need them
to to get the layout to look exactly
like we have here so i'll see you over
in that lesson when you are ready
so right now our layout is looking like
this and obviously we need it to look a
little bit different ignoring the
background image
we need the placement of these to be
very different from what the placement
is now and because we're doing a mobile
first approach i am going to start at
the smaller screens and worry about
these first and then we'll work our way
up through the other ones
so if we come over to here we can see
that at the small screens it's not
actually terrible but it's not perfect
either
and there's a couple of different
approaches we could take to fixing this
but the first thing that i want to do is
just get everything centered within the
space that we have so as a quick
refresher we have a grid container we
could do some stuff with potentially but
remember this also would have to be
something that can apply to other pages
as well
we also have a body class of home that
maybe could be useful
if we feel the need for that let's just
go look at our page here and you'll
notice all the text and everything is
centered and if we go and look at the
other layouts as well
on the other layouts on the mobile and
this is the tablet designs were provided
everything is centered on them uh for
each and every one of them no matter
what ignoring the top but like these
parts and don't worry about these titles
but like the main text on all of them is
centered until we get to the large
screen sizes so it follows the same
pattern throughout so that is something
we can do more generically to make sure
everything is centered and then we could
worry more locally about pulling these
down to the bottom because that's
something that's a bit more unique on
the homepage design so if you know how
we can get everything centered like this
then why don't you go ahead and do that
based on what i just talked about i'll
drop you right here i won't give you any
hints and i'll let you go and then
shortly i'll give my own solution
all right so the very first thing i'm
going to do is actually on my grid
container here i am going to come and
say a text align center
uh the reason i'm doing it on the grid
container and not on the body is there
you know i don't want i don't think it
would have any effect on my navigation
anyway because of how i'm setting things
up but it's very specific on all the
pages that it's sort of like the main
things here that it's happening with
i think if you put it on the body it
wouldn't actually cause any issues so
it'd be perfectly fine
and then we already have our media query
set up here for it which also is kind of
convenient because then i can put my
text align here and switch it back to
left so when we get to the large screen
sizes uh we can go back and forth so for
the text alignment that fixes that and
it's already looking a little bit better
i think and you'll also notice that some
stuff doesn't look terrible but this is
kind of stuck to the top a little bit
and we can fix that and i'm going to
we'll fix this button
at the same time while we're here and
then of course at the large screen sizes
we need everything a lot closer to the
bottom so let's again start here and why
don't we actually fix that explore
button and this is one of those times
where the explore button was using if we
go and take a look
i did put the font size 600 and i'm
actually going to take that off because
we don't want that one changing it's the
only thing that i found on the entire
design that doesn't actually change font
size uh that had the font size 600
sizing on it so we can just set that one
manually which was to rem so if we come
to here and we find my explore button
which was my large button we can just do
a search for that there and i can put a
font size here so font size and i'm not
even going to set it to my variable
because again the variable is actually
being redefined so i'm just going to put
two ram here so it just stays at 2 ram
all the time and this is something that
i wouldn't actually do and i don't see
very often but you know you have to make
decisions and have to do these things
every now and then and there we go i
think that's looking a little bit more
to how the design was actually meant to
look when if you take a look at the the
designs that were provided to us
so we're making a bit of progress there
now another thing we can do is i want to
make sure that this text never actually
gets this long and this is something
that also comes up on every page if we
go and take a look the text never gets
too long on anything and there's a few
different ways that we could tackle this
i'm going to try and we could do it on a
paragraph class and then do something to
like center the paragraphs and stuff
like that um which can actually become
problematic when you get back up to
these large screen sizes where this
could actually become centered in a
bigger space which could be a little bit
annoying
so uh what i'm actually going to do
and this is a little bit different i
won't lie compared to something i might
do in other situations but on this grid
container one solution that we could do
is to say dot grid
container
and anything that's inside of it we're
going to give it a max width
of i'm going to go with 45 ch and we'll
see what that does so 45 ch and if you
don't know that's characters and it's
equivalent the ch unit is equivalent to
the
zero character roughly the width of the
zero character so there we go we can see
it's limiting the length of our line and
let's see what it looks like compared to
here and i just realized the color i
think is off on that too so
uh we'll fix that in a second but it's
not too bad maybe we could go a little
bit bigger than that so i'll bump it up
to 50.
and we obviously run into the problem
where it's stuck to the side and this is
where we could try other things to try
and solve this um but it's there's no
problems here it's really just a problem
here
and it
it's only a problem with the center
aligned text you can see it's breaking
everything everything is run into this a
little bit of a mess
right now but luckily it's not too hard
to fix because we are using a display of
grid on here
and so what we can actually use on here
is a place items of center and there's
an align items center and a place items
center they're a little bit different
from each other one of them place item
center is short for
the justify items and align items
whereas a place content would be short
for align content and place content
so we can compare the difference in a
second but you can see that what it's
done is it's actually pulled it's
centering this is still and actually
know what we'll do let's just take this
i'm going to copy this i just it's going
to help us visualize what's actually
happening here
so uh and let's delete these columns
from here
so you can see what it's done is it's
actually it's centering this within like
this top space and it's centering this
within that bottom space that's right
there um so as things get bigger and
smaller it's distributing that space
however we need and it's also centering
them horizontally as well so it does a
nice job of doing both of them
if you used a place content rather than
a place items so place content it's
going to stick them together in the
middle so now you can see that it's
they're glued together there's no space
it's putting all of the empty space on
the top and all of the empty space on
the bottom like that
so that could also be useful if we want
to go more with this approach because
you feel that it matches with the design
a little bit where we have a bit more
space
i do think the other one works better
because of the large spacing that we
could potentially get here on a tablet
design right because we do have a lot of
space we are using grid you could put
this in as a gap value
so we could keep it like that and then
we could do a
row gap and you could actually do this
as a percentage so you could say like 10
uh or 20 or 50
and whatever that is we can see that
it's putting that percentage here
obviously it's causing overflows and
other issues right now
um so that is an option that you could
do it could be viewport units as well
but let's just say we did a
2 10 maybe
um and the advantage with that is is if
somebody's on a really small device
where there's not a lot of vertical
spacing
it potentially works and then as that
gets bigger that space increases so that
could be something um to take into
account or something to think about with
this and how you want to set it up and
create the spacing and then it does keep
it off the top and the bottom or we go
with the align the place items and then
it puts more space here and it does
leave us that cushion on the top and the
bottom so things don't get too close so
that's the solution i'm going to go with
but both of them have their own merit
and you might want to choose one over
the other depending on what you need
and the last thing is here at the small
screen sizes we don't really want the
text being able to touch the sides of
the screen either that one's a nice easy
one though there are multiple different
ways we could do it but i'll let you
give that a shot and then i'll be right
back with my own solution
okay so one of the solutions would
actually be to do something very similar
to this but to have only one
column in the middle and keep that
spacing on the sides if you want to do
that by all means you could but it would
it would involve um separate you know
coming in and actually placing the items
on the right
um within the right spaces here because
if not something could get sucked into
those side little columns that we've
created on the sides and i think a bit
of a simpler solution than that is just
to come in and add a bit of padding
of zero on the top and bottom or we
could do padding in line we've seen uh
padding in line of say one ram on the
left and the right and this could be a
margin as well wouldn't make a
difference but it just means that now
when we get to there the content can
never actually touch the side of the
screen because we have a little bit of
padding there and it just creates a
little bit of a buffer and everything
should still be fine we do technically
have that padding here at the large
screen sizes i don't think it would get
in the way or cause any problems maybe
then you want to drop these down to one
just to make sure that it doesn't get
too big at any of the screen sizes
potentially and the very last thing we
need to do now is to make sure that at
larger screen sizes these sort of stick
closer to the bottom than sticking to
the top and we can sort of take
advantage of some more grid behaviors uh
along the way here so because again here
i think everything is okay but here we
need it much closer to the bottom but we
do need some space which means we will
have to do a few things all of this will
have to happen in our grid container
here i don't want to do it on all the
grid containers though because it would
have an effect on the other pages so
there's two different approaches you
could take to something like this one of
them is we could come in on the index
and we could actually add a different
class here on the grid container and
this is what i'm going to do just so
it's more once again more of a utility
class that we could use in other
situations and we're going to have
another little tweak as well so we could
come in and add a new class here of like
ho grid
container home which is a modified
version of our grid container this
double slash is part of the bem naming
convention which is sort of saying that
we're modifying our grid container
this could be something that could be
also its own utility class of what i'm
going to do or parts of this but because
i'm not building out utility classes
that can be changed within different
media queries like you might see with
something like tailwind i'm going to go
with this approach if you have a
different solution to getting the same
thing that works
and even we have our home class here so
we can even choose like our good
container from our home page only and
select it that way as well so there's
different ways we could select this
and what we'll do with that is
only within this media query because i
want to make sure that it's only
affecting at the largest screen sizes i
am going to say that the grid container
home
is going to do two things one of them is
it's going to have a padding bottom to
create all that extra space on the
bottom so i'm going to say that it's
about six rem and why don't you try and
figure out what it is to move within
grid items all the way to the bottom if
you're not familiar with grid you've
seen a few things coming up now so maybe
you have some ideas that you can test or
just hit pause go into google and google
that see research it see if you can find
the solution before i give it to you in
just a few seconds because that way
you're reinforcing your learning you're
going to remember a lot more so take the
time to see if you can figure it out and
as i said i will give you a solution i
won't leave you hanging
okay so i hope you did find that
solution and i'm going to do an align
items and put end on here which should
move them all the way down to the bottom
and with that i'm also going to save
over here and look at that we have that
they're lining up now on the bottom of
the page and then as we get to the
smaller screen size they stack back one
on top of each other and we're okay and
then we can go back to the bigger one
and they're always going to be stuck on
the bottom
another solution that we can do that's
kind of interesting with this bottom is
we could actually put in a
max function
which would be six rem and we could put
a percentage or viewport heights so say
20 viewport height and the advantage of
this is if somebody was on a really big
screen maybe you don't want it all the
way stuck on the bottom and this max
function it will take the bigger of the
two values so it's bigger 20 viewport
viewport height units or six rem and
let's go and take a look i don't know if
we can actually get it high enough to
start influencing things right now
i can't right now so all right i think
it actually is changing so you can see
that
this is actually a little bit bigger um
and then it's going to lock in at one
point and it's going to get stuck to six
rem and so i could even exaggerate this
why don't we choose that at like 50 and
you can see it's really big and now it's
always going to be choosing the 51 and
it's actually causing overflow because
of it because it's always using the 50
viewport height or if i made this one
now the six ram is bigger so the six rim
will probably always be bigger and it's
always going to lock in just at the six
ram
so something i think like a 10 or a 20
finds that nice balance where once it
gets to a certain size that space is
allowed to continue to grow so if you're
on one of those ultra wide huge monitors
that some people have these days at
least things won't be like glued to the
bottom of the page if for some reason
they're actually on a full screen which
i don't think many people do all right
so there we go that's looking pretty
good i think we can get rid of all of
these borders now because we can see how
things are fitting on the page and how
everything is looking so when you get to
the next lesson all of those will be
turned off and we're going to be getting
into the background images
all right so with our background images
here you can actually see the the image
itself changes here we have it stuck to
the bottom and then when the layout
breaks and goes the other way we can see
that things change and it goes on the
side here instead of being stuck to the
bottom and if we look in our assets we
actually have three different images to
use so let's go and take a look that's
my home page and then we have a desktop
a mobile and the tablet version
that are all going to be coming in and
then we can use all of them in our css
and that is one of the reasons we have
our home class right here that will
enable us to select that so for that in
my css i'm going to come all the way
down to the bottom and we're going to
create a new category called page
specific
we could take some of the container
things that i created that were specific
to this page and include them here if we
wanted to
and here i will put home for the home
page because we will have some different
ones that get changed for each of the
different pages uh but overall we
shouldn't have too much other than the
background images uh actually and so
here dot home let's start off with just
putting a background image on here and
seeing what happens so with the
background image we need a url and we
need in this case it's going to be from
our root we're going into our
assets
and then assets it goes to home and then
it goes to our background and i'm going
to do home mobile mobile first dot jpeg
because we're doing mobile first and
there we go we can see a background
image has come in and it's repeating
itself like crazy but at least it's
there and it's working and that's sort
of as you'd expect at small screen you
know at a big screen that that smaller
image will repeat itself
so let's do a few things here let's say
that the
background size is cover
and we can don't need to bother with the
background repeat no repeat because we
do have the cover on there but the one
thing that happens with the cover is it
crops the image and i don't like how it
crops it um because if we go if this for
some reason we have a shorter page or
whatever is happening the planet sort of
disappears and i think there's a lot of
visual interest with the planet so i'm
also going to say background ground
position of bottom center which is more
or less where the interest lies in that
so let's go take a look and now we're
always keeping that planet bottom center
of course it's getting too big here but
that's okay because we're going to
change it and then here too it's not
looking good we can't read our text but
we're going to be changing the image
along the way so it shouldn't cause any
problems as we go on to these bigger
sizes now these shouldn't actually be on
the home page so i'm going to take those
off of here
and i'm going to come body right here
and place those here just to keep it a
bit more organized
i'm actually going to say backgrounds
and this will just be for background
images i think because i don't think we
need any other page specific styling for
anything
and then it makes sense a little bit
more having this body that's right there
and what i want you to actually try and
do now is to see if you can find a way
to bring those other images in uh when
we get to the different break points and
just use the same breakpoints that i
used above i think they should work
perfectly fine for you
all right so let's see how i would do
that i would just come in here with a
media query and on this media query
we're going to give it a min width and
the first one i used was my uh was a 35
rem so we can come in with that and then
we can come and copy this right here
paste it in
fix the tabs and then change this over
to tablet and i saw something change
already so when we're at the smallest
screen sizes it's looking like that we
start going and you can actually see the
image is switching there because you can
see it's getting blurry and then the
crop on the image actually change is and
it's when that crop happens that we're
switching over and then when we get to
the biggest screen size we need to
change it once again so if you didn't do
it the first time you can go ahead and
bring in your own background image now
at the next breakpoint
all right so i'm going to copy that
we're going to change this one up to a45
and then we can come in here with the
desktop
and take a look at it so let's go and
see if that worked
and we're going to look at this in a
little bit more detail but there we go
perfect so we have it there for the
smallest then we get to the next one and
then it's going to break over and go to
this
and this is a situation where it's
potentially possible that you'd want
different media queries based on a
landscape or portrait as well
but because i'm really focused on screen
width at the moment for when this is
going from one column to two column when
that happens and when it goes from one
column here to two columns here i i
really think it's important that we're
switching from this image to this image
because it's going to keep the text
readable
now we can see a little bit like
something like this maybe this text is
actually getting a little bit hard to
read so maybe it's worth on this one
actually changing the background
position
to the center center
or to come in with a media query that's
dealing with the orientation instead of
the back uh instead of only the screen
size but doing something like that will
help fix the crop potentially so if
where they're at a weird screen size
it's not going to run in where the image
is exploding at the top but if they're
on a more of a tablet with a bigger
screen everything should be perfect so i
think that's a fine solution but if
you'd rather play around and experiment
with different media queries and see if
you can get different effects i'd
strongly encourage you to do that right
now but i think for me and what i'm
after this is actually working really
well right now and i'm pretty happy with
that and i'm pretty happy with this
entire page and how it's looking right
now with everything on it actually
coming together really really nicely so
now we need to be able to start working
on our other pages and actually getting
to other pages and well we can't do that
because we don't have a navigation
that's functioning so in the next
lessons we're going to be diving in and
fixing up our navigation
alrighty time for the navigation which
are always these little simple
components that end up being more work
than anything else on the entire page
and this is we've already seen this
version of it and so now we're going to
be jumping into these ones instead with
a hamburger menu that then has to open
up and have
this and then eventually at larger
screen sizes turn into something that
looks like that there's actually a
middle ground as well that's a little
bit different but for now we're just
going to focus on setting up sort of the
bare bones of everything we need in
place then we'll focus on styling it for
mobile and then we'll worry about what
happens in the media queries after that
so um if we go and look at what we
already have and let's jump over to here
we've already created some stuff and we
already have some navigation stuff
that's created in our css as well so
we've done our primary navigation we
have our underline indicators which are
giving us those little underlying guides
that we have here we have the numbers we
have all of that set up but obviously
and we also have this flex class on here
just to give it a display of flex and
then our active class that's on here we
don't have to worry about that so much
as we need to worry about getting them
laid out properly here and you can see
the active's not actually doing anything
at mobile so there will be some changes
that we do need to come in along the way
on here so the very first thing i'm
going to do before i even jump into the
css and worry about styling things at
all is we're going to make a few little
changes here so in between my div and my
nav here i am going to come in and add a
button and this button is going to be
what our hamburger menu is so close
uh button
and what we're going to put in the
button we're going to write menu and
this is a very standard type of thing to
have in a button that is going to open
and close a navigation menu is writing
menu but we have a way to hide things
that we've already seen we set up a
class for that so if you can remember
what it is to make that visually
disappear you can go ahead and add that
right now
and so hopefully you remember there is a
span class that is equal to
sr only which we use when we set up our
dot menus
and then we can close
that span right there so now we have a
button that's there but it's visually
hidden nobody can see the text inside
but we can still access our button but
for accessibility purposes that is a
good thing we actually
i'm doing small accessibility steps
along the way right now we're going to
have a future lesson that's going to go
through the entire site later on and
sort of fix up some of the other
accessibility things such as the numbers
that we have here but we'll worry about
that a little bit later the other thing
that we want to do with this button when
you have something like this is you want
to i think actually let's first give it
a class because we need to you know be
able to select it so we're going to call
this my mobile nav toggle to just
explain what it actually is
and we're going to say that there it has
an area controls and when you have a
button like this that's controlling
something else it's opening and closing
my nav we want to say what it's doing
for assistive technologies so this is a
little bit more on the accessibility
side and here i'm going to write primary
navigation
but if you do something like this so
we're saying that this button is
controlling my primary navigation it's
not going to look at a class it's only
going to look at an id so i am also
going to add the id here
on my ul right here and so when we click
on this menu button it's going to
control this it's going to open and
close it and there's one more thing we
can add on here as well which is area
and we're gonna say area expanded equals
false
so right now we know that the menu is
closed and if we push on the button then
it will open and we're gonna have to use
a bit of javascript to get that to
actually work and now we've done
everything we need to do to set the
stage and to get things actually working
so uh
once again i'm gonna challenge you to go
ahead and take as much as you you know
go ahead and see if you can just get our
navigation instead of it looking like
what we see here to be horizontal to be
positioned here and all of that take as
much time as you want on it really work
your way on it and then in the next
video i'll come in and style it up so we
can get it looking a little bit like
this and then after that we'll look at
adding the functionality of making it
actually open and close
alrighty so let's get this navigation
actually working and we have our primary
navigation we've already done a few
things on it right here
the first thing i'm going to do is
actually delete this gap because it was
big and it fit with our design system
but it's way too big for what we want
right now so i'm actually going to
delete that from there and then we can
come in and start doing a few things on
it so the first thing i'm going to do is
actually set the flex direction on here
to be row instead of column um and
actually it was row we want a column i
always mix it up every single time there
we go
and now we can see that they're now
stacking one on top of each other and
look at my giant button
but that's perfect they're stacking
exactly what we want and actually it
looks pretty close to what we need
but obviously there's a few more changes
that we want to do and another thing
we're going to do on here as well is
let's come in and give it a position
a position of fixed just like that and
when you do position fixed it's now like
flowing outside of the flow so for the
moment we'll give it a background that
will change but we'll say background is
uh let's do light
green i think will not clash too much
with this design and burn our eyes like
coming in with a red or something might
so there we go we can see that it's
working but obviously we need it over
here i'm going to show one of my
favorite new new modern css properties
which is inset which is a shorthand for
top bottom left and right and it is a
logical property and so i want it to be
stuck to the top so zero offset on the
so this is like saying top zero then i
want to do my right of zero i want to
say my bottom of zero and then we'll
come in with like a twenty percent or so
on this side now it looks gigantic but
remember we're not going to have it
there it's going to be mostly when we're
at these screen sizes right here and
it's going to then change after that so
we can see that it's actually looking
pretty good i think it's positioned
where i want it to be but obviously it's
going below the explore button there
which does not look so good so one way
that we can fix that is when we have a
position we also have z indexes so we
can use that and i'll come in with like
just a big one that i'll probably never
go above and usually a thousand for me
is a very big z index so we can do that
uh the next thing i'm going to do so we
have position fixed we have a background
let's add our let's change the padding
we set padding in margin of zero uh
three rem on the top and then
two rem on the sides so if we go and
take a look we can see it's given us our
bigger space there no space on the sides
and you know this light green is
bothering me so let's change it to black
just so we can actually read our text
and see a little bit more of what's
happening and there we go i think that's
already pretty close to what we actually
need this to be right here with a few
obvious
changes that need to happen
so one of them is actually i think i'm
going to increase my padding quite a bit
on the top here and this is because i do
want to come in with a big value but i
don't want to risk any issues coming
with overflows and stuff this could be a
nice time to use another one we looked
at how max could work but sometimes we
want a minimum so let's say we do a
minimum of six rem
or if someone's on a really narrow say
they're on a vertical display they've
thrown it on their secondary monitor
that's vertical and it's really tall you
could also allow that margin or sorry
that padding on the top to increase so
here you could do like a 20vh and it's
going to choose whichever of these two
is the smaller value
and actually i'm just now that i said
that it's going to choose the smaller of
the two so we can pump this one up to
like a 20
and then this one may be down to a 10
and it's going to choose the smaller of
them so if someone's on a really big big
screen
it's going to lock it and stop it from
being more than 20 rem but it will allow
it to grow and shrink with the viewport
size so depending on it it's going to
grow and shrink just a little bit it
won't be a huge influence maybe we could
pump that up to a 15 and take a bit of a
design design decision on that so just
depending on the screen real estate
that's available
there's a little bit of wiggle room if
you want to play with that number with
bigger numbers just you can see it
working a little bit more go for it and
then in a second i'll finish styling
things up here so you could play around
with that a little bit and then i'm
gonna make one little tweak to the code
i've written and then give you a
challenge so i'll give you a second if
you do want to play with that
and for the challenge that i have for
you um what i'm the one tweak that i
mentioned i'm gonna do is i'm actually
going to come and move most of this up
into a media query media
but i'm actually going to use a max
max width instead of a min width which
for me is very very rare
but this is one of those types of
situations where i actually think
when you're doing navigations like this
where you don't want to have to
overwrite any of these things that
you've done when you get to the larger
screen size it makes a lot of sense for
a lot of other things often you have
less complexity that you're then adding
complexity to when you get to bigger
screen sizes so to me it makes a heck of
a lot of sense in those situations to
actually just be using a min width for
everything but for something like this
to me it makes a lot of sense to be
using a max width so if we
then we can take off this this this the
background black uh the padding can come
become zero again go back a little bit
to my default and the flex
direction can come off and of course if
you do something like this don't leave
your default selectors down here or they
will overwrite your media query will
come up keep your default styling first
then come in with your
media queries afterward and i'm actually
going to boost this up to 30 from 20
just because i think that the number on
that's
going to look a little bit nicer um just
gives us a little bit more space on the
side there
and so yeah i'm pretty happy with that
i'm going to ask you to do two things
for the challenge to finish this one off
one of them is to get rid of this
underline on the active and the other
one is going to be to bring you know we
don't need this hover state we don't
need any of that and the other thing is
going to be to smush these together
because they're very far apart here and
if you look at the actual design they
should be much closer together so uh i
keep pushing this x to close the slide
um so i'll let you go and try your hand
at that i'll give you my solution to it
and then we'll move on to finishing the
styling of this in the next lesson after
that
alrighty so i hope that went well for
you the first thing i'm going to do is
get rid of that underline and there's
multiple different ways we can do it and
the one thing we do have to be aware of
though is if we got rid of our
underlying indicators everywhere that
could actually cause a problem because
we have the tabs that are going to come
in later on that are using these
underline indicators
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
focus here where we already have this
media query and this is again the max
with media query where i think this
makes the most sense to be working and
i'm going to select my primary
navigation
and i'm also going to say when it has
the underlying indicator on it and we
don't actually need this extra
specificity on here
we could just choose the primary
navigation because if we look at our
index.html we have our primary
navigation here which is our underline
indicator so it is both of these
together but we do have the underline
indicators coming lower down in our css
so that could always cause a problem
with how the cascade is working but the
other reason i really like doing it this
way is
first of all the extra specificity in
this case is actually a good thing as
far as i'm concerned we do want to avoid
conflicts of specificity when we can but
understanding how specificity works and
knowing that a boost in specificity
might give you a desired outcome it's
not necessarily a negative to work with
that specificity and work with how css
is meant to be working so it's going to
ensure that plus i think it's really
really obvious what this is doing uh in
this case is i'm changing how the
underline indicators are working when
they're applied to the primary
navigation within this media query and
so on that we can choose then our dot
active and we can just say that it has a
border of zero so if it is the active
one then we get no border on there if we
do this it will actually keep the hover
effect on the other ones which to me if
you're in a mobile device you're not
going to see the hover effect anyway so
it keeps the hover effect for somebody
who is just they put their screen really
small on the side they're not using a
full width screen and it happened to
kick in their media query so i don't
think that's a problem if you like the
idea of just not having one you could
actually put the star here because the
border zero is going to just disable the
border completely and now we won't have
any sort of hover effect at all uh but
i'm gonna stick with having one on there
just so we have a little bit of a a
little something for somebody who might
be on a smaller screen who is on a
desktop computer that just shrunk their
browser window into the corner somewhere
the other thing we want to do is change
the spacing and you'll notice here i
actually left the underline gap here as
well as having it within here so i could
actually come in and maybe set a 0 or a
1 ram or i think in this case about a
point five will match the design pretty
good so we still can keep our effect uh
like that if you removed the border
completely and you decided to go with
having a zero here uh and not just with
the active the spacing might be slightly
different so maybe you'd want to tweak
it but again a nice thing with these
custom properties is you don't even have
to remember how you made this gap
originally we just know that we can very
easily modify that underlying gap and
that's one of the reasons i really think
custom properties are absolutely amazing
these locally scoped ones are something
that people don't take enough advantage
of
so there we have it there is my solution
if you took a different way and it
worked that is perfectly fine as well
but just i was trying to do it in a way
that would make sure that it's only for
the primary navigation underline
indicators and not for everything that
would be the most important thing here
with whatever solution you did come up
with
all right so this background effect is
really cool and it's actually pretty
popular these days um it sort of
exploded for a while and i think it's
slowed down a bit but in this situation
i think it just looks fantastic so hats
off to front end mentor for her uh how
good it looks and this is using
something um the style is called
glass morphism and it sort of gives you
that look of looking through frosted
glass and luckily we can do that with
css now
and it's actually pretty easy to do the
browser support for it is increasing but
it's not perfect as of the time of
recording
with the only major browser that doesn't
currently support it is firefox and it
is behind a flag there so it shouldn't
be too long but we're going to look at
how we can deal with that um when
browsers don't support it so it won't be
something that causes any issues and i
think even i think i saw it working in
nightly the other day so i think it
should be not too long until firefox
does support it anyway
uh but the first thing and actually we
can leave black but i'm gonna i want to
lower the opacity on this so uh we have
our our nice hsl's that we've already
created and actually it's already it's
going to be white um so i'm going to
drop it down to like a really faded out
white for the moment and we can take a
look at what that's looking like so we
have a faded out white background
and um actually we need this background
it's going to have to be on everything
because this is going to be the same
look whether we have it on the side here
or you can see it's the same effect over
here
so what i want to do is come and put
that background right here
and now i want to challenge you to look
it up i told you it's called
glossomorphism i told you we can do it
with css so if you already know how to
do it or maybe you've heard about it you
saw something a while ago try it out and
if you've never heard of it before do a
little google search see if you can find
the solution and implement it before i
show you how to do it and then if you
get stuck or you just want to compare
notes to how i do it i'll be showing my
solution in just a few seconds
alrighty so to get this to work we use a
a property i was going to say function
but it's a property called backdrop
filter and with that we alter filter and
with that we use the blur function and
then we just have to come in and say how
much we want to blur things and we have
to put a value in so i'm going to say
one rem and just see what it looks like
you already see it third let's go look
and hey you know what one ram looks
pretty close to what we have there um so
not too shabby and you i you know and we
can see it's already working up here too
and we have to finish styling that to
make it look where it needs to go but
the effect is working all around you can
tweak the number here so like if you did
a pure white background it's not going
to do anything it really relies on you
having a transparent background and then
it shows you so i mean you could come in
with zero you don't even need to have
any color on here whatsoever and it will
blur it
so if you do come in with a color it
does need to have like an opacity to it
you can't have a pure color so just be
careful with that i do think the point
one was actually a little bit strong i'm
going to come in with a 0.2
maybe a 0.5
something very minor to try and match
theirs and maybe we could even increase
this blur a little bit because they look
like they really blurred things
and it might not match the figma design
perfectly but we can get awfully close
to what um was provided for and you know
what i think that's looking pretty much
bang on it's such a cool effect it looks
really good and again it's working here
we just need to fix that but um yeah i
think it's looking fantastic it's a
really fun effect and you can play
around with it tweak it try different
color combinations just to see what it
looks like and then when you're ready
we'll go on to the next lesson where
we'll look at how we can deal with
browser support
all right so this is looking good if
you're in any browser that does support
it and if you're in firefox it would
instead of looking like that it's
currently looking like this because
backdrop filter is not supported and
that means that the navigation actually
is unreadable we can't see anything
that's going on there with all this
overlapping and everything so what i'm
actually going to do is fix what here
let's let's set this up as a default
which is going to look good so i'm going
to boost this up to like in maybe we'll
try seven five on the opacity and let's
change this to our dark so we still get
sort of this transparent effect and
actually maybe even go up to an eight
five or
even maybe a point nine
uh could look really good so yeah we
still get like this transparent effect
coming in it doesn't look as nice but at
least we're getting a workable
experience we can read our text and all
of that maybe even a 9.5 would be better
because i'm really want to make sure
that the contrast is high enough to make
the menu really easy to read
and then what we can do is come down
here and do it at supports
and if you want to give this a try i can
do ad supports like this and you can go
ahead and research it and see if you can
get this working
where if the browser supports backdrop
filter blur then we get the effect with
the background that we wanted and if it
doesn't well then it's going to use this
default that we've assigned right here
so go ahead research that it's not too
difficult to do and then once you figure
that out i'll show you my solution
all right so for add supports what you
want to do is bring in a property value
pair so i'm going to copy what we've
already have here and drop it right
there and it is very important to both
the property and the value as well and
the value here could be anything like we
could even put zero ram as long as it's
a valid value that we're putting here it
will work and that's because it needs
the property and the value because some
browsers will support a property but may
not support certain values or of course
sometimes it just doesn't support the
property at all before add supports to
work you need to have both the property
and the value if you only put the
property it's not going to work and then
we can come in with my primary
navigation and just get what we had
before so i'll copy this right here
paste it in add the blur back in and
and then come change this back to the
point zero five i think i had it as and
then change this back to my color white
and if you're in chrome you should see
it working nicely and again if the
browser doesn't support it this whole
thing comes out and at least they get a
workable experience
so this is a nice way to add in cool
features and to provide a fallback and
it works so well and it's really easy to
do
can you believe how long we've been at
this and we haven't had to write a line
of javascript yet uh but here we are
we're going to have to get some to
actually get our button working but not
yet we still need a little bit of css uh
to get our button in the right spot so
what i'm going to do is just a little
bit of styling then see if i can get you
to get the the icon in there and then
we'll go from there to add in the
functionality of everything so if we go
and take a look at our index we do have
our button that is right here and i did
give it the class of mobile nav toggle
so what i'm going to do is actually say
right here that my mobile
nav
toggle is a display of none so it
disappears when we're well just
disappears right now because i don't
want it when we're at large screen sizes
and display if none will pull it
completely out of the dom so it's not
something that like an assistive
technology or anything like that will
run into but when we're here we really
need that button so then what we can do
is within this media query we can come
in and turn that
mobile nav toggle back on by saying
display block you can also then position
it position absolute because we need it
to be wherever we want it to be uh we're
going to come in with a z index and i
said a thousand is really big we're
going to go with the 2000 now because we
need it to be on top of our primary
navigation and now we just need it to be
in the right spot so i'm going to say
what right of one rem and we'll do a top
of two ram just so we can actually start
seeing it come in we can see that it's
actually in the right spot
uh what we do want though is a
background of you can put background
none background transparent background
zero they all work i'll use transparent
just so it disappears it's a button so
we also want to say it is a border of
zero on here and now we need to actually
see the icon and you know our button is
there it actually exists but we can't
see it and so i'm gonna you know what
how how could we get the button to be in
there without placing it in our html
because we have our menu text here so we
don't actually want to come and place
the image here so bringing it in with
our css rather than uh placing it in the
html makes sense so go ahead place it
there right now and then i'll come and
take a look at that in a second
all right so i'm gonna do it with a nice
background image that's it background
image and if you didn't get it you might
have been overthinking things and so
we're gonna go from our route into our
assets into our shared into our icon
hamburger.svg
and if you just did that you would have
seen it come in but we can't really see
it um so what i'm going to do and i sort
of want this to be a nice little square
that people can click on so let's give
this a width of 1.5 ram and give it a i
won't give it a height i'm going to give
it an aspect ratio
of one
which should give us the right sizing
and we can see that it's come in but it
looks kind of funky um and that could be
because it's a background image so i'm
going to try one thing here with a
background
in it a background repeat
no repeat just to make sure
there we go that's what it was it was
the image was repeating itself downward
and we were getting an extra thick bar
on the bottom so we have that in place
and now obviously what we want is this
whole guy should actually be hidden away
when we click that it slides in yeah so
what we're going to do here on my
primary navigation is add in a transform
of a translate x
and on my translate x we can say 100 and
it's vanished and it's moved 100 of
itself away off to the side and it
actually i see we're getting an overflow
when i hover i thought we'd actually get
an overflow when i did that
and i was waiting for this point to do
an overflow of hidden so this is one on
this site so we can come all the way up
and just so when things start moving
around and we start animating there is a
good chance that there is some overflow
that does happen so i'm going to go
uh here on my body and we can just say
that the overflow
x is hidden
uh because it is possible that some
scrolling will come in uh when we click
and it should slide our menu open and so
that means we need to come in and start
writing some javascript if you're not
familiar with javascript don't worry i
will be giving solutions to it but if
you are familiar with javascript i would
recommend you seeing if you can come in
with a way to get it to slide in and
slide out and if you're able to also get
it to change the background image so you
can come right here and start doing that
you will have to go into your css
potentially to add some extra classes
and do some stuff in there and just to
get the transitions working and all of
that and when you're done with you might
even need to go to the html maybe add a
few little things there and when you're
done with that you go to the next lesson
to see how i complete this or if you
don't know at all where to start with
this and you want a few hints and tips
along the way we'll be looking at that
in the next lesson
all right so we can start writing some
javascript now so i'm going to delete
this comment from here and before we
even get started on this i'm going to go
over to my index and i'm going to come
up to the top and you might hear that
you should keep your javascript at the
bottom and i'm going to come here and
what i'm going to do is link to our
javascript um so it's script src is
equal to and index.js
and i'm just going to come in here with
a differ
um just like that and then click close
script or not click but write close
script and everything should be
perfectly fine here um the deferred here
just lets us keep our script at the top
so we can have everything here but it
will defer the loading of the javascript
until the page has been loaded and now
we can go in and start writing some
javascript and so what do we want to do
well we want when someone
clicks the hamburger hamburger menu
if the menu
is closed open it
if the menu is open close it
and we need to with those also change
the icons or the symbol you know we want
to change it to the x and back and forth
but for a very simple thing this is
basically what we want to do
so when someone clicks on the hamburger
menu we want to the hamburger button i
should say or the hamburger menu
if the menu is closed open it if the
menu is open closed all right so that
means we need two things in our
javascript we need our hamburger button
i shouldn't write the hamburger button
and we need to find our navigation so if
the nav is open or closed instead of
menu would probably be better
so if we need those two things so first
let's come in and say uh we'll get the
nav itself so const nav and this is a
name that i'm making up if you're not
familiar with javascript uh const is
just a way to store things so i'm gonna
go into my document and do a query
selector
and we're going to select my primary
navigation
and we're also going to do a const for
my nav toggle which is my button and so
we need to find that one as well
and now we have both of them that we can
access and do something with
so the first thing is when somebody
clicks on the hamburger menu so how can
we do that well the hamburger menu is my
nav toggle so we're going to start there
and we need to add an event listener and
an event listener we're listening for an
event that's going to happen and what
are we looking for well we're looking
for a click
and if somebody clicks on it we want to
do something and so this is an arrow
function so we have our nav toggle which
is our button and if somebody clicks on
that we want to do something so now what
we need to do is check if the nav is
open or closed and the thing is we don't
really have a way to check for that
right now
so there are different approaches to
this sometimes you see a class nav
opened or nav closed and you can check
if that class is there toggle a class or
something like that
but when we're you writing javascript i
prefer using data attributes which allow
me to hook in and sort of be you know
that i know that my classes are for
styling and then i know that my data
attributes are for javascript and it
sort of just lets me hook in that way
so we have my primary navigation right
here which is what we've selected right
here and this is what we want to check
we want to see is it opened or is it
closed
so on that primary navigation that we
have right here i'm going to add the
data visible is equal to false
because right now it's it's not visible
we can't see it and if you haven't used
data attributes before these are
attributes that you get to invent
they're your own ones you can write
anything you want uh just it's prefixed
with data and you could have like
visible you know you could even have it
like is
this the z bowl if you wanted to but
then you're you know we're just getting
a little long so i'm just going to say
data visible is equal to false so
visible is equal to false then we can go
back into here and we can use that now
so what we can do is we can check for
that visibility first so we can say
visibility
is equal to
and now before i was doing a document
query selector because i was looking
through the whole document to find my
primary navigation but now we already
have my nav so i can choose my nav so
i'm doing nav dot and i can look for
things like the attribute so i can get
the attribute that's on there and what
attribute do we want well we want our
data visible and why don't we see what
that's going to give us by doing a
console log so console.log and we can
console.log our visibility
that we just created
so when we click on this we see false
because every time we click on it we'll
get a false or we can even open our
console here and you can see all the
falses that are coming in and every time
i click on it we'll get another false
that pops up because that's what our
visibility is currently false so we know
that's working all right so if the nat
so we know now that it's working uh and
that we're getting false so if it is
closed we want to open it so the first
thing we can do is we want to start with
if
so we can say if visibility is equal to
uh false and i'm putting this in
quotations because um the data when
we're getting the data attributes it's
not going to return a boolean it will
return it as a string so if the
visibility is equal to false what do we
want to do well we want to do one thing
which is going to be nav and we can
actually change the attribute now so nav
set attribute of that
and we can change that over to true and
now we can test to see if this is
actually working because we have that
set up so let's go over and click on it
and it's false so now when i click it
should say true and it does so we can
see that it's working we're going back
and forth between true
and false or actually we're not going
back and forth we set it to true and
that's it and so yeah we need to be able
to set it back so right now we're saying
if it was if it was not visible so if
the visibility is false we're going to
set the visibility to true
else we want to do the the opposite
right so then we want to take this and
set it to false
so let's do false here and what that
means is it should now go back and forth
false true false true and now we can
actually see it's rotating between them
every time we click so that is perfect
so i don't think we need our comments in
here anymore i think it's pretty and we
already got that
the one issue now is we actually needed
to open and close
so there are different ways we could do
this but we might as well we have our
data visible here and the data visible
is switching between true and false so
that means we can come into our css and
we can actually change that
so then on here with my primary
navigation we can add in primary nav
irrigation and we can add an attribute
on here and so we can check to see if
the data visible is equal to
is equal to true
then we can do a transform
of translate x and go back to zero
and let's go and take a look and see if
it's working and look at that it opens
and closes just like that
now what i'm going to do first is i'm
going to delete this console log
visibility because it's going to be a
little bit annoying and then i'm going
to give you a challenge because there's
a few things that we need to tweak on it
still so it's working but it doesn't
look very nice when it opens and closes
so i'm going to challenge you to get it
to look a little nicer by sliding on out
and sliding on back in and of course we
need to change our our icon here from
this hamburger over to an x so why don't
you go in here do what you can to get
those to work make it look a little bit
nicer and then when you're ready you can
go on to the next lesson where i'll be
looking at my solution for both of those
all right so we'll start with the
easiest one first which is adding our
animation so here where i had my
transform i'm going to add in a nice
little transition and transform 500
milliseconds ease in out and that's the
nice easy one to do so if we come and
take a look now we should see that it
slides on out and slides on in and i
think that looks pretty nice when that
happens so i'm pretty happy with that
and that was the easy part now is the
little bit of a harder part because we
want to change the icon on this one when
it opens
to the x and to do that we actually need
to jump into our javascript and make an
improvement there or maybe you came up
and you might have added a something
else but we need something on this that
can inform it of when the menu is open
and closed and if we come and look in
our
html here we have a button and on there
we have our area expanded is equal to
false and remember this area is for
accessibility reasons so it's really
important when that menu opens that this
area expanded should equal to true so if
you got stuck and you just weren't sure
where to do it that doesn't mean the
first thing we need to do is come into
our javascript and make a change in here
so we can toggle the area attribute and
set it from true to false so if you're
feeling confident you can jump in here
if you're not confident but you want to
give it a shot i'll give you a hint in
just one second
all right and that hint is we already
did this with our nav and we were
setting the attribute on it and here we
have our nav toggle and on our nav
toggle that is here in our html which is
our button itself so this button has an
attribute that we want to be changing so
the same way we were changing an
attribute for our nav i want you to take
that and change the attribute for the
nav toggle
all right so nav toggle and we can say
that we want to set the attribute and in
this case it's not my data visible it's
the area expanded
and we want to set that to true
and then
i've been using semicolons so i'll keep
using them and then here we'll come in
and we can switch this over to be false
and just to double check that it's
actually working let's add a console log
once again console.log
of course if you're in a if you're not
in scrimba but you're doing this in your
own editor you can also just check in
the dom to see if it's being changed in
there and so here we'll do our nav
toggle dot get attribute and we want to
get our area
expanded um
yeah that's all we need so let's try
that out and it's true because it's open
and now it's false because it's closed
so i know that it's working properly and
i can delete my console log and now what
i can do is use that and use the fact
that that's toggling to hook into there
in my css to get the icon to change so
if you took a different approach before
or if you were just completely stuck and
unsure of the next steps to take now
maybe you have a better idea why don't
you try and get that icon to change and
then i'll show you the solution in just
one second
alrighty so let's come in here and what
i want to do is choose my mobile nav
toggle and do the attribute selector
just like before with my area
expanded
is equal to true
and when that is true we want to change
the background image right here so this
doesn't mean there's no animation on it
because you can't animate background
images and this would be icon close i
believe
or is it closed oh it is closed there we
go and we can see that it is working and
that's pretty cool now there's one other
tweak we can make in here um which is
the outline that appears on this just
because there's a little a thing that
bothers me when we have buttons like
this that we interact with and then it
leaves the selector the sort of the
weird blue outline
even though the outlines have been
changed recently
but to do that what we'll do is let's
just say down here we'll do mobile and
i'm going to choose focus just to show
you what this is going to do and then
we're going to change the focus to
something else and we're going to use
this on a few other things throughout
the site too
and let's give this an outline and i'm
going to say 5 pixels solid red and
we're going to change it later
solid red but the red will make it stand
out for this demo and then we can see an
outline offset
of 5 pixels too just so it's not
touching the button directly on it
and so now when i click on it and we get
that select you can see it's
highlighting it which is that's fine
one actually change really fast i'm
going to make here is background
position
of center center or the center one time
i had this so when i click on that it
did the icon is actually perfectly in
the center of the button so it looks a
little better so you can see when i
click on it it highlights it with the
red and then the red is still there and
i am in the scrimba editor so it's
possible uh you're not seeing it so you
can just pause the video and play with
it a little bit to see that
and see the red coming in on there and
what i want instead of using focus is
actually using focus visible
and what the focus visible does it's
sort of what you wanted focus to be the
entire time so if i come in and i push
tab it's actually going to highlight it
and i'm going to get it and then i can
push my button and i know that's what's
selected so i'm pushing
right so i'm using my keyboard to open
and close it which is perfectly fine i
can tab now onto these other guys and
tab back through them and i can see that
that's what's being selected but if i
click on it i don't get the big red box
uh it's so nice and makes me so happy
and again you might not be seeing this
as you're watching it through the
scrimba replay that i have here so just
hit pause and play with it yourself in
your own editor whether it's the
scribble editor or you're doing it in
your own browser and you'll definitely
see the difference between the two i
just think it's a nice little touch that
we can add so we still keep our focus
state but we don't have it coming in
when it doesn't look too fantastic and
of course we can then change this over
from being red to white just so it looks
a little bit nicer than a red box that's
just showing up on our site and yeah i
think that is looking pretty good
all right so it's time to finish up our
navigation we've almost got it done here
and then at the larger screen sizes we
have some other styling differences that
are going to come into it
so you can actually see it the smallest
one we have our numbers which then
disappear at the next screen size up
then we have our spacing here which that
we have none of here but where we push
things down a little bit at the larger
screen size and then we also get this
interesting line here which looks very
simple and may prove not to be
as a little bit of foreshadowing there
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
start with my logo then i'm going to
worry about this part here we'll get all
of that done in this video and with a
couple of challenges for you along the
way and then in future videos we'll come
and finish everything up at the largest
screen sizes
and the reason i want to start with my
logo is just right now where our logo is
stuck to the side here and we need to
obviously move it off of there and it's
something we haven't done yet so i'm
going to scroll up a little bit here so
here we have my primary navigation and
what i'm actually going to do is create
a comment here just to say these are all
part of my primary primary header
uh because we have our navigation we
have our toggle and we have our logo
here and so for the logo we can choose
it if you remember we had a dot logo
that we used so we need to move this
down and off the left side of the page a
little bit so if you want to give this a
try you can go ahead and try it out
and i'm going to say that the margin
here is 2 rim and it's not exactly
matching the design files that we have
the margin at smaller screen sizes is
actually smaller than this uh both the
distance off the top and off to the side
where it's actually 24 pixels instead of
the 32 that i have it at now and then at
the large screen size version and the
space on the left side here actually
gets as big as 55 and so my challenge to
you is we've looked at a few modern css
functions that let us do interesting
things with sizes and so can you think
of a way to set either a minimum a
maximum maybe a minimum and maximum
space
on the sides for your margin here so i'm
gonna actually delete that and let you
give that a try and to play around with
it a little bit and then i'll see you
with my solution in just a few seconds
all right so uh there's a few different
things you could have used a min a max
or a clamp for these i'm going to come
in with a clamp for now uh just to
explore this so it lets us set a minimum
like i said so we know that the minimum
we wanted was one point five the mat
then we can have a middle value which
i'll talk about in a second and the
maximum that we want was 55 pixels which
is a little bit smaller than 3.5 rem and
so we can do something like that and
then have the middle value here be
something like 10 viewport width and
then 10 might actually be a lot let's
try 5 viewport width and then what that
means is it can't get smaller than this
it can it will grow by this much and
then it maxes out at that space
so if we take a look the space you can
see it's actually moving down and across
and then it's moving back in and uh
not a huge fan of that the way it's
working right now but at least we can
see that it is working and what i'm
actually going to do is split this up
where my top and bottom values i'm just
going to give them a solid 2 ram so they
don't move up and down
and i will allow it to grow left and
right though and for me that works a lot
better so you can see that it is growing
left and right but the spacing
on the top and the bottom isn't changing
which just looks a lot nicer um so we'll
bring that down to a 1.5 so it's the
same as in the the mobile design just
because now you can see it's up a little
bit higher
and we can fix that as we go
um so that is with clamp if you did
something instead with a min or a max
that would be perfectly fine and you
could experiment with those to get
something that you want i'll stick with
just this here because it works really
well uh you'll also note i didn't do
like a plus one rem here like i did for
type my typography
so with typography viewport units don't
zoom if you're zooming in and out on
your browser because they're linked to
the size of the viewport and if
somebody's zooming in it's probably
because they want the text to be bigger
for the layout itself and for the
positioning of the logo i don't mind if
it doesn't shift or move around if
somebody's zooming in or out so here i'm
leaving the middle value just like that
the next thing i'm going to do is i'm
before we even get into a media query
now what i want to do is fix my layout
at this point this shouldn't affect our
layout at the smallest screen sizes that
we'll double check to make sure but i'm
going to choose my primary header and
what i want to do now is i want to
ensure that this is pushed all the way
over to that side and then my logo is
actually centered within this space here
so with that selected uh one thing is we
already have a display of flex on here
we gave the primary header a flex class
so we don't need to declare a display
flex but i'll let you come in and try
and space them out
all right so hopefully that went well
for you so i'm going to do a justify
content space between on here which will
space them out and i will do an align
items of center and if we go to our
small screen sizes you can see that the
layout here hasn't been affected
by it at all everything is working just
fine and then we go up to our big screen
size we can see that it's working
the last thing that we need to do now is
to fix the padding here and over here
where we don't have any so for that one
i am going to do it in a media query and
let's come down we already have a max
width of 35 rem here so i'm going to
come all the way down outside of that
and i'm actually going to move these two
up here
i'm just to keep the all the default
styling for my primary navigation all
together and then we can have our media
queries where we're making changes to
the different things that are in here
and because we had a media query for a
max width i'm going to do a min width of
35m
but for this one i'm actually going to
do and a max width
of 35m as well and these just like a max
width i don't actually use very often i
don't often use these linked ones like
this either but if we come and take a
look there's a few important differences
here so one of them is the numbers and
one of them is the padding is different
here and here so since the padding is
different and i have to overwrite it
anyway and because i do have to deal
with this number thing where we have
numbers at the smallest size then they
disappear then they come back we're
going to need a media query like this
one anyway and this should be 45 not 35
and so i'm gonna let you try this out
get it all working and i'll give you my
solution in the next lesson
all right i hope that went well for you
and you're able to solve both of those
problems uh so the first thing i'm going
to do is choose my primary not my header
but my primary navigation itself because
this is where the padding is and that
background color that we had so if we go
and take a look at what we want we need
this extra spacing on the left and the
right which we currently do not have so
if you didn't already do it come in try
and add it on right now
and with that it was some padding on the
left and the right which if we want the
shorthand version is padding inline and
again this is a logical property it's
part of more part of the modern css that
we the that i am just in love with and
i'm just going to throw a two ram on
there and you know we'll make that a 3
ram
and there we go we can see that it's
looking pretty good our logo is
currently bumping into there which isn't
the prettiest thing in the world but
we'll be able to fix that without any uh
issues i think especially once we turn
these numbers off and so let's go and
turn those off now and to be able to do
that i'm going to use the same approach
that i took when i set all of those up
in the first place which is my primary
navigation a span so we can actually
copy this selector
if i'm modifying a selector i want to
generally use the same thing unless it's
like in that previous lesson where we
actually went
a bit more complicated where we came in
with the like primary navigation dot
underline indicators so as being even
more specific but it's either just as
specific or more specific i'm gonna go
just as specific and nice and easy we
can just throw a display of none on
there and that's it so if we come and
take a look now we have the numbers at
our small screen sizes those numbers
disappear at the tablet size and then
those numbers come back in when we get
to more of the desktop screen size so i
don't think that was too bad at all i
think it's looking pretty good and now
there's one last change that i want to
do is just to deal with the space in
between my navigation items because they
are very close together especially when
we're at this size where we clearly
could have a bit more room between them
and so this is um i'm going to come all
the way up and if you remember we did
all of the the spacing on there through
my primer on my primary navigation with
the gap property and that's because we
have the gap set up with the flex which
we're using
and so on here there's once again
different approaches i could come in
here and say gap and let's just make it
really big so we can actually see that
it's working and then we have a much
bigger space between them i'm worried
that we're going to run out of room just
like we are there before we get into the
different screen size
so once again
i think what we could do is come in and
use a similar system to what we created
when we did this so why don't you come
and see a number that you could play
with on that gap to set a minimum
maximum and get it to respond nicely to
the different screen sizes and then i'll
come in and look at what type of thing i
would set up here
and you know what i'm going to start
with this
as my starting ground and let's go see
what it looks like and this is where
people always wonder what number to use
where this 5vw is
and
truth be told you just sort of gotta
play with it and see and look at that
that actually worked out really well we
have enough space between them that when
we get to the this type of space then
it's not smashing into our logo just as
we run out of room it goes and stacks
underneath instead so i'm actually
really happy with that but it is a
number
that you do have to just sort of come
and play with and maybe you want a
little bit more spacing so you come and
make that number a little bit bigger but
you see now we're running into that
clash so this i think at 5 works but you
could also play with this maximum and
this minimum number and see what works
for you to make sure that the minimum
maybe you make this growth factor maybe
you play with the growth factor and you
play with the minimum to make sure that
they're not getting too close
so this is where you could really play
with this one as well as play with these
two numbers here to see what it looks
like at different screen sizes and play
with it a little bit and yes you're
making some design decisions when you're
doing this so if this were you working
on a team and you might have designers
this could be a conversation that you
have with them and that would also give
the designers an idea of the types of
things you can do as a developer and
that helps in the long run when they are
designing things they can think oh he
has the ability to do this so i can
design these things to take that into
account this is where it can be really
nice to have discussions but when you're
doing projects like front end mentor i
think it's a really nice way to have a
really nice looking design that you
already have so it's going to look good
no matter what and then you can come and
play with these little things to make
these little tweaks and to make things
work at the different screen sizes when
you find like you're running into little
problems along the way so if you want
now you could take this and see if you
can get it working at the larger screen
size adding the space will go on top
here and this line that is right here
and if you get stuck or frustrated with
any of them i'll be coming giving you a
helping hand in the next lesson
so we have this done and now we need to
move on to these larger sizes right here
so let's just go ahead and take a look
at
sort of where we want and we can see
there that when our padding disappears
that's where we need to make the changes
and i'm going to start with the easy
wins and then come in with the line
afterwards because i had a lot of
trouble with that line so if you did too
and you got caught up along the way or
had any struggles at all hopefully i can
help you out and push you in the right
direction uh for how we can solve this
so the very first thing i'm going to do
is come down
to where we have my media query here
we're going to create a new media query
which is going to add media and we're
going to say a min width of 45 m and we
are actually going to see a an issue
with our media queries here and here and
we'll solve that as we go through
but the first thing we do is a primary
navigation
and what will this do is add some margin
to the top and the bottom and just like
we can use padding inline for the left
and the right we've been looking a lot
at logical properties so we can come in
and use one of those for the margin if
you didn't do that you'd like to give it
a try go for that right now
and therefore that would be a margin
block so my margin block i'm gonna go in
with a two ram and let's go take a look
there we go we can see we've added that
so here
it should disappear and then there it
comes in so we have that little snap
point there so it matches more closely
with the design just like we can see
here and all right so the next step
we're going to do is add that padding
that we need so once again we'll stick
with right here and we can change our
padding inline and you might be going
well kevin do we really need to change
the padding lines let's just say we come
in here and save padding inline is going
to go to a7 rem and let's go and take a
look at what that looks like so here we
have lots of padding and when we go to
the smaller size
right
there it clicks over and makes that
change and maybe that's actually a
little bit big
for what we have now because we're
getting we're getting actually a little
bit of overflow with that and so this is
somewhere where maybe instead of taking
this approach of changing the padding
because you can clearly see the padding
is bigger here and smaller over here
we could actually remove this from here
completely so i'm going to remove that
from that media query
and we can take this one off here as
well and what we could do is actually
have a media
min width of 35 m but without a max
width on it
where we have our
we throw this in there and we can
actually change this and use either a
min a max or what i will be doing in
this situation is a clamp so why don't
you come in and try that if this isn't
the solution that you used when you did
this on your own before to see how you
can get it working choose the growth
factor and all of that play around with
a little bit and then i'll look at my
solution after
all right so i hope that went well for
you so here i am going to come in with
my clamp and we're going to give it the
minimum which i'll do three i'm going to
have to give it a middle value and we
will have to come in with a
maximum which could be around six or
seven and then this is the growth factor
and this just becomes a number that you
have to play with and experiment a
little bit with your design and see how
things work so you can see that it's
shrinking down here you can see you can
see that padding getting bigger and
smaller as i adjust here and then it
maxes out at a maximum size and then the
shrinking shrinking shrinking and then
at one point we'll cross over and we go
to the smaller size here
so there we go i think that's actually
looking pretty good and it's working
well but we could always change this
growth factor depending on how you want
things to work so let's try 5 vw instead
and that just means it's going to grow
and shrink much slower so one advantage
with that smaller number is our logo
doesn't actually collide into there with
the break points i used of course
another solution would be to have
different break points which would be a
very valid solution as well and if ever
you did want to change them you could
just do a find and go through and change
some of the breakpoints you have if
you're wondering why we don't have
custom properties as our breakpoints uh
that is one thing we can't do is set
custom properties here because that
would make life very easy to make
changes but that is something that they
are looking to add to the css spec
so with that in place i think it's
looking pretty good i'm pretty happy
with that it doesn't quite get as big as
maybe i would like it at the larger
screen sizes so again this could be a
number that you play with and and have
some fun with so maybe i bring it up to
a seven and again it's a little bit of a
fiddly number i won't lie to you
and that actually looks pretty good and
i'm pretty happy with where that's
breaking and the last thing we need to
do is add the line here and as i said
the line is a little bit difficult and
it took me a long time to come up with a
solution that i was happy with and in
the end my solution i think is a
relatively simple one but it's not
something i would normally try and
implement and so if you found another
solution please let me know either in
the scrimba discord over on twitter just
ping me and let me know what solution
you might have come up with along the
way and what i'm going to do is set the
stage for you in how i'm going to solve
this and then see if you can finish it
and in the next video i'll give you my
full solution
and so to set the stage i will work
within this media query and again we
will have to probably make a small
change with these but we'll talk about
that in the next video as well
and what i'm going to do is go on my
primary header and we should probably
move this primary header over to the top
over here
and on my primary header i don't need to
necessarily select it but i do want to
come in and select the a pseudo element
and you could use it before or after it
won't actually make a difference here
i'll choose the before but again either
one um it wouldn't change anything so
for that we do need to give it some
content for it to actually populate on
the page and i'm going to give it a
display of block
and a position of relative because i
normally i would come in with a position
of absolute in which case you don't have
to give it a display property
and absolute which would mean that if i
did that i would also need my primary
header to have a position of relative
and let's
we'll do a quick thing here and show why
this didn't work for me
and so i had a height of one pixel here
and a background of red
width of 50 just for fun and see what
that gives us and we should see there's
a red line coming on
and the issue with using an absolute
positioned element is this number here
and getting the right width and we're
using left and right and all of that but
we can come in and we can play with that
number and actually it's probably gonna
have to be let's try 10 and see what
that gives us
and now i'm going to give it a left and
i'm going to give it a left value that
sort of follows with my navi uh with
where the logo is so my left of six rim
and let's go and see what that actually
looks like
so there we go we can see and actually i
guess that should have been eight and
now that i think about it so we can give
it the left of eight and it's getting in
the right spot there but then how wide
do i make it and the other issue is uh
the size of this if we do this as a
percentage so 10's too small so you come
up to 20 and now 20 is sort of the right
size but now it's too small and then
actually now let's give it a z-index as
well
just so it goes on top and okay so now
you can see how like it's ten percent
it's way too big it's not working
um and this i tried doing this also as a
position
as a pseudo element based on my
navigation itself but again to get it to
actually adapt to the space that we have
available to sort of always fill in the
space became something that was very
hard to do and the percentages were
always based on the wrong thing and i
tried viewport units and i tried all
sorts of stuff and so if you went down
that route and you got stuck don't feel
bad that's the same thing i did um so
what i'm actually going to do is we can
delete this because we won't need it and
as i said i'm going to change this to a
position of a relative instead
and this does change a whole bunch of
things we don't need our z index anymore
and i am going to take off the width and
because we're going to see you don't
actually need it and i'm going to take
off the left as well and let's go and
just take a look and we should see
uh or you know what let's give it a
width of 100
because we do need something on there
and now you can actually see there is a
line there it's not causing overflow
it's growing it's shrinking
and because it is position relative it's
actually in my dom right now it's
actually interacting with my logo and
with my header which is why the logo has
moved over because i've done this as a
before if i do it as an after it would
switch over and go after my navigation
now you can see that it's over here and
this is where things get interesting
because our line is a either before or
after that is positioned within we have
a logo we have this and this is another
flex item in my header now with how this
is working which we can then use to get
it to go where we need it to go and play
around with it a little bit so i'm going
to leave this right here and challenge
you to see if you can get it in the
right place and then of course get the
right color and all of that and then in
the next lesson i'll give you my own
solution
so i hope you were able to figure that
out but if not no big deal let's go get
that red line where we want it to be and
to do that first i'm going to go over to
my index and take a look because we have
to remember we have my header
which has this display flex on there so
this is one flex child this nav is
another one because our button is a
display none and then we have it now set
as an after it could be a before
and because it's on the header after
it's getting positioned right here so
this is my
after is here
if you did it as a before instead the
before would come all the way up and be
right here and that would be my before
is here and that's because of how
pseudo-elements work whereas if i do a
before on my primary header it was
before the content that is here and if i
do an after then it goes after it i'm
going to leave mine as an after so we're
just going to remember that my after is
here and we have this div here then i
have my nav and then i have my after
and to get this to work now what i'm
going to do is come over to here and on
my after i'm going to add something
which is going to be an order property
so order is going to be a number one
and if we go and take a look that
shouldn't have actually changed anything
it's right where we left it off but
let's just say i came in and made this a
negative one what would actually happen
is it goes before everything else and
order is a property that opens up when
we're using css i would normally not
recommend that you use order for many
things but in this case because we're
moving a decorative element around i
think it's perfectly fine to be using
order for something like this and again
i'm going to put this as a number one
just to keep track and make things a
little bit easier for me and let's just
go back to the html for a second because
we want this to go before my nav we're
going to do is select that nav and we
can say that that has an order
of two on it and now if we go and take a
look like magic it's gone in between the
two of them and because it is a flex
item it will grow and shrink and there's
no content that's actually in there
there's only a width so we'll actually
shrink down to zero if we do run out of
room which is kind of cool the only
issue is i do want it to go on top over
here and right now we have these spaces
that's a good question and if you were
stuck before i'm getting it to be in the
right spot and now you know how to do it
but you want to do the final touches i'm
going to leave this here for you to try
out and then afterward i'll give you my
solution on finishing this up
all right so this is another one that i
wouldn't normally
use but what we're going to do is i'm
going to come and give this a margin on
the right side of negative let's try
three rem and see where that positions
it and go take a look and look at that
it's pulling right on top there and it's
going to grow and shrink now we do run
into this strange little area here where
right like where there's some weird
stuff happening here we'll address that
in a second but for the most part i find
it's actually working really well i
might drop this down to a 2.5 um instead
just so i think it's i think it looks a
little bit better there and i'm pretty
happy with that let's lastly just come
on and change this to our
uh
light white color like it is in the
design instead of that bright red and
there we go i think that's looking
pretty good and i'm happy with that and
that last thing that we want to address
or that i mentioned where things get a
little bit funky is right here you'll
notice that we get this weird like
middle ground that's happening where
we're jumping all over the place for a
little bit
and that's just because of how the min
widths and max widths work where there's
this strange middle ground between our
max width here and our min width right
here and so what i'm actually going to
do is change this one over to a 44.999
and it seems silly but it does help us
solve this issue and in the future there
is a new syntax coming to css which is
uses like greater than and less than
which is going to make our life so much
better
and easier to prevent these types of
things from happening but for the time
being we do have to work with that so
now if i look at it when we hit that
break point right here and that that
just prevents that weird overlap where
the numbers were disappearing before we
switched to the other layout and so this
just helps prevent that from happening
the other thing that you need to look at
when you're doing something like this
also just to be aware of 99 of users
don't actually actively resize the
browser once they're open and they're on
a site so us as devs we like to move
things and play with things and see how
things respond once a user is on a page
like they're here that's what they're
looking at it like or if it's here
that's what they're looking at it like
or if it's here that's what it looks
like on their device especially mobile
devices where you're not really resizing
pages unless you change the orientation
of your device so yeah with that i think
i'm happy with that solution if you want
to play around with it experiment with
it a little bit or if you want to try
and do alternate approaches to it that
would be really really awesome and then
once you're ready we'll move on to the
next page
so i know we said we'd be getting into
the next pages but before we get there i
want to make a few accessibility tweaks
to this page and so the next two lessons
are gonna be focused on that the first
one is tweaking what we currently have
now and the second one is going to be
making a small addition to what we're
working on that is a very important one
for accessibility reasons which i'll
explain once we get to that one but the
two ones we're doing in this are really
easy and simple ones so we're going to
start with that these are the easy wins
that you can make when you're working on
a page and they're very common things
that i see
not done and one of those is right here
with this which is
the you know this is this content that's
all there so we have this section at the
top with our header which is great we
have a nav so we're using our nice
semantic html there but over here we're
not doing it so much and there's one
important change and again this is
something that i see lots of sites not
bothering with and so i wanted to make
sure we had a specific lesson that would
take a look at it because it is such a
easy thing that you can change and a
really big accessibility win so if you
know what it is already go ahead and
make that change and if you're not too
sure you can wait just a second and i'll
take a look at it
and that one change is there's two ways
we could do this we could come here and
just take a main and wrap all of this
within our main because this is main
content and it's really important to
have a main on your page and you should
have only one main per page uh of course
by doing this there is a small problem
that has happened is our
grid container home which was helping to
set things up a little bit for us with
aligning uh different things is now not
working so everything is stuck to the
top instead of being at the bottom where
we'd taken all that hard work to do it
so there's absolutely nothing wrong with
taking what we have here and switching
this over to our main and just making
this our close main and you can
definitely have classes and other things
that are applied to here we will be
adding something to it in the next
lesson as well and the main axe is a
landmark for assistive technologies uh
just like our nav does as well and these
can be used to quickly get to different
areas within a site and for the screen
reader to know that here is actually the
navigation and here is our main content
and if you have a footer which this
design doesn't have any use for footers
but we have our footers and our sides
and articles and all of those different
things and many of them are acting as
landmarks to help navigate through a
site and there is another thing we can
do to really help out people who are
using screen readers and let's go take a
look at our page to understand how this
is going to work let's just hit a
refresh there we go so we can see it's
working and that other thing is when you
look here and you're looking at these
you're not reading zero zero home zero
one destination zero two crew zero three
technology you're coming up and reading
home destination crew technology and
because we have bold text here and then
the lighter text here visually there's a
distinction between the decorative piece
of information and the text itself
because visually we can see that
distinction between those two pieces of
information we just zone out and we
focus on the the important piece there
the home the destination the crew the
technology parts
and the other part just acts as a nice
little decoration on top of that
but if you're on a screen reader who's
reading this content it doesn't know it
just reads zero zero home zero one
destination zero two crew zero three
technology and as you can imagine that
could be very very frustrating so what
we're going to do is i'm going to come
on all of these spans and if you know
what i'm going to do you can pause and
go ahead and add it on now but if you're
not too sure then just wait one second
and i'll give my solution
all right so what i'm going to do is add
another area and in this case i'm using
area hidden is equal to true
and a little bit like how when we set up
our
button we used the sr only class on this
and that s our only class was so a
screen reader would still see this but a
sighted user would not see it so
visually hiding this but screen readers
can still access it
area hidden is a little bit of the
opposite it is hiding it from screen
readers but it is allowing it to still
visually be on the page so we can use
this to hide decorative elements or
sometimes there's effects where you need
to have double content so you have the
same text two times in a row if you're
on a screen reader that would drive
somebody absolutely nuts you're steering
the same words over and over again so
using area hidden true allows us to keep
the content on the page but to hide it
from screen readers because really it is
just decorative extra information so two
very easy wins that we can get right
here without very much work and in the
next lesson we'll be looking at one more
so in the last lesson we added our area
hidden true and we also added the main
an image and the main can act as a
landmark and it's a very important
element to have on a page always have a
main and every page should only have one
main and it just you know it's we're
saying this is the main content of our
page and while so far a lot of the
accessibility things that i've been
talking about are dealing with screen
readers there's other types of
disabilities as well and there's
different ways that people navigate
websites and imagine if you're a sighted
user and you come on our page and you
want to get to the explore button but
you don't have the ability to use a
mouse and you're just using keyboard
navigation so what does that mean well
you get to the page and you tab tab tab
tab tab and then you can hit your
explore button and then from there once
again you have to tab through and
eventually get to the content and then
you're on the crew page you get the idea
always having to cycle through the
navigation to get to the main content
can be very just extra time that we're
wasting that somebody who's using a
mouse doesn't have to do because you can
just drag your mouse down to here and
click and so it's super easy to make an
accommodation for this it's incredibly
easy so that's we're going to be
focusing on in this lesson
and i'm going to start by coming on to
the main here and we're going to make
one little difference we're going to add
an id is equal to main and we want to do
that because we want to make it easy to
link to this content then we come all
the way to the top up here and we can
say a
is equal to our main
and by doing that and i'm going to put
skip
to main content
and close a or you could even just have
skip to content and then we are able to
skip to the content in our page and just
to see how that would work let's go and
take a look i'm going to do an inline
style that we'll take off here
so style is going to be color
white just to make it really easy to
read for now
and i'm doing it the old-fashioned way
so color is white and if we go take a
look there is my skippy content so if
somebody lands on my page now if
somebody lands on the page now and i hit
tab the first thing that actually gets
selected is that skip to content uh
right there and so if you then click it
with enter on the keyboard and then hit
tab you can see i've already selected my
explore button so i was able to skip
going over all of these different things
if you are on a bigger site that had a
larger navigation or a big heading and
you want to be able to skip to you would
scroll down to that section and skip all
of that extra stuff and bring you to the
main content
now obviously it's a little bit
obtrusive having it like this you might
be feeling like you should throw an sr
only class on there but again this is
not only for screen readers where they
would have the ability to skip all of
that and hit the main content which
would be nice because this would be the
first thing that is read to them but
there are cited users who are going to
use this as well so we're actually going
to come on here and let's give this a
class
is equal to and i'm going to call it uh
skip to
content it's very descriptive of what
it's doing we take our style off of here
now and we're going to do a few things
to style it up because we don't want a
purple link sitting at the top of our
page
and one approach for this if you want to
try it out i'll give you a second to do
it but one approach is actually to
use the sr only class but to not have it
working when but when something comes in
focus for this to go off if that makes
sense so if you want to try that what
i'll actually do is come on here and add
the sr only and this is approach i've
seen and i've used
so it's visually hidden but when we gain
focus you want that link to then become
visible so i'll come right here and let
you try that out to see if you can get
it working and then in just a second
i'll give you my solution
all right so the solution uh there let's
just come in and say skip to
uh content not to main skip the content
and i want when it is in focus so once
it's come in focus we can say that it
has a position of relative
a width of 100 i'll actually do a max
content on this if you don't know it
we'll explain what that is in a little
bit
the height of auto and i'm sort of just
coming through and overwriting some of
these clip of zero
and i'll also come in here and give this
a background that is white
and a color that is black just so we can
visually see what's happening
and with that in place let's go and see
what happens and there it is skip the
content is now visible so i can push
enter and the next time i hit tab i am
selecting this over here and i've
skipped my navigation i've gone down to
the main content
and let's just we can reverse and shift
tab goes backwards so i can shift tab
bring it back in tab again and then go
through my navigation if that's what i
want to do and while that works i for me
i'm i've sort of moved away from that
now and i sort of style this up on its
own because then we can do a little bit
more with it and we're not fighting
against this sr only class so much to
for when things come into focus
so what we can do instead let's delete
all that and we're also going to take
the focus off of here and i'm going to
make it look a little bit better and
then i have a small challenge for you so
i'm gonna give it a background and come
in with my actual color and then use my
color dark uh we'll give it a little bit
of padding so padding of 0.5 m and 1m
and let's give it also a margin in line
of uh i was in right center of auto to
place it in the center and i'm just
going to save over here to make sure
that everything is done and there we go
it's perfect and so we have this nice
skip to content so if i tab onto that
and then push enter and then tab
it's still working everything is good
and it looks a little bit nicer
what i want to do though instead of
having it um
we don't want it obviously always
visually there so another step that we
will take
is to come and give this a position of
absolute absolute
and that should actually leave it
exactly the same everything will be the
same as what was before the big
difference is it's pulled it out of the
flow so the other content isn't paying
attention to it so it doesn't increase
the size of the space that we have there
normally and of course then we'll also
come on here and give this a z index and
we'll give it our nice big z index to
make sure that it's on top of everything
i don't think we'll run into problems
with it but just to make sure we didn't
we have a one thousand and two thousand
this is like our ultimate winner every
single time and there we can see that
it's visually on top
now there's one last step and this is
where the challenge comes in is we want
it to be visually hidden off the screen
somehow and when someone focuses on it
it can come into the screen and it could
be nice if it was done with a nice
little animation of some sorts or
transition so i'll leave you to your own
devices to see if you can come up with a
solution to that and then in a few
seconds i'll show you how i would do it
all right so what i'm going to do is
come on here and say transform and we'll
do a translate of y which is the up and
down axis and on the translate we can
say a hundred percent and 100 we'll move
it 100 of its own height now 100 we'll
move it down so if we go look we can see
it's moved down which we don't want to
do we want to do negative 100
and just like that it's visually hidden
from the screen because it's it's in no
man's land somewhere we can't access
because it's too high up
so to fix that
to content
focus and on that one we can then change
the transform of translate y
and put it back down to zero so now if
i'm on the page i hit tab it comes into
focus and then when i keep going it goes
away and then we can gain focus back in
and as i said it'd be nice if there was
a nice little animation or something for
it to come in and visually make sure
that it gets people's attention as it's
coming in so if you haven't so if you
didn't figure this out or if you tried a
different solution and now you want to
add the little animation in there
yourself you can go ahead and do it and
i'll add it in in just a second
and for me that would just be a nice
little transition of my transform we'll
do 250 milliseconds ease in
and so by doing that let's go save that
take a look at what happens and now it
will fade in and then slide back out so
i think that's nice it's a using the
animation in this way is also a nice way
to make sure that people see um when it
comes in because the animation of it
will catch the eye and then if they want
to use it they can use it and if not it
disappears and they can keep going
through the rest of the site and with
that we now have all of this done and
our accessibility is more up to scratch
and if you've never seen the skipped
content before i'd encourage you to go
on to other sites and try it out and see
if you can find it on other sites
because it is all over the place and
many people don't even know that it's
there and you can get ideas on how
people style them on the different ways
they bring them in or hide them and go
into your dev tools explore and see how
they're hiding it and how they're
showing it because there's always
different approaches to it and so yeah
that is it for this one maybe it would
be a great time to take a break and then
i will see you in the destination page
when you are ready
all right so we're moving on to the
destination page and this is really
where things are going to get a bit more
interesting and you get to make those
decisions that i talked about because we
have multiple pages that all have to be
built out and they could be done all as
separate pages or they could all be done
as a single page where we're bringing in
the content in many different ways
depending on how you would like to
approach this as i mentioned earlier i'm
going to be doing things where i'm doing
it as a single page and will be using
javascript to change the content that's
visually seen on the screen and for me
all of that content will actually be in
the html here and we'll be using like a
tab type of system but if you would like
to take a different approach you can
definitely do that where you keep each
one of these as their own page and we
just link between the different ones or
of course there is this data.json that
is available to you if you would rather
go in that direction as i mentioned for
me i'm having a single html page all of
the content will be on that page and
we're going to be using javascript to
show and hide the content that we need
to and that is the approach that i'm
going to be taking the other thing i
will be doing is we will be starting
mobile first and working our way up and
we've already started setting things up
with grid and i will continue using grid
because for what i see here i think it's
going to work really really well for now
going to be tackling this moon page and
turning this into what we see here and
i'll be focusing on that then i'm going
to focus on the crew page i want to get
all the layout things done and then
after once everything is in place we're
happy with everything we're going to
circle back around and actually add the
functionality to these two pages so if
you want to take that same approach that
i'll be taking you can do that or of
course you just build everything out as
much as you can here see if you can add
the functionality and everything and
eventually see how i do it when you get
up to those next stages or if you'd
rather just see how i get started with
it and then take off from there and do
some of the challenges that i'm giving
you that's perfectly fine as well but do
try and do as much coding on this as
possible and not just sitting back and
enjoying the ride because you're going
to learn a lot more if you're actually
implementing the different things on
your own good luck with whatever
approach you want and when you are ready
i'll see you in the next lesson where
we're going to be diving in and setting
up our destination page
all right so let's get started on this
i'm excited for this and what i'm going
to first do is grab from my header all
the way up to my doctype so we have
everything there just so we don't forget
to bring and all of this our navigation
is done our skip link is done we have
all our google fonts and all of that so
i'm going to bring that all over to this
destination and moon and that was all of
my head all the way up and i'm going to
paste that in like that
then the next thing we definitely need
to do is change the body class to
destination
and we then can come down and after the
header we want to come in and add our
content here for this there is a few
things i'm just going to go back over to
the index just so we can get a refresher
on what we did here where i have my main
that has my grid container class on it
and so i basically want that and nothing
else that is in here and we can jump on
over back to my destination moon paste
that and just make sure that we close
the main right there
so we don't need this anymore but we can
go and grab all of this
cut it out and bring it up into the main
and start working from here and one last
thing we'll do is my main has the id of
main which is good grid container and we
have grid container home i'm going to do
a grid container destination and because
the links aren't actually going to the
right spot right now for now i'm just
going to click run here in scrimba so we
can see our page and we can see that the
content is starting to come in though
everything is in the wrong spot right
now but don't worry we'll be fixing that
up pretty quickly
for now what i will actually do i'm
going to add an x here on my grid
container uh we'll do
like a bunch so we remind ourselves to
turn it off just so we can start styling
our content with all the utility classes
we have see that it's all looking good
without the grid getting in the way and
then we can just delete this and then
start placing things actually on our
grid so if you didn't already build out
the page on your own and you're waiting
for some of my little challenges well
now is the time to do that start adding
all the utility classes and the
different things that we've already
created to style this up the way we need
it to i have this here if you want to
look at this example but i would really
encourage you to either look at the
figma or sketch files that are provided
by front-end mentor there is a lot more
information in those and it will be much
easier to get everything that you need
from them than looking here but it is
completely up to you how you want to
work so good luck with that and then
when you're ready you can hit play and
i'll see you with my own solution
all right so we'll start right here and
this is going to be my h1 and this is
one of those reasons why i said i like
having things that are agnostic of the
heading levels and close h1 because this
doesn't look like an h1 but it clearly
is the heading of this page pick your
destination and we can tab through moon
mars europa titan and we have these sort
of subheadings for pick your destination
this is the title of the page and then
we get information and sub you know
that's the the next level down is this
information here even though moon is
visually the most important thing this
really is my h1
so h1 is like that but we need to style
it and make it look how we want it to
and if you remember we actually took
some time to do that in our design
system numbered titles over here and we
did all the hard work to already get
that to work so we don't have to do very
much and while we're here i do know that
we're also going to need my tab list in
a second so i am going to come and copy
that and we'll bring it in
when we need it the first thing we can
do is come here and say class is equal
to numbered title just like that and
then we also want to come here and wrap
this in a span
and we can close our spam here hit save
and look at that a lot of the work is
already done for us there is one more
improvement we can make here something
we did not too long ago
to help with accessibility reasons so if
you can think of what that is just look
up if you're not too sure you can add
that into your code
and that would be adding an area hidden
on here area hidden is equal to true
because once again this is much more of
a decorative element you don't need the
zero one right out loud to you we just
want it to say pick your destination
so there we go we can visually see it
but the screen reader will not read the
zero one out loud and we can keep on
going at this layout right here the next
thing we do have is our image and we're
going to have another lesson that's
going to focus more specifically on the
image because we will switch this over
to a picture element but i want to
devote an entire lesson to that so for
now we'll just use an image
png we do have a webp that's available
to us there as well but again i'll talk
more about that when we switch this over
to a picture element in an upcoming
lesson and for this we do want to give
an alt of the moon and this should not
be
an image of the moon they know it's an
image already so the alt here can just
be the moon and nice and simple we have
an image that will come in so there we
go it's a nice and pretty
cool image of the moon right there i
think it looks really awesome next up i
will come in with the tabs and if you
remember i already copied those when we
were on our other page so we can
paste those in
and we have moon mars europa and we'll
need one more of these guys
just like that and so that this is
finished we can delete all of that away
and there we go these are already
working they're looking just like they
need to work and we can bring this down
i guess to a smaller size since this is
where we're focusing so there we go we
do need to center things and all of that
but all of this is going to come
together
very quickly so don't worry too much
about that we can see that is working
the next thing we want to do is this
here and for this part because this bit
of information about the moon and what's
written in here with some of the you
know the information on the average
distance and the estimated time travel
and all of this this is sort of a
self-isolated bit of information so what
i'm going to actually do is take all of
this and wrap it in an article with the
r key called that and come down and
close
article and you can use articles for
lots of things and in this case i'm
going to be using it for here and it's
anything that's sort of like the
self-contained bit of information which
is exactly what this is
you might see sections used as well but
i think that article is actually a bit
more semantically correct with the type
of information that is in here so now
it's just a question of wrapping it all
in the right elements and adding in the
right utility classes so i'll add the
elements quickly and then we'll go back
through and add the utility classes
all right there we go so i've started
doing it there is a little bit more
structure that will have to come to this
uh but it's setting the stage at least
in the right direction and you'll notice
here i've used h3s so it's like moon is
my category some information on the moon
then we have the subcategory of average
distance and then we say what the
distance is and then estimated time and
then the estimated time that goes along
with that so
i've put this and organized it this way
one of the fun things with semantic html
is it does come down to interpretation
so i could actually see this as one
paragraph with a span in it just to
style them differently because you could
say it's average distance 38 or you know
whatever estimated travel time three
days you could read that as a single
sentence but i do see these a little bit
more like headings and then the
information below it so it makes these
two categories within the document
outline now if we look at how these are
always organized they are always grouped
together and even here they do make two
columns and to be able to keep these as
two columns it will be important to sort
of wrap them or have some spacing around
them so i will come on each one of these
and add in a div and then come over to
the end and just close the div so we can
wrap the content properly so now we have
these two that can be kept together but
i know i'm going to need something to
actually make this into two columns as
well because here they stack then here
they go next to one another which to me
generally means flex so i might as well
come right away and add a div class
is equal to flex here and then we can
close my div here
and just space those out and hit save
and if we go and take a look we now have
our two columns on there even though a
lot more styling is required
and one thing you might notice here is i
didn't give these classes we might need
to add classes if we need to manipulate
the middle but as long as i have my div
class flex here we don't have to give
divs classes if we don't need them
they're doing their job of dividing our
content into two blocks and they're just
there to structurally organize our
content so in cases like this don't feel
like you need to give a div a class it
does sometimes seem weird seeing divs
without them but we don't always need
them so there we go i think that's
looking good
if you haven't already taken the
challenges that i've been giving you or
you haven't styled things up go through
all of this and now add in all the
utility classes to set our font sizes
and different things that you might need
and then i'll share my own solution with
you when you're done
all right so let's come up on here and
give this a class is equal to font size
800 because it's nice and super big but
not the biggest one that we have we also
will want this to be uppercase and to be
my font family songs i'm not saying i
should say sarah so we can see the
larger and smaller font sizes so i think
that's looking pretty good and that's
coming together the paragraph i think is
perfectly fine and we don't need to add
any styling on that but these guys at
the bottom we clearly do because there
are some differences going on in there
so let's come on this my two h3s are
styled the same
and so let's take a look perfection and
then we can come on to these two
paragraphs right here case on there so
i'm going to add it there and we'll take
a look and that's looking good what's it
yeah you can see the km is uppercase
there so there we go that's looking good
i think it's looking pretty good here as
well at the different sizes so it's
looking pretty good except for this
which is actually i'm looking at it
going you know what
that's supposed to be getting smaller
and so let's go look really fast add our
index.css go all the way up to our font
sizes and that one is using our font
size 500 which is our numbered title and
what i think is that this should have
actually changed at the different screen
sizes so i'm going to take the font size
500 here and bring it into our largest
media query and drop it right there
which is where it should be and then we
can come in and make these modifications
so this would be a font size 500 which
would go down to a
1.25 rem which comes out to 20 pixels
and then here the font size 500 will
actually go down to one ram just like
that and if we hit save and then go take
a look at it
that is looking a little bit better and
matching the design a bit more where we
get these smaller font sizes when we're
at that small screen size and i think
we'll make a little bit easier to match
the layout that we're going for so i do
apologize for that ahead of time but i
do think that should make things work a
little bit better and now that we have
that done it is time to take the layout
and make it happen and since we already
have a grid i'm going to be using it so
we can come and delete that if you want
right now and then go ahead and start
making things happen i'm just letting
you know that i will be using graded
template areas quite heavily for this
because it's just going to make life so
easy to get everything to go where we
want it to and those grid template areas
will be placed on the grid container
here if you have experience with grid
and you want to play with this or if you
want to take what you learned from when
we did the home page and apply it here
if you'd rather follow along with me and
do more smaller challenges along the way
i'll be starting in the next lesson with
the mobile screen size of this and then
over a few lessons we'll break down the
different screen sizes and get
everything working for this layout so
whenever you're ready i'll see you in
that next lesson
all right so it's time to make the
layout come to life which is always an
exciting time i'm going to delete this
that we have right here and then hit
save to make our layout come to life and
let's break things a little bit because
things are trying to squeeze into
columns they're not supposed to be
living on and it actually causes a bit
of overflow because of the max width
that we've
placed on items that are in our grid so
our image is causing some issues right
now but that's going to be fixed shortly
just because we need to get it to be
smaller anyway you can see that we have
a lot of white space around that image
so a lot of the problems that we're
seeing now will be solved without too
much work so let's go over to our css to
fix things up and
right now we had our grid container here
with our good container home
and i do think it's going to make things
a little bit easier in the long run um
depending on how we want to do it you
can pull this whole grid container piece
out and this is becoming much more of a
component than it is a utility class so
i think what i might do is actually take
this entire thing here just to keep
organization a little bit easier and
bring it all the way down
and create a new category down here so
we're going to paste that back in
and then i'll grab this here and we're
going to put in layout
and this is really more layout related
things so we can write that right here
layout and then we can come back down
here and so we have our good container
which is our main layout and then we do
have these modifications that are going
to be coming in so all of this is
related to the different
pieces and parts of everything and right
here we will come in and say that this
is my
destination layout
because we clearly need to make a few
changes right now and these changes
don't necessarily apply to all of the
pages and so let's start with this one
and we can come down and say this is my
grid container sd nation and as i said i
want to rely heavily on grid template
areas for this we already have a display
grid that's applied here so we can just
come in right away and say our grid
template areas
and on these grid template areas i
always like breaking them down onto a
new line and then writing them because
it makes life a lot easier and we don't
actually really need to declare it at
this point because it is um
so straightforward but
we i like doing it at this point and
then redefining it just because i find
that it's a little bit more clear what's
actually happening
so then we can do our tabs and then we
can do the content itself so i'll call
it content it could be body
it could be different things but i'll
say
sort of content the main content area
for this grid template areas and if we
go back to our moon here that would be
everything that is inside of this
article right here
and to make life easier let's come in
and give this a class and we'll give
this the class
of destination
so we just make it a little bit easier
so we're not going to all the articles
just in case that not that i think this
will be the only article that is within
our grid container destination but it
just makes life a little bit easier to
select it
so uh yeah that's what we can do for the
grid template areas and now what i'm
going to do is let's jump in and start
with our number title and say that this
has a grid area of title and this could
technically break things and you'll
notice here it's in quotations and here
it's not that's just how grid areas work
with the number title i'm saying this
assuming it's always living on the grid
if ever you had a number title that was
outside of the grid this would just be
invalid and wouldn't work
you could
take like raise the
raise this a little bit by saying this
and then it's only gonna work if it's in
the grid container but it's only gonna
work anyway and with the scope of this
project i feel safe with this and so
we'll keep on going and i'm gonna go
like this with grid destination img so
i'm really just selecting my image that
is inside of my grid destination and if
you wanted to be very sure that you're
getting the right thing just in case
multiple images would come in we could
do that or of course this could have a
class but with the layout the wave here
it's clearly just one image that's
coming into this grid so i feel like
once again comfortable with this and
this scopes whatever styles i put on
here to here so we can see that this has
a grid area of image and along with that
we can give this a max width of like 60
or something like that and i think that
will actually look pretty good so let's
go and see what that would look like
where there we go we get our moon
sitting right there in the middle and
it's looking pretty nice and already you
can see this is pretty close to what we
need so that's kind of exciting and you
know i'm pretty happy with that so let's
keep on going with that though we have
our grid destination image and we could
even like you could have this here and
that would work but this is going to be
working for all of them so i actually
you know what this number title with the
grid area here i guess could actually
come up we have this this
we could place it here just because it
becomes something that's very generic
and is going to be applied to all of the
grids that we're using so i'll leave it
there just because this is destination
layout only
then the next one we have is our grid
container destination and then we want
to select our we'll start with the tab
list and so that gets the grid
area of tabs
and then i'm just going to copy this to
speed things up a little bit
and then the last one that we have here
is our
uh hummingbird our deskt nation info
here this class is going to be unique to
this page whereas tab list could be in
other pages which is why i like scoping
it here
and same with this so using a descendant
selector which effectively scopes it to
here is going to help us out uh in this
case we don't want this to be tab so we
want this to be in our content and so
you know we're raising the specificity
on that so i could do this because once
again this is unique to here but it's
not going to hurt anything to have this
and it just makes it a little bit more
clear that we're making sure that we're
relying on this grid
so that's why i'm doing it this way it
does mean it's higher specificity if
ever i wanted to overwrite it but if i
wanted to overwrite it i wouldn't be
doing it in my grid container
destination and then placing it within
there so this i think if somebody were
to come along this code later on makes
it a little bit more clear what's
happening and the higher specificity
really shouldn't get in the way so to me
this makes a lot of sense um the last
thing that is kind of important right
now is if we look here we have this flex
and they are actually going next to one
one another which we don't want to
happen so if we go and look at my markup
here this was just a flex and what i'm
actually going to add to this
i'm going to call this planet
meta because it's sort of or it could
even be just it will stick with
destination destination
meta um just so we're consistent with
our naming throughout so destination
meta because it's like the meta
information for the destination that
we're going to
and
you know we could choose you we could be
going along the whole like grid
container destination and then choosing
the flex class
um but i do like having this is sort of
like this little mini component so i do
think having its own class on here is a
little bit more useful than doing that
and like here it's an image that's in
here but then we have my tab list we
have my destination info we're being
very specific where is that dot flex
like um i don't know to me it's a bridge
too far but i won't nest this i'm just
going to say that it's just
dusty nation meta and you might be going
well kevin all of this is nested
on
with this right we're using all these
descendant selectors and then we're not
doing it here and because this is
nothing to do with how it's laying out
on the grid i don't feel like nesting it
achieves anything it's still very clear
what's happening where it's my
destination meta the description of this
class is very telling and what it does i
should easily be able to find it and
these are very grid related things i'm
placing this on my grid so i'm saying
that this on my grid is doing this
whereas here it says something where i'm
going to change the flex direction
and we're going to make that
column which should make those rows and
then there we go they're actually
stacking one on top of each other which
is fantastic the next thing up on my
flex direction column that i'm going to
do is let's come in with a border top
and we'll say it's a 1 pixel solid and
we'll use our hsl once again it is a
little bit different in the design file
but um i'm gonna come in with this
because i think it's gonna be a little
bit more consistent and give us pretty
much the color that we want it to be so
i'm happy with that maybe we could go
down on here to like a point one
uh and get exactly what we're after and
then we can come in with some padding
top on that of 2.5 rim and then we can
also do a margin top of 2.5 rim so it's
just equal distance on both sides of
that and there we go we got our nice
line that's coming in and i've also
realized the font size on these is wrong
but we'll address that in a future video
because it is the right size at the
large screen sizes it's just um the
media queries we have for them it's
getting too small at small sizes so
we'll definitely address that as time is
coming
and one more thing i'm going to do is we
definitely need some spacing on here and
there's a few different ways that we
could introduce that spacing so i'm
going to give that to you as a little
challenge to finish this one off and
once you're happy with your own solution
i'll come in and show you what mine
would be
all right so we have a few different
ways that we could do this one of them
would be to introduce a road gap and
that would work but we've already done
the hard work of creating our flow
classes
so here on my main we can come in and we
can introduce a flow class on there and
that right away is going to introduce
some spacing which is a nice start and
the next thing we could do is we could
either come in with an inline style to
increase it or because we've already
taken the time and we have our
destination here another thing we could
do is come in and give our flow space
and come in with a two rim to increase
the total amount of spacing there and i
think right away that looks much much
better and much closer to what the
design was looking for and i'm pretty
happy with that overall the last thing
that we have an issue with is just the
space on the bottom over here and we
never ran into that on the home page and
to me the easiest way to handle that is
to go on our grid container itself so
it's all the grid containers and come in
with a padding bottom because this won't
affect the bottom on the
um you know whatever number you want to
come in here with it's just going to
give us that breathing room that we need
here at the bottom which is going to
make life a lot better because we
definitely need some there when people
scroll down or else it's just really
awkward
and even on the index page that might
solve a bit of a problem we had where
when we were hovering before sometimes
we were running into issues where that
could actually cause an overflow uh
and be kind of awkward where the scroll
bar would jump in and out so that sort
of helps us prevent that problem and
even at bigger screen sizes having a
little bit of padding at the bottom it's
not going to greatly affect things and
it still lets us keep the overall layout
in everything that we're having so it's
a little bit of a compromise there could
be a way where we target more specific
pages with this but i think it's the
easiest way to tackle it myself but if
you would rather see something that's
more specific for certain pages you
could approach this in a different way
as well
and with that i'm actually really happy
because i think we've tackled our mobile
layout really well the tablet layout is
almost exactly the same so i think we
can do the tablet layout and this one
all in the next lesson if you want to go
ahead and try those out before i get
there and then when you're done with
that you want to see my solution i'll be
looking at that in the next lesson
so our mobile layout is looking pretty
good we want to move into this area here
where there's not very many changes one
of them is the title goes from center
align to left align and another thing
that happens is the
area down here breaks from one column to
two columns but other than that
everything is basically the same thing
that we have right here so there aren't
a lot of adjustments that we have to do
and let's come here and we're going to
add in that middle breakpoint of an add
media and we'd say a min width of 35 m
and on that i am going to select my
number title and the reason it's in the
middle is because of the alignment of
what's happening right now because this
is on a grid and if you remember when we
set it all up for smaller screen sizes
and our mobile screen sizes we said
everything should just be centered that
was working and it still is working for
most things but it's not working for the
number title right now and so even if
you tried a text a line left it's not
actually going to change anything if we
go and take a look it's still stuck
right in the middle so
how would you go about moving that over
to the left side i'm going to leave that
up to you to see if you can come up with
a solution
so because we are in grid and this is a
lot like flex we said everything is
justified a center and so we can't say
justify itself and justify itself is not
something we have in flex but it is
something we have in grid and we need to
say start and if we do that and we go
take a look it's lined up all the way at
the start so here it's looking pretty
good then we get to the break point it's
there and then it just stays left
aligned which is perfect there is this
awkward point there that's going to be
fixed really easily as well the other
thing though that i would like to
address is just the um spacing that's
happening here right now and if we go
and look at the layouts here there is a
bit of space and then that space does
increase and already that space is
increasing because we're adding a margin
top and bottom here let's just take
advantage of that extra spacing because
we want it both times anyway and we just
say that we have a margin
top or if you do want to stay we've been
doing margin block and margin inline you
can do a margin block start which is
just the top so if you do want to stay
with the logical properties you can do
that but just to stay consistent since
we've been using top and bottom
everywhere we'll add a two ram of margin
here on the top so now these medium
screen sizes we have that space that's
good now we just have to address this
problem down at the bottom which is very
easy to do and you'll even see the
alignment is just completely off and
let's go look here hmm
we might have some weird alignment
issues that are happening and i know why
those are happening we might see this
across other pages too so we're going to
address that shortly but for now let's
just fix this so it does go across two
columns
so that is my destination meta so in
this same media query we can come in
we only need to do one thing we can
delete most of these leave one of them
and make a change here so what is that
that we need to change i'll let you do
that and then i'll take a look at it as
well
and that one thing that we needed to
change is just coming in here and saying
that this should be a row instead
of course when we do that things sort of
break a little bit but the row is
working where they're going one next to
each other and that is perfect
so if we come and take a look they
should be spaced out a lot more is there
a way just with flexbox that we could
sort of keep that with our spacing so
i'll let you give that a try and then
we'll take a look at how we can do that
and i'm going to come in with a
justify content and i will come in with
a space evenly and space evenly was the
last one that was added and it's the one
that you have space between space around
and space evenly uh space around sort of
is very similar to space evenly but
space evenly is usually the one that you
want so with the small sizes i think
it's looking alright everything is okay
we get to this larger screen size it's
looking pretty good we still need to fix
these font sizes we'll get there don't
worry and then we get to this larger
size where now this is where the next
adjustments have to happen so there's
quite a bit of different things that are
happening here so i'll let you try and
solve all of those things and see if you
can get things working and i'll see you
in the next lesson
all right so let's get our big layout
going and we're going to be doing a lot
of as i said with grid template areas
so one thing we're going to have to pay
a bit of attention to here is let's
paste this in and delete this and then
let's take a look at how our areas are
even set up so if you remember we have
the left and the right are set up with
these which are sort of like the the
extremities where nothing should live we
want everything living in this area here
so what we can say is we're going to
actually come here and say dot and then
title and title and then a dot and the
dot is like a empty area so we have our
empty area then we have title across one
title across two and then going across
into we have nothing over here
so in all of these we're going to start
them all with a dot and we can actually
delete this last one because what we
want is our title all the way across the
top then we want our
planet here
and we have our tabs and we have this
content so our planet is actually going
to go across two of these so let's go
and take a look at that we have our
image and then our image right there
and then after the image we can have our
tabs
and then the dot for the empty area
that's left over
and then here we have our image and we
have our content and then the empty area
that's left over
and just by doing that let's go take a
look at what that's done and oh my
goodness it's looking pretty good
my we did we barely did anything and i'm
super happy with how that's looking
so that's a really uh nice surprise i
think this is one of the reasons i
really love grid areas and then we come
in with our justify and if you remember
we'd originally a long time ago changed
the justify items so we're going to come
with the justify items until we start on
that instead of center so then
just here everything is centered then we
want it all to go more left aligned so
if we go and take a look that's working
for almost everything except down here
which is using flex but let's just see
here we're pretty happy with that then
we pop over to here
and why is my title not actually working
let's take a quick look at that
and actually what's causing that is this
here with our grid container first child
and last child that we were doing to
create those two columns there so we
will come in and fix that just by saying
that's only for our home layout
and home and because we're doing that
and fixing that only for our home
because all the other ones we'll be
using
uh grid template areas on anyway we can
come and fix that like that
and now if we go and take a look we can
see there we go that looks a little bit
better where it's actually stretching
across the top
uh another thing we have to fix is our
image so here we can say
we want to use the same selector because
we're overwriting what we've already set
right here
so i can use that same selector right
here and then change the max width
now to 100 to let that image actually
grow and it does look a little bit big
so maybe we'll actually come in with
like an 80
uh or a 90
just to make sure that it doesn't get
too large another way we could
accomplish the same thing is by setting
a bigger gap here down the middle and
yeah i think that works out really
nicely we can drop down to the tablet
layout and it's looking good and then we
get to here and i think that's working
really really nicely now the last thing
we sort of need to fix up is this guy
right here and so to be able to do that
let's go and take a look and we just
need that one to be left aligned and to
fix those font sizes at long last so to
get those left aligned i'm going to
leave it for you to see if you can
figure out how to do that and then i'll
take a look at it in a second
all right so that is my destination meta
if you remember properly so what i will
do is just take this right here once
again we'll drop it down here
and the flex direction can stay like
that but my justified content we're
going to do is put a start on there just
so it goes to the left alignment instead
of spacing everything out but we'll also
come in and we'll use our gap property
here let's increase it after like a
three rem to add that spacing in between
those two elements and i think we could
actually increase it more to about a six
and there we go i'm super happy with
that and that's looking really good
and the last thing to do is the font
size that's coming on here and i
actually made a change early on uh on
one of the elements also on the home
page where we're having an issue with a
font size which was our explore button
and if you remember when we did the
explore button we were just we took the
font size property off because it wasn't
giving us the size we needed and we just
explicitly set it so i'm going to do the
same thing here we're going to delete
this and delete this one right there
and in this case i'm going to use my
destination meta and choose my
paragraphs
there could be
if you want to create a class that just
has a fixed font size that is something
that we can do as well but for me it's a
very unique case through the entire site
so we'll grab that we'll come over to my
index and so for my destination media
paragraphs and not the one that's here
we don't want to be working in a media
query because the font size should
always be the same so then we can come
in with our dusty destination meta
and say that a paragraph that is nested
inside of there will have the font size
of 1.75
rem and so let's go and take a look and
there we go we have the proper font size
that's on there and as the screen size
gets smaller that font size is staying
the same across the board one more
change i do want to add here a very
small thing we can't really see it here
but if you're on a computer with a much
larger screen than what i'm working with
at the moment um if you got to these
large sizes or the screen was much
taller than what we have here everything
would start sort of pulling away from
each other a little bit so just to
address that the easiest way is here on
our justify items start i will come in
here with an align content start which
we won't see the difference as i said at
all right now in within the editor that
i'm using but if you're on a larger
screen it's just going to keep all the
content sort of together at the top
instead of slowly stretching out
as the page size increases so yeah i
just think for bigger screens that will
be an important change to make and
lastly the thing we want to address is
these alignment issues that can be
cropping up where things are working
super well there and as i mentioned
earlier it has also found its way under
the homepage with this right there and
so you know that doesn't look very nice
when that happens
and it's just way off to the side so
this could be a nice opportunity to dive
in see if you can figure out what's
actually causing that and see if you can
fix it on your own before i show you my
solution in the next video
all right so i won't lie this was a
little bit of a tricky one and the
what's actually the culprit here is this
grid container with our star with a max
width of 50. and to be able to highlight
what's happening i'm going to come on
here and we're going to give this an
outline and we're going to say 3 pixels
solid lime green because that should
really stand out on our background
and if we go and take a look we can see
all these boxes that have been drawn
around everything because basically
everything has an outline on it now and
a few of these have very small font
sizes on them and those small font sizes
when we take a look at the smaller
screen size right at oh look at that
there's another problem there we'll
solve that in this lesson as well but at
these small screen sizes what's
happening is you can actually see that
the total distance here or the total
width of this is less wide than the
total width available to it because this
has a max width on it a 50 ch and it's
such a small font size and if we go and
look at the home page and run that one
again the same issue is happening here
this font size is so small that 50 ch is
actually smaller than this entire space
that it has to live in
and the reason we set this in the first
place is because of this paragraph
and other paragraphs to it whereas this
is growing we're going to see we're
getting this extra space on the sides
here which is nice it's good that's what
we want and if i come in here and i turn
off this max width what happens is this
now stretches the entire thing and it
just it becomes a little bit harder to
read if you're on a tablet and it was
like this like it just doesn't look as
fantastic as it could look so
that's why we initially put that on
there so now that you know what the
issue was if you weren't able to solve
it at the beginning see if you can find
a way to make it work and only select
those paragraphs
i'm going to turn this max width back on
so it's actually being applied and what
i'm actually going to do is change this
from a star selector to a p selector
which is choosing all my paragraphs and
in this case it's actually working on
this page the only issue that can come
up with that is if we go over to my
other page it's selecting a few things
that i might not want it to select and
luckily that's actually pretty easy to
do where we can add one more thing here
which is going to be not
and then in the knot we can put in a
class on an attribute selector so it's
saying any paragraph that does not have
a class applied to it and if we go and
take a look we can see that's only
applying to this here so it's leaving
our max width set perfectly on that and
if we go back to our index the same
thing it's only being applied on that
one and so we can see that it's only
being applied here and if we go back to
our index page we can see that it's only
being applied right there and this is
one of those ones i don't use very often
but it can every now and then really
come in handy so we can turn off our
lime green because we don't need that
anymore but as we saw we are running
into a bit of a problem with this text
over here when we hit a certain screen
size which is right around here
and that's happening for a very
interesting reason we're running into
these little issues that sort of pop
their head up as you're working on a
site that's very normal to happen and so
i really want you to see if you can
troubleshoot this one right here that
we've just run into and see if you can
solve that one as well
all right so that is happening purely
from one selector all the way down to
the bottom we had which is our
destination meta and that is because we
have a very big gap on here and it's
just running out of room and so it has
to break onto different lines
and so one solution here is to change
this from six we could just make it a
smaller value of course but i'm going to
choose a min function and in the min
function let's come in with like 15
viewport width and we can do a six rem
and what this means is choose whichever
of these is smaller
so if six if we're getting to a very big
screen size then 15 viewport width will
be really big and then it will choose
the six because six will be smaller but
if the screen size gets very small then
the 15 viewport width will be smaller
and it will choose this one instead so
if we go and take a look it looks like
15 is already too big and that's not
actually helping us maybe we need to
drop that down let's try eight and just
see what that looks like and uh there
that looks already much better so we can
see that it's shrinking down and ah
that's actually working pretty good
now i am thinking that on these other
planets we might run into larger
distances so maybe we actually want to
drop this down to like a five or a six
just to make sure that there is enough
distance and we don't have to readjust
it maybe we will we'll see when we get
there and once all of these different
numbers are brought into there but right
away i think we've hit a nice zone there
we've solved a couple of problems that
have reared their head and as i said i'm
not going to add the functionality to
this yet we'll cycle through the pages
we'll put the layout for the next page
in place and then we'll come back
through and go and add the functionality
where we can actually use these tabs
that we've created right here so if you
want to make any adjustments look at any
of the code in here
take a break for a little while and
whatever it is when you're ready i'll be
waiting for you in the next lesson
and this one is another fun one very
similar to the last one that we worked
on and of course we have multiple
different ones and unlike the tab system
this time we have the dots to be able to
go through the different crew members
and then of course we have all the
different sizes to worry about as well
where things clearly get moved around a
little bit more than on the last one
because here we have an image on the top
the image goes to the bottom and then
the image goes to the side instead of
always staying in the same place which
makes things a little bit more
interesting so i'm going to start we can
jump over here to the crew commander
page and i think you can do a lot of
this all on your own you might run into
little problems here and there along the
way and that's where i'll be coming in
and helping out because in a few seconds
i'll come through and add in a lot of
the markup and the utility classes to
this page to get us started before we
get into the layouts
all right so for this one i'm actually
going to go over to the moon page to get
a lot of what we're going to be doing
it's like last time i'm actually going
to start at the main so we can go from
the main
all the way up
and hit copy on that and then we can
come over into my
crew commander page and we can do
everything from we'll start right here
and hit paste
then of course this is opening my main
so we just want to make sure that we do
close the main and of course this time
it's grid container and it will be crew
instead and we'll come up up over to the
body and make sure that is true as well
and let's run that page and we should
see things are starting to show up in
there at least now the next thing is we
need to bring in all of the different uh
tags and utility classes on here so if
you waited for me for this step you can
go ahead and do that now i'm gonna go a
little bit quicker for this because it's
to be very similar to the last one that
we looked at so i'm going to bring in
all of the tags and utility classes at
once instead of talking my way through
it just because it is so similar to
everything we've been doing up until
now right so i have most of the things
in place the last thing i'm going to do
is just come up and
go on over to the design system and we
can grab this right here because we need
our dot indicators and drop back up over
to here and paste that in
and we will need a couple of extra
buttons so let's copy that button and
paste it in and this time we do have
these slide titles where i'm going to
change this one to be
the commander
and there we go we have the commander
mission specialist pilot and the crew
engineer and so again these are in an sr
only class so they will not be visible
but for a screen reader that comes along
when these tabs are there it's going to
make it so they sort of have an idea of
what they're clicking on so they'd get
to meet your crew and then this is going
to be the selected one so they're going
to know they're on the commander and
then we have the commander information
here and then we get to the mission
specialist the pilot the crew engineer
one thing quickly before we get into the
layout something that ideally i would
want to do is actually to have
this content and the image inside that
article because this image is very
related to what's happening here
obviously but because of the layout
differences that are happening where the
dots are sort of we have the image then
the dots then the content are then over
on this one then the image is dropping
below and we have the dots and then the
content and then here things are
breaking up it's always organized in
very different ways be very difficult to
be able to do that so i'm doing the
image on its own over here i don't feel
like it's an ideal situation but in the
end it's one of those compromises i'm
making to be able to actually execute
the layout that we're trying to build
so
yeah that's why i'm excluding the image
here is the same on the previous page
why the images were the way they were
and with all of this in place i do
believe we're ready to work on the
layout so i'll see you in the next
lesson where we're going to do just that
all right so before we were doing all of
our work on the destination layout now
let's come down right to here and come
in with our crew layout and if you
haven't already done it i'm going to
challenge you to do as much of this as
you can on your own and then just come
to me for advice so i will move a little
bit faster through this one than we did
on the last one and we will be using a
lot of grid template areas and a lot of
very similar things
to what we've already used um up until
now
so i'm going to leave this here for you
i'll switch this over to crew for you
and i'll see what you can do with this
page and come in with your own solutions
to this again i'm going to be going a
little bit faster a little bit less
explanation at this point because i
think you should have these skills to be
able to move forward and then if you do
get stuck or there's small little things
you can see how i do things a little bit
differently hopefully to find the
solutions to the problems that you've
run into
and so the first thing i'm going to do
is actually also come up to here and
take all of these and we have to make
some changes to them but i'm going to
grab these just to be able to work a
little bit faster and drop them in here
because once again we do want to have
this could be my crew
this one is going to be my crew and this
will be my dot list
and then we can come in with crew here
and
uh this is my crew info is what i
believe i called it is it
oh i put crew details okay we'll stick
with for details maybe info would have
been a better name but we'll stick with
crew details on that one
and the order of things is obviously a
little bit different we have our title
our image our tabs and actually maybe it
is the same go ahead save here and let's
go and take a look to see how things are
looking comparatively to over here where
hey it's not too bad actually
uh so yeah not too bad at all we do have
a color differences on a few things here
that we need to fix we need to add a bit
of flow i think and a bit of a border
so i'm going to go ahead and do that um
i did say on the previous one this is
very related to grid content but i am
going to stick here and just do a border
bottom
of one pixel solid and hsl
with this one now because we are using a
border in multiple cases where we had
one previously on the meta description
it was very similar even though i did
this at the top
this could be a utility class that you
create and instead of doing it on here
we could do it as a
border top on this area over here so
just to say there are different ways
that we can skin a cat and approach
these different things now the one issue
with that is because i have a 60 on
there it's not quite as long as we
needed in the actual design but it's
going to be close enough that i'm
actually pretty happy with that
but now we do have that issue where we
get to here and the layout actually
needs to change when we get to this
tablet screen size
so this is something we didn't have to
do before but we can come in and take
this guy right here and once again we
don't have to really redefine other
things we only have to redefine
our grid template areas which is always
so nice to have to only be able to do so
title is still going to be first then
we're going to have our content and
everything else is going to follow so
the image moves all the way down to the
bottom so let's come in with our image
so we're going to cut and then the
content of course is going to get moved
up so we can make this one content and
make this one here tabs and of course i
need this last one right there so at the
small screen sizes everything is the way
it should be we get to the medium screen
size here and then that's working we're
re
reorganizing our content and then when
we get to the larger screen size but we
still need to do that uh there is one
more thing i'm going to do if we take a
look this should always be stuck to the
bottom of the page i am a little
concerned what this might look like at
really big screen sizes so
while it should be stuck to the bottom
of the page and that does mean that
maybe on this one we've added that
padding that we want to get rid of
because we want to have our content
stuck to the bottom
i am going to leave that border bottom
that we have here
just as a bit of a precaution because i
think it really large screen sizes it's
going to be a little bit awkward no
one's going to notice it if it's stuck
to the bottom of the page but if we get
to a very large page then we won't have
any issues where it looks like this
weird floating corpse at least this line
does provide us that separation
that could actually go a really long way
into making things look better so let's
take this one now we can come down into
this media query
and paste it in and redefine things so
remember in this one we need the dots on
the two sides so we have our title
across the top
then on this one we now need to have our
um it's going to be our content and
image and i'll come bring the dots in in
a second
then it's going to be our then it will
be our tabs
and our image and we don't need this
last one down here and as i said we can
come through now and bring in those dots
you just say that these grid areas of
the extremities are blank
so with all that in place we should be
able to come over
open things up and look at that it's
working not perfectly and i think my
dots are in the wrong spot so let's just
make sure
i have the right set up on that one
uh dot list oh there it is top in the k
tours i did the same thing twice
much better
and
we can see that things are looking
pretty good we have one other change
that i'm going to make which is
interesting because it's the same as
this one so i'm actually going to do a
comma and say grid container
image and just so we can save a little
bit of lines of code there so my image
isn't getting too small
now one difference that you will notice
right away from the main design is the
name here is going all the way across
and my name here is breaking across two
columns again normally i would increase
maybe my media queries just a little bit
and these would be set to 40 ram each
instead of 30 rem as their maximum size
so that could actually have a nice uh
could actually fix that as an issue
another thing we could do is come in
with a clamp on this to try and fix that
from breaking on two lines but that
might be something we'll address later
on seeing how things work out and if
they don't look too good
and i do have two challenges now for you
just to sort of put the finishing
touches and there's a few little things
that i think could be improved overall
on this but the two challenges i have
for you first of all is getting this at
the large screen sizes and just making
sure it's aligned all the way on the
left side
and the other thing is to make sure that
the image is stuck to the bottom instead
of being stuck right here
and so i'll leave those two challenges
to you in just a few seconds i'll look
at the solution
so sticking with my min width of 45 m
here what we can do is choose my
grid container crew and on there we can
say my dot indicators and on those we
want to say that there are justify self
start on there and that should help pull
them over to the end just like we did on
our destination meta on the last one and
now we can see that it is lining up the
way we want it to and then here
everything becomes centered once again
and then to get the image on the bottom
there's two different things one of them
is we do have padding that's down there
that is preventing it from being stuck
all the way on the bottom
so if you remember that padding is
coming on my grid container right here
and the grid container destination is a
modification of that class
so we could say i'm going to not do this
at the smallest screen size but i am
going to introduce it at the
medium screen sizes and up
on this one we could say that the
padding
bottom
is zero
and if we go take a look we've
eliminated that space and as you can see
you can but that border that was there
is basically non-visible so that's
looking pretty good and that's fixed
that problem at this screen size but
then when we get to this large screen
size we still have it not actually
touching the bottom
and this is something that i did in the
previous one because i didn't want to
prevent the problem that could arise
from this i actually think that maybe
taking this step of keeping it like this
could like at this screen size and the
screen sizes we'll be looking at here
while i'm previewing this i don't think
we'll run into any issues with it
but it's one of those things where at a
very large screen size it could look a
little bit strange so i think i would
leave it like this personally but there
is a way we could make sure that it's
always stuck to the bottom so why don't
you see if you can figure out what that
is and then in a second i'll come and
address that as well
all right so for that one it would just
be coming down and very similar to how
we did this i can take the same thing
change this over to just my image and
then justify itself is left to right
right now so we can do
an image not an image and a line itself
and throw an end on there and that means
it's always going to be lined up to the
bottom of the grid and so if we go and
take a look you can see now it's stuck
to the bottom uh no matter what and it
should always be stuck to the bottom
with how we set this up i'm just worried
at very large screen sizes that some
strange things might happen with how the
layout is going to look on that one so
i'll let you be the judge on that
whether you want to keep it or not so
i'm actually going to comment that out
but if you would want to leave it then
you could definitely leave it or if you
want to find a way to make it not look
too bad
you could also take another approach on
that one i wouldn't mind at all so
i'll leave that one up to your own
discretion and we have a few little
finishing touches on the last two pages
we've done just to make sure everything
is looking good and then we'll be
getting into the functionality in not
too long
all right so i just want to make a few
very small little touches improvements
before we add the functionality and one
of those important ones i think we need
to do that we haven't done yet is to
come all the way up and to fix the
backgrounds here so uh we have them all
set up for the home page but i can copy
this and do a paste and paste because we
have two more pages that we need to set
things up for and if you want to go
ahead and switch them all you can now
but this is pretty straightforward i
think so i'm just going to jump right
into it and i'm going to choose the home
basically everywhere we have here and
just switch that out for my destination
page and then do the same thing for my
group page so i'll see you in just a
second
and there we go we have my different
backgrounds in place and so let's go
start with our crew commander page and
see
i can already see how my background
image has come in so that's looking
pretty good and we should see the image
is going to change
it does so i'm pretty happy with that
let's go next and look at our
moon page that we have right here and we
should see a nice background oh we have
another mistake that's coming with these
background colors which is
i know why that happened
i'm not sure if you remember because it
was a long time ago that we'd set things
up like this but why don't you see if
you can find out why those background
colors are there how they got there and
if you can find a solution to fixing
that little problem
all right so this is one of those normal
problems that sort of pops its head up
as you're doing more and more work on a
site so the reason that they did happen
is when we made our design system we
just had a solid background color on
there and when you have buttons they
have a default button color so this was
an easy way to get rid of them but
obviously we didn't want it so i'm going
to remove that class from here in my
design system even though we're finished
with it just so i don't accidentally
copy and paste it and run it into the
same problem again in the future
and then we can come over to my moon
page here and take off all of these and
there we go they're gone and if we take
a look well now it's even worse
so if you didn't find the solution
before see if you can fix it now and
then i'll look at the solution in just a
second
all right so that one was let's go up a
little bit and we can find our underline
indicators and basically all we have to
say is background
color that is transparent
and if we do that it doesn't affect our
navigation links at all because the
navigation links didn't have a
background color anyway and you can see
it's fixed the problem that we had there
so a nice little wind that didn't take
very much work compared to the initial
design i do feel like the gap that we
put here was a little bit big i'm gonna
see if you can remember how we made that
gap and if you can fix it and this is
not something i do specific to this page
i would just do it for that component in
general so
i'll let leave you here and see if you
can
shrink that down a little bit
so if you remember we did that using our
padding right here and i said don't
worry about doing it as like a general
fix just do it on the element itself and
that is on our navigation we actually
increased that space by increasing our
underlying gap in this case we don't
actually have one if you did redefine
your underlying gap somewhere else and
that worked that's perfect but i'm
actually going to come here and redefine
it here as a 0.75 ram instead just to
try and pull it a little bit closer and
i think even a 0.5 ram would be exactly
what we need there we go i think that
looks a little bit better and as one
last change that we're going to make
before we move into the functionality is
just the title here of commander if we
go and look at the design we can see
it's not actually using my accent color
it's actually faded out and if you go
into your design files in figma or
sketch you'll see it's at about it's a
white color but at about 50 opacity so
see if you can find a nice way to be
able to adjust that and in a second i'll
look at fixing that last thing up
so that is happening here on the crew
details on the h2 and so we could give
this a class but i think just choosing
our h2 in crew details is good enough
and so let's go and do that right now
where we can jump on over here let's go
down and find my
layout and i even though this is more
like typography related just because we
do have these grid we have like a lot of
things that are related we have my
destination meta here then we get my
crew layout i just think it makes sense
to group it with all of this so this one
was called my crew details and then i
can choose my h2 that is in there and we
can just on this one
we could do two different things you
could actually say the opacity
is uh a 0.5 and that would work
perfectly fine since it's all the text
and it's just the text that you're
fading out so if we did that it would
work and you can see it's faded on out
or of course you could change the color
of it
and use our hsl at 8.5 and that would
have the exact same effect so if you did
either one of those
or you found another way to select it
that would be perfectly fine but that's
that last step that we needed to do
just one really quick note i really
don't mind doing these types of things
with some descendant selectors it even
forces people to take a certain approach
if they needed to create a new one to
make sure that they're following the
a certain way of organizing your text
that i think is important anyway so for
me this works out really well again if
you prefer a class on this instead of
saying the h2 instead of crew details i
completely understand that and there's a
few different ways you could go about
choosing the type of class you'd use
there but i'm really happy with where
we're at now i think the page is looking
fantastic even though this is breaking
on two lines to me that's not the end of
the world even though in the design file
it's not doing that we can always look
later on once we add the functionality
if we see that things are jumping around
a little bit too much maybe we could
come and tweak things a little bit more
but for now i'm going to leave it though
there is one last thing is everything is
really crunched together and smooshed
right now and if we come and take a look
here we can see we have a lot more
spacing coming on our elements and over
here too the spacing is a little bit
more on everything and this is something
that we did earlier but i want to again
increase the spacing a little bit more
and so if you can think of a way that we
can sort of space things out there
within here within a class that we
already have you can go ahead and add
that in
that one is just by coming on and adding
our flow class here and this is actually
going to cause a problem when we do this
because now we get a really big space
here and here if we look at the design
the spacing here is a lot smaller than
our spacing there and from a design
standpoint that makes sense this
information is related to each other so
there's a little bit less spacing on it
and that does create a little bit of an
issue with our flow class here
and in a way you could think this could
cause a problem and then you could come
in and have to add individual margins
and everything here
another way you could adapt around that
is to wrap this content in something and
one thing you could do if this was
different types of content you could
come in here and use a div to do that
just so what happens now is the flow
class will add spacing around this
and this item here so when i hit save we
can see that now this is grouped
together and then we got our space so
that is one solution for short in this
case because we are in an article i
mentioned this earlier and it's why on
my header when i created it we have a
class of primary header and i said it's
very you know sometimes you can have
multiple headers in different places and
one place that you can have a header is
within an article and you can say that
this
is the header and close header of my
article
and this is my heading so that h2 is
like the title of my article and this
paragraph is effectively now a subtitle
and one thing you definitely don't want
to do is use another heading level like
an h3 as a subtitle a subtitle should be
a paragraph and a nice way to sort of
distinguish it as a subtitle is actually
by wrapping them within a header like
this so this is the heading of my
article the main title is commander then
we get the subtitle of commander is
douglas hurley and then we get into the
content itself
and what we can do on here as well
because we do need a little bit of
spacing
is to come in with a class is equal to
flow on here and then you may be going
well okay but that
once again reintroduces too much space
and one way we can solve that is to
change the flow spacing that we have on
this header right here and i do want to
be able to bring this also onto the moon
page potentially or you might also need
this for the third page so to make it a
little bit more generic we could just
come in and say flow space small
as a reusable utility class so we're
saying that we're using our float space
and then we're modifying it or you could
also do something that's more of like a
scope style using a descendant selector
or you might say grid container article
just because of how it's always being
used or you could come in with another
way but i want this to be something that
can be reused in different places so i
will take this approach but again you
can follow with multiple different ways
to accomplish the same thing so let's
come on over to my index
go find my utility classes
and right here what we could do is we
could add that in flow space
small and i guess actually
this would actually make more sense
we're taking that and modifying it that
just makes more sense because we're
modifying flow so flow space small you
can do small space if you prefer and on
that one we can just come in and then
say that my flow space and change it so
we're modifying what this variable is
and we could come in with a 0.5 rem
instead and we'll just have to then come
back over to here just to modify this to
fix it there as well and let's hit save
and now you can see that that space is a
lot smaller than what it used to be so
let's just bring this back up to one or
remove it i should say maybe and we'll
go and take a look and it's a big space
and then we can come in and say that it
should be a 0.5 rim and we'll hit save
and then you have a smaller space that
is there to match closer to our design
and if you really wanted a more robust
system like this you could even have
like a split space 1 a flow space 2 a
flow space 3 and have different spacing
available for each one so then you'd be
able to sort of have a whole range of
utility classes that you could use to
modify things but for now i'm just going
to stick with the small and i think i'm
actually going to bring it up to 8.75
just because i think that matches the
design a little bit more and if we go
and take a look at the moon page
and hit run on that we we do already
have a flow class that is giving us some
space so that would be all the way up on
my main
we do have this flow so if i took that
off and we hit save everything is sort
of you can see there's less spacing here
so i'm going to put that flow space back
on
and i think that's better but i do think
we should have a little bit more space
in between the text of moon and this
right here so i'm also going to come on
the same way we did before on my article
and just add a flow up here we won't
need our small spacing
and i do think that is a bit sure to the
design itself so i'm going to leave it
like that and in the next lesson we're
going to see an improvement that we can
make with our image that is right here
and do something a little bit more with
it because we do have web ps that are
available to us as well
so one of the things that was provided
to us from front-end mentor was when we
look at our images we have a moon.png
and we also have a moon.webp and there's
other image formats that are also
becoming very popular such as avif and
there's probably going to be more and
more in the future and one issue with
them is browser support and while webp
actually has excellent browser support
at this stage and avif is getting better
when we do have these it is a good idea
to provide fallbacks just in case the
browser that is trying to load that
image can't load the webp and webp is a
very interesting format it can replace
both jpeg and png because it can support
transparency if there's transparency in
the image and both cases for png and for
jpeg it's just much much better at
compression compared to those older
formats and so you're getting very crisp
good quality images at much smaller file
sizes and so just to compare between the
moon.png and the web p here
the png version is 71 kilobytes whereas
the web p1 is 28 and for all of the
different images there is quite
substantial savings anywhere from 50 and
much much higher and to be able to
support these we will be using the
picture element and it's pretty easy to
use the picture element i'm going to
come here and write picture
and then just come down here and we're
going to close picture
and there's a little bit more to it but
this is the very beginning where you
actually do keep your image inside of
the picture here you can do a lot more
with the picture element than what we're
going to be using for it here you can
have it bring in different images based
on the density of the screen so if you
want to bring in a lower res image so
it's lighter weight a higher version
image for larger ones you can also use
it for art direction where you can add a
media attribute within here as well so
you can do art direction where you're
coming in with different images
depending on the space that that image
has available to it but we're going to
keep things really simple just as an
introduction to the picture element here
where i'm going to write source
and source is a lot like the source we
have right here so we have a picture
then we have our source and in this
source what we're going to do is write
source set and then we want to get the
exact same image so i'm going to take
this one and put it right there but we
can switch that out for my web p and you
do need to give the browser a little bit
of context about what the source is and
so it can know if it's able to use it or
not so i'm going to come in with a type
is equal to we're going to say image
slash web p and if you're familiar with
video this might look very familiar to
you
uh one of the things that's a bit
different is where you can provide it to
these here and we don't have an avif but
if you say we did have an avid version
you could come in here and have the avif
and then over here just do it like that
and what this is doing is this is
setting the png as our default but the
browser is going to look through these
and it's going to see which one it wants
to use does it support webp oh you could
use that does it support this nope okay
i'm going to use this and the image it's
really important you do have an image
here because it's actually going to
replace this with what we see here so we
don't have this version so i'm going to
delete that but just to show you how you
could provide multiple different
versions of the same image and just
really fast the reason it is source set
is because you could provide multiple
different ones here as well and this is
where if you had uh different ones with
different resolutions so this could be
your 1x and then you'd put a comma and
do mid path here
image dot
web
p and this could be your one 1.5 x
version and then you could also have a
2x version and you just comma separate
the different ones that you'd want to be
bringing in with a source set uh and
that's why it's a source set and not
just an src because you can provide a
set of different sources here but in
this case we only have these two to pick
from and if you've never seen the
picture element or used it before this
could be a nice little note to take down
as something you could explore more
going forward
we will notice that things have broken a
little bit because this image is now
because it's floating on over here
instead of being over here and that's a
really simple reason that that's
happening and will be a very very easy
fix so we can go over to my index
dot css and i'm just going to scroll all
the way down and the reason that's
happening is if you remember when we set
things up we did them all with grid
container destination image because
that's what we had so we can just change
that out now for our picture element
instead picture and this could actually
be a good argument for putting a class
because then if it was on a class
instead of an element then it could be
agnostic of either one but we can just
do picture here because we're going to
be using a picture in all of them and
that just means we do want to come down
and change it over the picture anywhere
we were using that and there are a few
more spots where that was here is
another one
and i will even though this is commented
out just in case in the future we'll
switch that one out right there and that
means everything should be working fine
on this page but we do need to also go
and fix that on our crew commander page
because if we look now the crew
commander has shifted over and
everything has broken there because this
one is still an image so i'd encourage
you to go and just try switching out the
image we have here for using the picture
element with the webp in the source and
then leaving this one just like that and
just so you can get a little bit of
practice writing it all in and building
up some muscle memory there and in just
a second i'll go through and do it
myself as well
all right so we can come in with our
picture over here we close our picture
and then here we just need to add in our
source
and we need the source set is equal to
and now everything should be good we'll
hit save and we've fixed all of our
problems and everything is working
beautifully right now and with all of
that in place i do believe it is time to
start adding the functionality or at
least uh in the next lesson we won't be
adding the functionality itself but
we'll be setting the stage so we're able
to add the functionality very very soon
so if you've been at this for a little
while i'd really encourage you to take a
nice break right now before we get into
this next section just to give yourself
time to digest everything you've been
learning and then when you're ready to
keep on going i'll see you in the next
lesson
how the fun begins and we want to add
some interactivity to our site where
when someone clicks on mars it brings
them to the mars tab or the europa tab
or the titan tab and make it easy to go
back and forth between them all so as
i've mentioned a few times now one a
very simple way would actually to make
these links instead of buttons and each
one is just its own page which would
just involve taking what we've already
created on say our moon page and then
copy paste everything in place but then
just change out the content for the next
planet and do the same thing for each
one of the planets and that would work
very well but we want to make things a
little bit more interesting in here so
we're going to be using javascript to be
able to do it
again if you want to just step things up
and level up even more than what i'm
doing here the data.json file is there
and everything could be populated from
there instead in this case what i'm
going to be doing is the middle ground
which will require having duplicate
content on the page and cycling through
that content so we're gonna have all of
that html content only on this page and
then when somebody comes and clicks on
mars it will just change we'll hide the
moon content and we'll bring in that
mars content and the same for each one
of these other ones so to be able to do
that we need to set the stage so we have
that content to be able to cycle through
so because this destination page for me
is going to be acting as my only
destination page and not through those
other ones i am going to rename this
page and we're just going to call it
destination instead of destination moon
but i will leave those other ones for
now because we still need them to get
the content that will populate all of
our text and everything
and one thing we're going to want to do
now is to actually create all of this
extra content so i'm going to come and
take this and we're going to put in four
images three four
and you can maybe guess what i'm going
to do is this first one will get changed
to image mars this one here will get
changed from image moon over to
europa and if i spelled everything right
all of the images and actually we
shouldn't actually see all of the images
we should only see one image if i did
everything right here and actually we'll
have to hit the run and not save and we
should only have one image which should
be titan and yeah there we have it we
only have titan that is showing up
because all of these images are actually
there they're just overlapping each
other because they're all living in the
same place so there's the next one
underneath it and now this isn't what we
want to do we don't want them all
visible at the same time and overlapping
each other so there is something we can
do to hide them and your first instinct
might be to come on and use that class
of sr only because that visually hides
things we don't want to visually hide
them only though because if somebody is
using an assistive technology and the
screen reader is reading through it it
will read all of these and i just
realized i didn't change these out
either so we do want to make sure all
descriptions are good
so those are better and if an assistive
technology was going through here now we
have the proper alts in place we don't
want the screen reader to be able to see
them and we don't want people to
visually be able to see them either so
what we can do for that is to actually
come on here and use the hidden
attribute and the hidden attribute hides
it from both screen readers and
assistive technologies as well as from
visually hiding the content on the page
so if i hit save now we can see we only
see the moon and if i add the hidden
here hidden and then we take this one
off and hit save we will only see mars
so that is what we're going to use to
hide and show the planets we're actually
going to be using the same thing for all
of our content as well
and so if we come down
we have our articles that are here and
if you have a guess at how i'm going to
do this it's very similar to what i did
for all the images you can go ahead and
set it all up now
as i said very similar to what i did
from images let's just come down
and for this i am going to use some
comments because there is a lot of
content that is here that is very
similar so this last one will be titan
this one up here will be
europa
this one here whoops not the wrong spot
this one here will be mars and then this
one here is the moon
and this just makes our life a lot
easier when we're scrolling up and down
and looking at our html to know which
one we're on
and so uh with that i'm gonna quickly go
through and actually change all the
content just copying and pasting it from
these other pages and then we'll talk a
little bit more about how this is going
to work maybe a while though anyone's
able to visit yeah titan considering it
would be a seven year trip wow uh
they're already worried about the
radiation in getting to mars which is
just a few months so imagine trying to
get over to there anyway uh with all of
those in place if i hit save we just
have a mess of content because
everything is just overlapping each
other and it is a complete disaster
as you can see there so we want to come
onto each one of these in the moon i
will leave alone but then on mars we
want to add in hidden
on the next one we want to come in and
add our hidden class or attribute i
should say it's an attribute not a class
and then hidden here as well hit save
and there we go we're back on it just
being the moon so now we need to make it
so when we click on them things move
around and we also want to be doing this
in as accessible as a way as possible so
in the next lessons we'll be handling
javascript we'll also be jumping back
into our html to making some changes in
here as we go as well just to make sure
that everything is as accessible as
possible
all right so here we are in a nice blank
javascript file and you'll notice one
thing i have changed just really quickly
is i've created this navigation.js this
was just the index.js that we'd started
with originally
just for development purposes i find it
much easier to separate the concerns
into separate files and then you can use
input when you go to production you can
have something minify that all into one
uh all into one file if needed or for
something like this tabs it is on every
page except the home page but if you had
this only needed on one page it might be
fine just to have it as something that
you're only including in that one page
so let's go and do that now we'll go to
my destination and here we can just copy
that script and add this in so this will
be set as my tabs.js so it's linked and
we can make sure it's working when we're
actually going to be using it
and now what do we want to do well the
first thing is we need to be able to
access my tabs list itself so let's go
and do that so we can say tab
we can select my tab list and i will do
my document.queryselector
and
for this there's
you could select the class because we
have a class that is available to us but
to ensure that somebody who is
implementing a tab system say there was
another page that got added that needed
it to ensure that they're taking we
spent all that time setting things up
to make sure that things were accessible
so if you create your tablets this way
making sure that the person's actually
used the role when creating it it
reinforces that accessibility because
the whatever they put in place
if they haven't used the proper roles on
everything it will be one way to ensure
that it doesn't actually work
so we sort of make sure that the right
steps are being taken and we can hear
we've found our tab list and our tabs
live in there so just to make it a
little bit easier for the browser we can
look inside our tab list for our uh
for the different tabs and for this i
will use a query selector all
because we have multiple tabs defined
and so in there we can then once again
reinforce the accessibility a little bit
by coming in and saying that the role is
equal to tab and now we are ready to
start rocking and rolling uh there we
will need to get the images as well but
we'll come back to that stage a little
bit later and for now in this lesson
what i want to be focused on is the
keyboard navigation to be able to go
between the different tabs that we have
here
so to do that let's just start with our
tab list and add an event listener add
event listener
on there and normally we'd be listening
for
clicks it's something very often but in
this case i want to listen for a key
down
and that just means if somebody pushes a
key we want something to happen so we
can come in with a function
and once again using an arrow function
there and i am going to come and put e
here for you know we could write event
as well if you wanted to but i'm going
to put e what we want to do is when and
in this unlike our navigation it's
really important that we track where
what the event is happening on so when
that key down happens we need
information from that so let's just do a
console log of e
and see what that tells us what's what's
the browser getting from that
so browser list is not defined
tab list oh i put tab lists sorry we'll
do tab list here as well it should be a
singular list and not multiple lists so
i'm going to tab on to moon and now what
i'm going to do is just push a key on my
keyboard and you can see we're getting a
keyboard event so what that e is getting
is it saying
it's giving us the keyboard event saying
an event has just happened and it is a
keyboard event which makes sense because
we're looking for key down and then with
the keyboard event you can actually get
a key code
so let's go check with that keycode is
so we'll select moon again and i can
start pushing buttons on my keyboard and
you see numbers coming up
and these numbers correspond to the key
that i'm pushing and i can push
basically any key on my keyboard and get
the key that is associated with it and
the only two that we care about right
now are my left key which is 37 and my
right key which is 39. so
let's go and make sure we don't forget
those so i'm going to create two new
cons we're going to say const
d
down left down left is going to be equal
to 37 and a const t down right is equal
to 39 just because it's going to make
our life a little bit easier and as we
build everything out here
and now we can do different things based
on those key down numbers so at this
stage there's a few different things
that need to be done
so we know we can now we're looking for
a left key down or a right key down and
this just leaves a few different things
to be done so if we go back over to our
destination and look at how things were
done first of all we have this tab index
of zero that's here and then a tab index
of one negative one on this which means
it's not selectable so if ever we push
it it means that we need to change
this to a negative one and make the new
one be an actual one and the easiest way
to do that is
first by uh just coming in on here and
just saying
uh when we have the key down we want to
change the tab index
of the current uh tab to negative one so
it doesn't matter which key it is that's
something that needs to happen and then
we want to say if the right key
is pushed
move move to the next tab on the right
or
if the left key is pushed move to the
next tab on
on the left
and so if you do have javascript
experience and you're feeling
comfortable being able to do all of this
there's a few little
other things that will have have to
happen for this to work also in here so
i didn't break this down as much as we
could but if you're feeling comfortable
and you just want to run with it and see
if you can get this working then
definitely go for it right now if you're
learning javascript you're a little bit
not sure what the next steps should be
still try it out see what you can do but
i will be giving you some hints and push
you in the right direction at the start
of the next lesson or if you're
completely new to javascript or it's
something you've just started with and
you're feeling a little bit lost right
now in the next video we'll try and
break things down as much as possible
let's focus on this one first even
though it's gonna give us some some
difficulty but let's say if the e key
code
is equal to our key
down
left
or
our e dot key code is equal to
our key down right we want to do
something and that's because we want to
make sure that we remove or we change
the current um
we want to be able to change the current
button to get rid of the tab index
that's on there so let's go and see if
this is even going to work let's just
say we console
log test
for now and i'm going to hit save on
that and so i'm on the moon that's
selected i can push to the right or left
and either when i'm pushing it's saying
test if i push on any other key nothing
is happening so
if the key is equal my left or right
we're console logging our test which we
don't want to do obviously we want to do
something else so let's console log
and i'm actually going to console log
tabs for now which is all of our tabs
and hit save on there again and now when
i select it you can see that it's coming
up with a node list because our
query selector all creates a node list
and actually if we go and look in the
actual console and we have one two three
four and that would be my one two three
four buttons and if you're newer to
javascript uh javascript does start
counting at zero so the first button in
our node list is number zero then number
one then number two
so if we want to be able to select just
the first one which is the currently
selected one
we want to select zero so we can just
put a zero like that right there and now
if we test it and we hit tab
and we go and select the moon and i push
to the right we can see that we're only
getting the first one that's coming up i
know it's the first one because if i
look here we can actually see that area
controls is my moon tab so i know i'm
getting the first button
the only issue is we actually need to be
able to cycle through the buttons as
things are changing and so right now our
tab focus is equal to zero so i can
actually come here and switch this out
to say tab focus
so if i save now it's gonna be the exact
same thing left or right it's giving me
the same thing we had before because our
tab focus here is our zero that's right
here so we know that if we
select this one we are getting our first
button for now and what we want to do on
there is similar to what we did on our
navigation when we would change an
attribute we could use set attribute to
do that and i want to set the attribute
of my tab index
to be negative one because if you
remember when we set all of this up what
we did was we said moon is zero because
we want people to tab onto it and these
ones have the negative one but if i push
to the right or the left this one
shouldn't be focusable anymore so i'm
going to change this to negative one in
javascript and then we need to change
one of these other ones back over to
zero so we'll see how we can do that in
a second but i'll put zero back on this
just so it is still selectable so in
doing that we're enabling it so we can
remove the attribute when that key down
does happen
now what's important is we need to
change our tab focus to select the next
button and we need to make sure that
we're selecting the correct one so to
make sure that we're doing that let's
say we'll start with the right
functionality and then we'll do the same
thing but the other way around for the
the backwards so here we can say that if
our e dot key code is equal to our key
down right so if we click to move to the
right we want something to happen and
the first thing i'm going to say is tab
focus plus plus and have focus is the
same as actuating tab focus is equal to
tab focus
plus one so we're saying let's add one
to here and then
save that number back into here so if
this is at zero it becomes one if this
is at one we do one plus one is two and
then tab focus becomes two and so on and
so forth and we can just say that that
is a plus plus right there so let's do
that and let's console log our
tab focus to make sure this is actually
working so we'll hit save we'll select
my moon and push to the right we get one
two three four five oh no we got past
five because there's no more tabs to
actually go through and actually we can
test one more thing before i do anything
else if i come back to my page now i can
actually not select my moon tab anymore
because this has been set to negative
one now let's save the page so just make
sure everything's refreshed we've
selected moon i push to the right and i
can start cycling through but then if i
push tab again and then i do a shift tab
to go backwards it jumps up to my
navigation because it can't select my
moon anymore because this has a negative
one on it so i know this is also working
at the stage
so we know this is working and our tab
focus is going up every time we push to
the right so that's a good sign there is
one thing that we could go too far that
we don't want to happen but for now what
we'll do is let's just leave that like
that uh there is more to do in here but
just to make sure we can go up and down
why don't you take what we've created
here and see if you can get it to
subtract when we go the other way so if
i push left on the keyboard it subtracts
and makes tab focus go down instead of
going up
all right so i'll grab that paste it in
there and we just want to make sure this
is my key down left not my key down
right and we have a plus plus we can do
a minus minus instead
so now we go on my moon push to the
right one two three push to the left to
one so now by pushing that the keys on
here we can cycle through those
different numbers and that is super
super good and we're actually getting
pretty close to being done so let's just
take these comments out because i think
they you know this is saying what we're
doing so with that in place now what we
want to do is when we tab into and have
moon selected if i push to the right or
left i actually want it to switch to i
want the focus to switch to that tab i
don't want it to change the content
that's here yet i want it to be if they
they can shift the focus over to the
next one and then if they choose that
tab then it will change the content
that's inside of it and to choose the
tab once it's selected you can just push
space on the keyboard and it will select
that button so when someone pushes left
or right i want the focus to move to
that next tab and to be able to do that
there's two important things one of them
is we want the focus to actually move to
that tab and we also want to change the
tab index on that one as well to set it
to zero so if you feel like you have a
little idea in your head about how we
could accomplish that go ahead and do
that now if you'd like a little hint i'm
going to give one in the next lesson and
if you just want to follow along a
little bit with me as well we'll be
continuing off here in the next lesson
and i'll leave this for you as we have
it at the moment
all right so if you tried that out i
hope that it went well and you were able
to get it to work and if you ran into
any issues let's see if we can help you
with them right now
so what we're going to do is choose my
tabs with my tab focus here and on here
what we do is then say set attribute and
it's kind of the opposite of what we did
when we went here where we set it to
negative one we actually want to set
this one to
zero which makes it so we can actually
select it and three with zero there and
what this means is that next tab
actually becomes something that can be
focused on
what it doesn't do is focus that tab
immediately and we want to make sure
that the focus switches at the same time
so to be able to do that we can come in
and say tab tab focus
and then we can say that we want to set
the focus on here and do it just like
that we could string these together but
doing it like this is nice and clear so
i'm going to leave it like this and to
test and just double make sure that it's
working i'm going to go to my css file
and let's just come down and say
role is equal to
tab
focus
and we'll say the color is lime green
and with that in place make sure this is
saved and let's go and take a look if
it's working so i should be able to tab
onto moon and then push to the right and
look at that we've changed and change
and we can go back and forth between
them now but we do run into a problem
and that problem is if i go to the right
and then what happens if i push right
again now
we get an error
because there's nothing to set the
attribute on it's trying to go to a
fifth element here and there is no fifth
element and now i've completely broken
it and the same problem could happen i'm
going to refresh my page get onto my
moon we can go that way but then if i go
back to my moon and i push to the left
we get an error there because there's
nothing to go to and that breaks
everything
so if you know how to fix this you can
go ahead and come up with a solution to
it now and if not i'll be showing a
solution in just a few seconds
so what we want to do is if somebody
pushes the right and they get all the
way to titan and then they push right
again there's two options one of them is
we just don't let it happen or we cycle
back and bring it back to moon and
that's what i'm going to do but if you
chose one where it just stopped going
and then you got to hear and it stopped
going that way i think that'd be okay
but i just like being able to cycle
through things and i just think that's a
little bit easier if somebody is using
keyboard navigation to move between
these
um and if it's especially if it's a
screen reader and you push to the right
and it just does nothing you might be a
little bit confused and not know why
nothing's happening
and again then you'd probably figure it
out but let's lower the friction as much
as possible here
so on the tab focus we want to do a plus
plus but we don't want it to go any
higher than what it's doing so if we get
to the end we want to go back to the
start so if tab focus
is um we want to say if it's greater
than or equal to
tabs.length let's let's find out what
tabs.length even is
before before i say that so we can say
tabs
so let's say console log tabs.length
now anytime i push to the right we see
four come up so it's basically just
counting how many items we have in this
list even though we're starting counting
at zero it knows you know it's zero one
two three it counts for all four items
that are in there so
if let's so let's bring back that if
statement that i just had is so if tab
focus is greater than or equal to tab's
length so if it becomes four or bigger
we want to do something and as i said i
want to cycle it back to moon over here
so either if you weren't sure how to do
this at all or if you created something
that worked but it stopped when it got
to titan and you want to try and get it
to go back there why don't you see if
you can figure out what the solution to
this would be to get it to go back to
the beginning
all right so for that one it's not too
tricky we just have to say tab focus is
now equal to zero if tab focus happens
to get to a number that's too big it
just goes back to zero and so let's try
that out and i should be able to go to
my moon go that way go that way and now
fingers crossed
it goes back to moon and i can just keep
cycling around that way but if i go the
other way it breaks again so we need to
bring that same type of functionality
down to this one so if you've been
following up until now because you
weren't too sure why don't you go to see
if you can reverse this to get it to go
the other way around right here
all right so i hope you were able to do
that and you might have had to think
about it a little bit if you especially
if you're not used to javascript so i'm
going to say the same thing before tab
focus but in this case we don't have to
be equal to anything we just want to say
that if it's less than
zero and this is where if you're newer
to javascript maybe you got tripped up a
little bit
when we're going bigger we want to stop
when we get to the end of our list but
when we're going the other way our first
item is zero so if we go lower than zero
we want to change our tab focus
and so what you might have done or what
sometimes
people will do in something like this is
they'll say tab focus is equal to four
i don't want to do that because if i say
uh three even it shouldn't be four
because we're starting count at zero so
zero one two three would be titan uh the
issue with that and this is the same
reason i use tabs length here instead of
just putting in a hard-coded number is
because what happens if they end up
adding another destination or if we're
reusing this on one of the other pages
later on we obviously don't want this to
cause any issues along the way so that's
where we can come here and say tabs
dot length
this once again will cause a little bit
of an issue because if we do that um
let's just go look and see what happens
where whoops i forgot this so let's go
and fix that and go take a look and now
if i go there and i go from here and i
go to the left it gives me an error
because it's trying to find something
that doesn't exist yet because tab
length is 4 but we have zero one two
three right here so if ever you do
something like this this does need to be
a negative one right there
so it's the full length because we have
four items but because we start counting
at zero we have to subtract one from the
counting we were doing so a little bit
tricky not so straightforward so if you
did get stuck if you were newer to all
of this no problem at all now let's go
test it out now so we can go this way we
knew that was working and now we can go
that way as well and we can cycle
through in both directions
so i'm super happy with that and one
thing that we can actually do here just
to clean things up a little bit instead
of having all of this here is to grab
this and take all of it out
just like this
and i'm going to come over here instead
and we're going to say that we're going
to have a function
called change
tab focus
and the advantage of doing this is it's
just going to help us sort of clean
things up and make it a little bit more
clear what's actually happening so we
can change tab focus and we're saving
all of those things that we did and i'll
just grab this tab focus and sort of
keep it with that function
just because they're related this does
need to be kept in um this does need to
be kept outside this function or just
the numbering is going to go off and
then what we can do to simplify this
even is when we have the key down we
want to do something and we want to
change the focus uh the tab focus right
there so we can actually delete most of
this just like that and just say change
tab focus just like this so when
somebody so we're listening for a key
down and when a key down happens we're
going to change the tab focus then we
want to know what is that we can look
down here and find that function and see
everything that it's doing right there
so let's hit save and just double check
that it's still working there we go we
can see that we can still cycle through
our tabs and everything there is working
perfectly fine
so this just makes it a little bit
easier because we're gonna have another
function that's going to activate this
so we're going to be able to select the
tab and then activate the tab so we're
just sort of making it a little bit
easier to read so we know what's
happening and then if we need to make
changes to our tab focus we can do that
and if you're comfortable or feeling up
for a bit of a challenge in activating
the content itself when a tab is clicked
on then why don't you go ahead and add
that functionality now and if you want
to see how i get started with it i'll be
doing that at the start of the next
lesson
all right so i hope that went well for
you if you took the challenge on and if
you weren't too sure about where to get
started with it we're going to do that
now and we're going to do something very
similar to what we did here but this one
will have to be a little bit different
because i need to be going onto each
individual tab instead of looking at the
entire tab list all at once and to do
that i'm going to say tabs got
four each so we can cycle through and
loop through the different tabs that we
have
and then with this for each that means
we can do something with each one of the
individual tabs so we're pretty much
saying for each thing that's in here we
want to run a function
i'm putting the word tab here you can
call this literally anything you want it
to be it's just we have tabs so tabs for
each tab that is inside of there we want
to do something so i think that you know
that's a very common uh naming
convention to have your plural here and
then the singular one here
and then for each one of these we can
add our event listener so then we can
say tab dot add event listener and in
this case we don't want a key down we
want to look listen for a click
and then if somebody clicks we want to
do something and
let's just say for now we'll come in
with a really quick function to see
what even this is doing and i'm just
going to say console.log
tab itself just so we can see what we're
getting so if i come on to moon and i
click on it
you can see the area controls moon or my
mars
or my euro bus so when i'm clicking on
them it's working interestingly enough
if i use my mouse to navigate through
here and then i push spacebar it's also
going to act as a click so it means that
it's also very easy to keyboard and
navigate through here which is very good
and so there we go that's how this is
working and how we can get an event
listener on each tab and it knows what
we're doing on each of them but we're
going to take a similar approach than we
did here so for each one of those we can
delete all of this
and delete that and we can say here that
we just want to say change tab panel and
that's what our function will be called
so before we were changing the tab focus
and cycling through our tabs now we're
going to be looking at the indiv the
entire tab panel that we have there as
well and so that's all we're going to be
doing and i just need to close that so
we're closing everything off and now we
actually have to create this tab panel
function so let's go all the way down to
here and then we can say function
we can then come in and create something
so there's a few different things we're
going to have to do this time and if you
weren't too sure where to get started
and this sort of pushed you in the right
direction you can take off from right
here and obviously if you'd like a
little bit of help i'm going to keep on
going so what we're going to do is a
const target button it's equal to e dot
target and target and let's see what
that even is so console log
of my target button
and let's go take a look
whoops i'm missing a
and here i'm just missing uh closing
parentheses sorry about that and so now
if we go and take a look uh if i click
on one of them we are getting our target
buttons this is the same console log i
was doing before so we're getting the
button that we've clicked on or the tab
i guess this could actually be target
tab would make more sense
so there we go we're selecting the
our target tab the tab that we've
clicked on then the next thing we want
to do is get our const target panel
target tab and on here what i'm going to
do is i get attribute and this is a
and if you can think of if you want to
go look in the destination and how we
set everything up what attribute do we
have that is on there that we'd be able
to use and find out what panel we want
to be getting so remember the target tab
we're going to see the button and we
have an attribute on the button that is
linking it to a panel so i really
encourage you if you haven't already
built this out on your own to go and
dive into that and see if you can find
out which attribute that would be
so i hope you found it maybe even got
that in there and got a little bit more
working so let's go look at our
destination page and this is here when
we have a button we have our area
controls the moon tab and that is going
to bring us to here and i just realized
we actually forgot the role that we
needed on these so i'm going to bring
those over in a little bit but right now
we don't need them yet
um so we have our area controls of our
moon tab so this is the one that we need
at the moment so let's go back to our
tabs.js and that means here we can get
our area
controls let's go and do a console log
again console log
target
panel just like that let's go see if
this works if i click on moon moon tab
if i click on mars mars tab so we're
getting the attribute and it's telling
us the name
of the panel that we wanted to activate
so that is perfect i'll leave the
console log there because we're going to
keep on console logging stuff as we're
going through so now we want to show
that selected panel we know which one we
want we want to be able to show it and
this is where things are actually a
little bit tricky because when we're
looking at our tabs here and what we're
cycling through in this this target
panel is really just like a a string
we're not actually finding the the piece
in there that we need to show and so if
we go back to our destination page we
look at how this tabs are set up right
now we're inside of this div so we're
living here right now and we don't
actually really want to be living here
right now we don't even want to be in
the parent we're sort of on this
individual button thing here if we
jumped up to the parent we'd be over
here and what we need to do is move from
here to like this bigger to this entire
main really and we need to look at
everything that's in here on the main
so we can do that not too difficultly
but it is a little bit strange and if
you got this might be something that
sort of caught you off guard and you're
unsure of how we can find the right
article and so we need to do is take a
step back
to here to do a few things that we're
going to do a little bit later on and
then we need to do that further step
back to be able to get into like the
entire parent to be able to do some
different manipulations on there
so i'm actually going to create another
const here so this is going to be
const tab container and we want to say
target tab
and then from here we can say the parent
node and that just means select the
parent so let's take my tab container
and console log that to make sure it's
working so if i click on any of these it
should show us my entire tab list so tab
list tab list tab list it's showing up
for each and every one of them so we've
select every time we click on that it is
identifying which one the parent is but
as i said we also need to be able to
take a step up from there so we can do
one more step here of saying const main
container
and equal tab container dot parent node
parent
node and you you might be saying this is
a weird way to be like stepping
backwards but it's safer to do it this
way to then to be doing a specific query
selector to try and find the parent
because you could be saying well kevin
it's always in the
you know my parent in this case is my
main but you might drop it into a
situation where you don't want to be
looking in the main you have a different
setup maybe it's in an aside all of a
sudden and then the main doesn't help or
it's in a footer for some reason
or it's you know nested in a completely
different way where it's three levels
deeper so the important thing is you
just want to have a div here that's your
tab list and then a list of articles all
the articles individually placed outside
and then
as long as these guys are all siblings
with each other this is always going to
work no matter what situation you're
being put into and wherever your plug-in
playing thing so it just makes it a
little bit more robust even though it
might seem a little contrived to like
step back a little bit
so now if we come in when we click we
should always get our main in this case
but again if you plugged and played this
you could use it in different places and
it would still work perfectly fine so
now that we know which one the main
container is we can go in in my main
container and do a query selector we
want my my query selector to be anything
that has the attribute the the query
that has this attribute on it
now to be able to do that we so we want
an attribute selector so we can come in
with our query selector with our
attribute selector and what we want to
do is actually use something called a
template literal where we're going to
use a set of backticks and inside the
backpicks we can then call we're going
to do this guy right here our pound
symbol and then use this guy right here
so we can go in and get our target panel
and so we can say target panel
and when we do that we want to do
something on this target panel which is
to remove
remove the attribute
of which attribute you want to remove
the hidden one because that is why we
can't see it on the screen
so if we do that let's see i'm going to
comment this out because we don't need
that and let's try this out and see what
happens so i'm going to
get on to let's go and select europa and
push spacebar
and it shows up but we have a problem
which is our old content is still there
so if you want to try and solve that
problem right now and i'll be looking at
the solution to that in the next lesson
so obviously that's a little bit of a
disaster where we can hide and overlap
content like that because it just
doesn't look nice and we can just we can
keep on going and get all of them there
and we don't want that to happen so
before this happens we want to be able
to hide the current panel that we're
already on and one thing that we're not
looking at right now is what the current
tab actually is so one way you could
solve this is find what the current one
is and then add the attribute of hidden
on there and another way that simplifies
things a little bit is it doesn't really
matter which one we're on we can just
hide everything and then activate this
afterward where we're removing the
hidden from the one that we need to see
so that just means we can do a little
bit less work
so to do that we can just say that our
main container and on the main container
we can then do a query selector and i
want to actually we need to find all of
them and currently they're articles so i
will just come in here and write find
every article that is in there
and as you've seen before and let's put
a bit of space here
you've seen before that when we do have
a query selector all we can then do and
we've just used this recently we can
loop through all of them
and so let's do that let's say our query
selector all every article we can loop
through them all so we can run a for
each and so for each and we can say
rtcol what do we want to do we want to
for each article we can then say set
at tribute and we can just set a hidden
is equal to true
on all of them now this is making one
really long line so one way that this
can actually be made a little bit
simpler is you could um break this up
over multiple lines so we could actually
say
main container query selector and then
just put a space there and it knows what
to do with that
um and then even here we could break
things up onto multiple lines here if we
wanted to as well um i'm gonna leave it
just like this though and we're gonna
hit save and if we click here you can
see now it's actually working now we
have a little jumping content that's
happening there which is kind of
interesting and it's happening because
the text here is
shorter here and longer here and it's
actually causing even the image to move
which i'm surprised the image is moving
so we'll take a look at that in um once
we sort of clean things up because we
might have to play with the things a
little bit more but also just to check
things should still be working at this
one as well where we can see our content
is
um behaving properly and there we go so
we can see things are working nicely and
we're able to go between the different
pieces of content
and so again we're saying here that
everything is becoming hidden and then
we're turning on the one that we wanted
instead of having to try and find which
one we were doing
now the problem with this is this is an
article and just like before i was
saying that we want this to be able to
be used anywhere and if maybe you're
doing a tab system that isn't using
articles that should be fine we
shouldn't be forced to be using articles
necessarily because you could be tabbing
through other pieces of information that
maybe aren't you know and articles not
the right co the right semantic code to
be using here what i'm going to do is
we're going to jump back over into my
destination
and on each one of the articles i am
going to add a role so we can come over
here and i'm going write role is equal
to
tab panel and this and for the rules you
can't invent your own and i might have
maybe should have mentioned this earlier
but since we're here roles are very
specific things that come from area so
i'm not inventing these these are
existing things that i'm using and it
adds as i said it adds context to things
like divs and so
before in the old days this would be a
lot more useful now we have our nav our
header our main so we don't need to use
roles as much as we used to but there
are certain things where we do and again
they're very they're predefined these
aren't things that i'm creating on my
own and for each one of these we can
come in and add a role of tab panel
and last but not least we have this one
right there on titan so i've saved that
and let's go back to my tabs here and it
just means instead of selecting my
article for each one we can come in and
change this to save for each and then in
here we can say the role is equal to and
put my tab panel
and just make sure that if you have
single quotes use double quotes or vice
versa and this should be lowercase there
we go
and then here i can change this to say
panel and panel so it's a little bit
more consistent so for each tab panel so
we get all of my tab panels for and then
for each uh panel we go through and set
that panel's attribute to hidden so
same functionality let's just go and see
make sure that i didn't break anything
and it looks like it is still working so
i'm happy with that we can go through
and also do it with our keyboard
navigation and i'm happy with that
except it seems to have broken something
right there with my moon title and so
let's go over there and see i probably
just took off one too many um
closing brackets
and that's exactly what it was we just
have to make sure that we close that
right there and we fixed it good okay
uh and now we can cycle through and
select the one we want and there we go
it's working just like it should uh of
course no we have another problem which
is our image isn't changing so why don't
we look at how we can do that in the
next lesson and as usual if you want to
take your own stab at it first you can
go for it and then i'll be taking a look
at it over there in the next lesson
and if you did get stuck at all you
should be able to take a lot of what
we've already done here but to make it
work for our images
and as i actually said in a previous
lesson when we were setting everything
up ideally the images would be part of
our tab system but because of the way
the layout was working um i couldn't
actually fit it into like the tab panel
and
just with the the way the layout broke
especially on the destination page but
with the tabs like with the image let's
get to this screen size with the image
being up here then the tabs and that
down there
i couldn't find a good solution to
include the image within the article
here so that's why we are separating
them out but we should be able to change
them so the first thing we'll do is we
saw that we need to hide things so as i
said we can do things very similar to
what we did here to hide the image so
why don't we copy that and then just
break things down and see how we can use
that to also hide the image
so my main container query selector all
but this time we want to select all of
my images or in this case it is the
picture element and i was saying before
how i didn't like using article up
higher for that like it doesn't i like
that it could work in an environment
where maybe the the article isn't an
article it's just a div or it's
something or it could be something else
and i think that could actually make
sense depending on different contexts
here if we have an image ideally it
would always be a picture element uh if
you wanted to make this a little bit
more robust you could make it and look
for either a picture or an image and
only use whatever it comes across we
don't run it into any problems but i
feel pretty safe saying we're doing a
query selector all for the pictures
and then we could say for each image and
remember this here and i could say like
for each pick
if we wanted just so it's sort of
keeping the same um the same thing or
even picture
so we're doing we're looking for all the
pictures and then for each picture
we can then set the attribute of hidden
to true and of course if this becomes
picture this one will also have to
become a picture and let's hit save and
go and check that out and ideally that
would just mean the image would vanish
and it does look at that there we go
perfect
and then the next thing we need to do is
get the new image to come in and now we
actually need to do something very
similar to how we did this to be able to
get the image to work but there is a bit
more work than has to be done than is
super obvious right now so if you want
to give it a try you might run into a
few issues along the way that could trip
you up a little bit but if you want to
give it a try i'd really encourage you
to do it but it's not as simple as
taking this and switching this out so
that's the first thing i'm going to say
if you'd like another hint i'm going to
give one in a few seconds and then after
that hint i'll wait another few seconds
before i give the actual solution
all right so for this you will need to
use as i said something very similar
here
but
the target panel here we could change
this to say target image
first off though my target panel is
something that we've already defined up
here so
that means we need to define what our
target image actually is and to be able
to find the image that we want to target
we will have to make a few little
additions and changes in our html and
i'm just going to leave it there that's
the one thing i'm going to say just to
make sort of a link the same way that we
linked our panels to our tabs to our
panels we're going to create a different
type of link from our tabs to our images
i'll leave that hint there for you try
it out and again if you get stuck don't
feel bad i'll wait a few seconds now to
let you take on this challenge and then
i'll go through and show you my solution
all right so as i said we need to come
up here and let's say const target image
is going to be equal to
and how do we find out so let's let's
just keep on going target tab dot
get attributes
and if you remember area controls goes
to an id so we can't use the area
control so we do have to use something
else here
and so let's before we do that let's
come back to my destination and just
take a look here so here we have my area
controls moon tab and then if we look
down here that's linking to my id and
well an id is a good way to hook into
something because you know there's only
one of them so we could come up and add
the ids to these pictures up here i'm i
think that actually makes a lot of sense
so i'm going to come into each one of
these and i'll add an id to them and
i'll see you in just one a second
all right so there we go i have a moon
image by mars image my europa image and
my id of titan image on that picture and
now how can we hook into those what can
we do and one way that we can do that is
on their buttons that we have here we
get to add more attributes to here and
i'm going to come in with data image and
remember data attributes are ones that
are your own attribute unlike an area or
on like our roles
and other things like that this is
something you can define and you can do
anything you want with it so my moon
would just be my moon image and so on
and so forth so i'm going to just
quickly place this on all of them and
then we'll go back into getting
everything working
all right so all of those data
attributes are in place and let's go
over to my tabs now and if you can think
of how to finish this off if you haven't
already done it go ahead and do that and
then i'll take over and do it myself
so here we can say our get attribute of
data image and that means that if we hit
save now that should be it
look at that our image is also changing
so cool and so fun so just like that
we've created most of the functionality
that we need but there's one more thing
that we need to do with all of this
which i'll be addressing in the next
lesson plus i think we can clean this up
a little bit as well
and so if we go over back to my
destination page and we look at my
buttons
one thing that you need to remember is
we had our area selected here and we're
saying this one is currently selected
and again this is for assistive
technologies to know which tab is
currently the active tab and if you
remember when we styled things up like
we go to my page now and i click on
these it's not actually switching which
one is the active tab and that's because
we used our area selected to help us
with that and so we can take that and
take advantage of that by actually
moving that around so that is how we're
going to get this to move from one to
the next instead of needing a css class
or something like we did on our
navigation which we still haven't
actually changed but we'll do that when
we sort of clean up all the loose ends
at the very end
and so with this
we need to switch it to the active tab
so to be able to do this we need to do
two things we want to first make sure
that the current tab isn't area selected
we need to switch that to false and then
the new tab that we've selected we want
to switch it to true and for this it's
actually a little bit simpler because in
these we had to do a query selector all
to loop through all of them and apply
the hidden class
uh in this case we don't need to do that
it's a little bit easier because we only
have one that actually has
we only have one tab that currently has
the area selected of true on it and
whenever we switch there should always
only be one so for this instead of
looping through all of them to find the
one that has the false we don't need to
do that you can just find the one that
has an area selected of true on it
switch it to false and then go through
and choose the one that we need to be
choosing like sort of like we did down
here but there's an easier way to do
that as well to add the area selected of
true on there so if you want to try that
out go ahead again it's a lot simpler
than what we did here um so if you can
sort of use this for inspiration but
simplify things a little bit
and so for this we're going to start
with my tab container and we just do a
query selector on here and i'm doing the
tab container rather than the main
container both would work but we're only
looking at our tabs so i might as well
just stick with our tab container i want
to select and again there should only be
one so i can do my
area selected
is equal to true on here if ever you do
a query selector query selector is
always going even if there's a 10 of
these that were true it would stop at
the first one whereas all will get every
possible one so here we can't use a
query selector on roll tab panel because
it would stop and only get the first one
in this case there should only be one
and if there were multiple there's a
problem so
we shouldn't run into any issues but we
can say select the one that is true and
then set the attribute of area of the
area selected to false
and that means that it's no longer
selected so let's actually try that out
and see what happens so if i move over
to mars and i select that one there you
go it actually removed my selected from
there because you can see our css
styling got removed from it but now
nothing is actually showing up as
selected so what we can do and actually
i'm just going to break this down onto
another line just again to make it a
little bit easier to read instead of
having these really long
um
you know stretching off too long doesn't
look too fantastic
uh and then on this one what we can say
is this one's a little bit easier
because we want to get my target tab and
we're just dealing with the tab itself
we're not looking anywhere else so we
can just say that my target tab
has a we can actually just copy this
paste it there and make this true
and if we did this properly so when we
whatever our target tab is we'll then
get the area selected of true to show
that is now activated so let's save that
and let's click on mars and look at that
it moved over and then we can choose
europa and it moved over and so on and
so forth and if i come through and use
my arrows and then use my space bar
same thing is still working so super
super cool and i'm really happy with
that one thing i'm going to do is go to
my css and i think we can get rid of my
lime green that i had on the focus date
and i think the last thing we want to do
on here is actually clean this up a
little bit um it's getting a little bit
long as a function just because there's
lots of different things that are
happening in here and there's a lot of
repeated things that are going on that i
think we can sort of simplify and make
it into you know less less of what's
going on here and simplify things a
little bit so we'll look at that one in
the next lesson
so if we look in here right now when i
say we can fix things up like right now
this and this are almost the same and
this here and this here are almost the
same there's very very small differences
between them and when you're doing
things that are almost the same you can
usually make a function out of them they
can sort of make things a little bit
easier and it's also going to make
things a lot easier to read as well and
so we're going to do is create a
function down here so we're going to say
function hide content
and we're actually going to have a
function of hide content and we're also
going to have another one of function
show content if something all right we
want to do both of these things
and so let's grab all of this and then
see what we need to do with this to
actually abstract it away
and there's two important things here we
have my main container and we have the
content itself that we want to hide away
so what i'm going to do is we want to be
able to and like ideally this i guess
could be plug and play and be used in
different places what i'm going to say
here is the parent because the because
my main container is the parent of this
so i'm saying the parent is i'm being
able to select the parent so i could do
this and use this in different ways and
then i'm going to put the content itself
here so first i'm selecting the parent
and then i'm selecting the content
within that parent that i want to be
able to hide so that means my anywhere
that this main container will become
parent and anywhere that says
the this will then become and when i'm
saying anywhere it's just going to
become content and because that's
content panel doesn't make much sense so
i will put item and item here as well so
what that means is any i for we're going
to loop through each item that is part
of my content and it just abstracts
everything that we've written here into
what we have right here
so then what we can do is we could take
all of this and i'll comment it out for
now instead of deleting it and see why
don't you try and fill this out and see
if you can get it to work
all right so that would just be coming
here and we would just have to write
hide content the parent is my main
container like that and then comma and
my content is the tab panel exactly like
i have it right here you can put it just
like that
and to double check if it's actually
really working i'm also going to turn
this one off because that's showing the
next one i just want things to disappear
to get a really visual and if it worked
here we go it's hidden it away so that
means we can delete this and we can turn
this one back on for now so now we can
go through and it is functioning
so with that done we can also do the
same thing for this one right here so
here we can come and say hide content
and in this case the parent is my main
container once again main container and
then what i'm trying to hide is my
picture element so we can just grab a
picture
drop a picture in there we should be
able to delete all that
and once again let's turn this off and
if this works the image should just
disappear and there we go it is gone
amazing
so that means that we can turn this one
back on so i think that's pretty cool
and you saw how i did that to abstract
away for hiding content so why don't you
take your hand at making that work for
the show content
all right so i hope that went well for
you and we're going to just take the
show content which was this guy right
here i'm going to copy him paste it and
once again we'll just throw a parent
here and the content here so the parent
so the content that i want to show and
that content's parent and then that just
means that right here instead of having
all this this becomes content
and instead of main container i can
write parent right there
and we can get rid of my square bracket
and i think that is good to go so then
we can come over to here and instead of
all of that we can say show content
once again it's on my main container and
in this case it will be this one right
here paste that in we can delete that
and if everything is going well we
should also be able to do my show
content here
my main container and this time around
it would be my target image that i want
to put there and we can paste that right
there and delete that and let's go and
take a look
everything should still be working
fabulous so i'm super happy with that we
can see it's all working
and the advantage with doing something
like this is first we're not repeating
basically the same code two times we
just have it once here and then we can
reuse it as many times as we want and if
we needed to use this in other ways and
bring it into other functions where
we're hiding things or showing things it
becomes very easy to do and the main
container here can also be switched out
so it doesn't have to be something in
these very specific circumstances and
there we go i'm very happy with that and
if ever the markup got changed and we
changed a little bit of how the system
is here we need to change the main
container to something else it becomes
fairly easy to do as well
or if you need to use this in a
different tab system where maybe the
main container is different it becomes a
little bit more robust it also becomes a
little bit easier to read we have our
function of change tab panel that's
doing the area things right here and
it's hiding in my main container my tab
panels and then it's showing my target
panel which is my target panel up here
and then doing the same thing with my
images and we can read it and then you
want to know how that's working and you
can come a little bit further down so
it's a little bit less repeated code and
a little bit more obvious that we're
just hiding and showing and one other
thing we could do is actually to come up
and fix up things a little bit here just
because these if statements we have a
lot going on and i think we can make
this also a little bit easier and the
first thing is we're getting this we're
saying if it's a key left or key right
we want to do this and then we're saying
if it's a key right to do this and then
if it's the key left to do this and we
have this going on as well and really
all of these things we only want to be
happening if it's a key left or key
right and if not we can ignore all of
this code here and it doesn't have to
check those statements again so we can
actually bring all of that up inside of
here
and let's just fix the formatting on
this a little bit we can tab all that
over
tab all of this over like that
and so now we're saying if it's a key
left or key right we want to change the
focus and then we can check was it out
of these two was it actually a key right
if not we can keep on going was it
actually a key left if not we can keep
on going
and then even with this one we could do
is bring this up and do an else if if
it's a key
down then we do this else if it's a cue
left we can do this and technically you
could even bring all of this off and
just make it a complete like else
statement so if it's a key right else do
this one because we're checking is it
cue right
we're looking for either a key left or a
key right and then is it a key right yes
then do this else do that one because
the only other option is a key left i'm
personally going to leave it like this
because i think it's a little bit if
somewhere someone were to come into this
code right away i think it's a little
bit more clear that we're saying is it
key right do this is it key left do this
so even though it accomplishes the same
thing with more code it's also more
obvious what's happening so i don't
think that's a bad thing and then as
long as this was true we still want to
run through this so it's all included in
this one if statement instead of having
a whole bunch of different ones so this
entire block here won't be evaluated
unless these are true instead of having
to say is it a key left and then it's
going to check again was it a key left
so this just simplifies things a little
bit
and it won't have to check multiple
things every time a key is pushed so
let's hit save and let's just go check
that's still working my keyboard
navigation is still working and so with
that we are good to go and we're ready
to move on to the crew page
okay so we finished that other tab
system and now we have to come on to
this crew page and set this one up and
while things look a little bit different
because we have these dots down here
instead of it being that other system
it's actually going to be super super
similar to do and we don't have to
reinvent the wheel which is obviously
really nice and
so what we're going to do is we're going
to drop down to here and the first thing
we need to do is on this i'm going to do
it really fast let's rename this just to
my regular crew.html because everything
will be living in that one page and then
you saw how i set everything up on the
previous one so we do need to make a few
changes to how this is set up right here
and we also need to come through and
sort of build this system out a little
bit more so i'm just going to go ahead
and let you tackle all of that and build
everything out if you're not too sure
about some of those roles or some of
those other things you can refer back to
when i set all of those up in the
previous lessons or just the finished
code right from the last one just to see
if you're on the right page and i'm not
going to give the solution in this one
because i really do want you to tackle
this in the next one i will do it but i
will be moving a little bit faster but i
really think you have everything you
need to be able to at least get the
stage set if not add the functionality
as well because there's not too much we
need to do just don't forget to link the
javascript file because it's not
currently linked to this one so yeah
that's it for now i'm going to see you
in the next one with my solution
all right so for my solution i'm doing
this so the first thing to do is
actually give this an id of commander
tab
uh commander
tab and with that what i can do is come
over to my button right away and say
that my area controls
equals my commander tab
so we've linked those two together like
that and i'll copy and paste this onto
these other buttons really fast
and there we go we have a link between
those and once again the other thing
that we needed to do to link things
together was to come on and create a
data image
and we'll do that really fast once again
commander
image and i'll change all of the other
ones and i'll see you in just a second
and so i'll start off this just by
putting my id down here on my image as
well before i forget to do that so that
one was my commander image and we'll
bring in the rest of the content after
but i want to have everything in place
so when i copy and paste i don't i can
just make these little changes and i
won't forget anything along the way uh
the next thing that's really important
on here is on this div itself and give
this a rule of tab list as we that was
something that was really really
important and if you remember with that
it's sort of useful to have a title that
goes along with it so we can give that
the title by giving that an area label
and that will be my crew member
list
and so again the area label here means
that when it gets to this even though
there's no actual heading on here
there's no you know that we don't have
an h2 in h3 or something like that but
the area label here will be read out
crew member list and then we have these
buttons and once again we have these sr
only is where it's gonna be crew member
list the commander the mission
specialist the pilot the crew engineer
even though when we go and look at this
page none of that is actually here we
don't see that but visually we can click
through and do it but for a screen
reader it just gives them a lot more
context to be able to work
now we added i added the role of tab
list there so i'm going to come on to
each one of these buttons and also add
in the role that i need on here which is
just the role of tab so role is equal to
tab
and that also means down here i will
give this a roll of
tab panel
and there we go those are all in place
now another thing that you might
remember from our button list here that
we were creating last time is we want
these all to have tab indexes on them so
this first one is selected so my tab
index on this one will be equal to zero
and then on all of my other buttons
we want to come in and give each one of
those ones a tab
index
is equal to negative one
to negative one so it can't actually be
selected and we're gonna have to use our
keyboard navigation to go between the
different tabs
not only do we need to do that but we
also need to give this a tab
index a tab index of zero because it's
important that we can then jump from the
the different tab that we're on and then
when we hit tab it's actually going to
select the content that we have here
um and for a screen reader it's gonna
just help for to make it so they can
actually access and read the content
that's there without having to go
through each tab so they get the tab
they want they hit tab they select it
then they can push tab and get the
content related to the one that they've
just selected again if you're making
changes to tab indexes be very very
careful and make sure there's a very
good reason to be doing it the next
thing i'm going to do is just bring in
all of my other articles and images so
i'll fast forward as i do that
all right so with all that in place i
make sure that all of these have the id
that is linked with what i'd set up
above same with these all the ids that
are the right ids that we need so
everything is properly linked with our
buttons that are here
the one issue is everything is
overlapping so we do don't forget that
we need the hidden attribute on every
single one of these except for the very
first one because we want to make sure
that we have some content on the screen
before it all starts so we know throw
our head in there and then we can come
down onto our pictures here as well and
throw the hidden on there
and what's beautiful about all that is
even though it's so visually different
we're here it's this tab these like dot
systems whereas that other page was very
different in how it looked where we had
like a real tab system going on
if we come up to here and we throw on
our
tabs.js
and i hit save
it all went well
there we go look at that it's working we
don't have to do anything else it's it's
just functioning um there are a few
little things where you can see the page
is actually jumping and changing in
height because of the different images
that are coming in
and because of how the the whole system
is is really set up
and so that could be a little thing that
throws people off a little bit
especially this image seems much taller
than the other ones so it is um throwing
a little bit of a wrench in the works on
that but if you notice how we set all
this up on
this is very similar to we spent a lot
of time on our design system and it took
us quite a while to set up and then we
got to the home page and we had more
layout stuff to do but things started
coming together pretty fast as we were
doing this one
and then from there we went and started
styling up our destination page and that
one the styling on it went quite a bit
faster and there was a few little things
on getting stuff where we needed to but
it came together pretty quickly and then
finally we made it on over to our crew
page and that one the styling of it went
even faster than that because so much
was already done and in place
and now even though visually things are
very different
they are coming together so quickly with
the javascript because we've heard it
once and we just need to set everything
up properly and it's working exactly
like we need it to here so in the next
few lessons i'm going to just address on
cleaning up some of the loose ends
making sure our pages are linked
together fixing up any weird things that
might be happening and making sure
everything is good and then i'll talk to
you a little bit about the final page
all right so i thought we had a little
bit of an issue with the linking of the
pages but it's actually working since we
changed the names before but there is
the issue if it's not highlighting the
right page and this one here is not
actually going anywhere so to me
explorer should go to destination so
let's start there just by making sure
that my do do do explore we can change
this over to my destination.html
um the next thing we want to do is make
sure that when we're going to all these
different pages like i said that white
line is actually going with us and with
how i've set things up there's no
dynamic way to do it um i often get
asked about things like this it's really
just where this class is now there's
dynamic ways of doing it if you're using
a javascript framework maybe you've
already set things up so it's working by
itself and it can handle that without
you having to do any work or even a
static site generator can handle that
but i did this just with static html and
css so that just does mean when i go to
my destination page i do need to find my
index take the active class off of here
and just stick it on right there where i
need it there so now if we go and take a
look it's going to be on the destination
and it follows me from page to page and
now we want the same thing for the crew
page so let's jump on over there i would
give this to you as a challenge but it's
not really much of a challenge at this
point so i'll do it without you needing
to take over for me
and
there we go
that is working and so now if we go over
to my crew page we can see that it is
working over there as well so i think
that's really cool i'm really happy with
that um one of the things that is
bugging me a little bit is here how uh
the text difference here is actually
causing the actually it depends on the
screen size because here it's not doing
it we go a little bit bigger though the
mars text is shorter than this one and
it's
it's not actually bothering me that the
text is different because whatever uh so
that's going to happen and it doesn't
really matter but what bothers me is
that the image is actually moving a
little bit and i believe the reason
that's happening is because of the
alignment on the picture that we have
here
so let's go in into my css.index over
here and
we're going to go and find that image
and this one is really on the
destination page
is the only one that i'm really worried
about where this is going to happen so
we have our destination grid container
with our picture so we're selecting it
there
and for this if you want to think of a
line of css that might fix this go ahead
and do it right now and then i'll look
at a solution in just a second
so we are on a grid and with grid items
are becoming stretched by default and
the way the picture works is the
pictures and so what i think all we need
to do actually here is an align
uh self of start
and i'm pretty sure if we do that and
they're all lined up at the start now
the image doesn't jump even if the
content becomes shorter and it was just
an issue of the grid getting too short
and because the grid was short because
the grid here has less lines like this
was stretching before and sort of trying
to fit into that space and now it just
lines up across the top on all the pages
so we don't get that jumping on we can
shrink our page down everything's
looking good we can still use our tab
system and everything's working fine
we can keep on going down and then we
get to the mobile sizes where everything
is still working so i think that looks
pretty awesome one thing you might
notice here is if we're at a smaller
screen size and it's going to be when
it's really on the border so maybe right
around here
notice how here between mars and the
moon it does jump a little bit because
there's with a scroll bar and without a
scroll bar if that drives you nuts and
you want to try and fix that there is a
new css property that has come out which
enables pages even when there is no
scroll bar to have some space that is
available on the sides to try and
prevent that type of content jumping
from going on and it's called scroll bar
gutter so actually it's just right here
really fast it would be on your html um
so it's called
so it's a scroll bar gutter like that
that's the name of the property i'd
encourage you to look it up and play
with it and see if you can get that to
solve this but this is one of those
types of things with dynamic content
that can happen where some pages are
longer and some are shorter and the
scroll bar gutter right now does not
have wide browser support um it wouldn't
break anything if you added it just
because browsers that do support it
which is chrome
it would work and then browsers that
don't support it it just wouldn't work
so they would get the old they would
just get this experience anyway so it's
not like it would just all of a sudden
cause the site to break so if you want
to look into scroll bar gutter you could
do that
the only other thing though that i do
want to fix is on this one with the
image that gets way too long which is
this one and it's kind of interesting
why that's happening and it just has to
come down to the native sizes of these
images being a little bit different and
ideally the grid would actually be a
little bit different because in front
end mentor you'll notice here he has a
lot less space he has a lot less space
than say these other guys so she's
actually pushed off a little bit more
he's taking up less space and this is
taking up way more than 50
of my grid like i have it set up now
like on these other ones that doesn't
really work
if you wanted to you could actually come
up with a unique grid for each one that
where the grid spacing becomes a little
bit different for this to work or you
might be able to find other solutions
including the potential of overlapping
content with the name where the name
would be allowed to sort of overlap but
i think you might run into more problems
than that could help but one thing we
can definitely do for something like
this is on our another destination page
we want to find our crew
grid
and we could redefine what the grid was
but actually you want to be really
careful with that if you want to
if we want to make that change just
because we'd want to first go into our
media query so let's find our original
one here where we're setting up this
grid
of having these different columns i'm
going to copy that same one and make
sure that i'm changing it based on this
and it's not my destination but it's
going to be my crew and i could come in
and change it here and instead of a
repeat and having the same thing for
both of them so we get rid of this in
the middle so we can come in with a
a min max here and we'll do a second one
min max here and for these they'll both
start with zero just like we had before
but before we had them both they were
adding up to 60 and we did a 30 30 we
can do a 40 ram on that side and a 20
ram on this side so we're just giving
this side a lot less space this one more
space and i do think that's actually
more true to what the design was in the
beginning anyway and so with that our
image has less room and our text has
more room so we have got the bonus of
the names actually not breaking and
going at large screen sizes at least not
breaking and going all the way across
now some of the images are getting a
little bit tiny so i do have a nice
little thing here but you'll also notice
that the text doesn't actually have
enough room and its alignment is a
little bit off so the same way that we
did a justify items and an align content
start here on our destination we could
use the same justify item start over on
this one here as well so right there we
can throw that and that would fix that
issue
and that means we wouldn't need this one
anymore so i'll delete that from there
and we can go take a look and now we see
everything is lined up nice and square
on that side but the image is definitely
looking like it's a little bit too small
because it is smaller maybe we'd be
comfortable bringing this back on and
maybe we wouldn't run into those issues
at larger screen sizes so i'll throw
that back on just in case we end up
wanting it but the image definitely
looks like it's getting too small so one
thing we could do is maybe this could be
like a 23 and this could be a 37 or you
could find a nice balance between them
that would give you enough space for
your text but there is one more thing
that'd be a little bit fun and it's
something that you could potentially use
when you get to your next pages because
you can see this guy is not looking too
bad maybe he could be a little bit
bigger and i will do two things because
they're a little bit smaller than i
thought they would be i'm going to take
this crew one off from here and we'll
just leave this one by itself
and then i'll actually we'll copy that
whole thing
and
right here it will work so here we can
just do the max width of 100
and that will help uh
increase it a little bit so we're
working with a little bit more space and
the destination i think the 90 worked
really well but here i think you can
agree that this is working better but
they're still
they're still not as big maybe as you'd
want them to be so i am going to show
you and again this is being limited by
the width that they have available to
them so this is something you could use
on the final page as well and actually
you'd have to use it on the final page
so it's a little bit of a hint that on
here we could say the grid column even
though it's on the grid area image we
can sort of cheat a little bit and say
there's a span too
and what that means is it's allowed to
break into the right side and it's
allowed to break into that final column
that we had and by doing that the images
are allowed to get a little bit bigger
than they were before and things start
coming together a little bit nicer and i
think that looks a little bit better um
maybe then we'd actually limit this down
back down to an 80 or a 90. pop that
back down to the 90 that we had but you
could find like a nice balance to try
and get it on and i don't think you'd
ever really run into any issues at
larger screen sizes
uh that that could pop up i think that
would actually work pretty well just
letting it bleed off into the right side
a little bit and so i'm actually pretty
happy with that i think it's a nice
little way we can cheat a little bit and
it's definitely something we could use
when we do our technology page which
i'll be talking about in the next lesson
all right so it's time for the
technology page which is an interesting
page there's a few little differences
with how the layout is working we have a
different type of component to do the
the tab system that we had before
obviously we have these images that
bleed out which i sort of talked about a
little bit in the last lesson and of
course we have the different ways of
laying it all out through the different
screen sizes but very importantly
you are on your own for this one i am
not holding your hand i'm not walking
you through the process anymore while
there are a few differences with certain
things that we just saw and there's some
new parts that you'll have to build out
outer style you have learned everything
you need to get this done i've been
trying to challenge you along the way up
until now as much as possible a lot of
you i'm sure we're killing it and doing
those challenges whether it was the
really big things or just the little
questions i had here or there but at one
point i do need to let go and let you
figure things out on your own if you
really want to reinforce everything
you've learned and whether you've been
doing all those little challenges take
all of what you've learned and apply it
now and if you haven't been doing them
it's even doubly important because
watching something and understanding it
is very different from being able to
apply it yourself so i really hope you
enjoyed following along with me up until
now i've really enjoyed it but now it is
your turn to go and make those pages
happen once you finish the page make
sure that you post it and let us know
about it if you're posting over on
twitter make sure you mention me scrimba
and front-end mentor to show us how you
finish things up i really hope that
you've enjoyed this course i've really
enjoyed giving it i really enjoyed
building out this layout it was a lot of
fun and so i'm looking forward to seeing
how you finish it up and the
improvements you can make to it from
where i've left you right here